Bruh.
Everything is breaking right now. Holy crap. Everything has broken.
I can't even hear in-game sound. I'm pretty sure I'm supposed to be here in the music
right now. Hold on. I'm so sorry. Everything broke from yesterday.
My headset isn't registering sound at all. I knew it wasn't. You're lying to me!
Ugh, the scuff isn't- Oh here we go.
I just heard the test of some music. Okay. I can now hear the title of music? Yes, I can.
And you can hear it too. I don't know how loud it's going to be though. Oh my god. Anything
that can break will. I didn't change a single thing from yesterday's drum.
Ugh. I apologize for being late, little refunds. That was horrific. I haven't even been able
to watch yesterday's words. I know the next stream is starting. However, I meant to keep
up with your strawney. That's the fun part. I have endless stamina.
See? Those details come really good later on. Right. I don't- I need to- I made- I'll tell
you what world we're in. Right now I'm entering world 424. But I- I want tutorial island.
So please don't worry. What was that first song? It was called music makes you lose control.
Music makes you lose control. Let's go. Please don't worry if you've not actually got your
character outside. Good ol' Lummi Castle, Lumbridge Castle. I've not even done the tutorial
part. I do- I'm playing with a plugin called Runelight. But we're just going through tutorial
island super quick. I'm not- Oh no, I just liked it a brand new. Oh, we're doing an
in-depth in tutorial island then. Ah. Ah. I've actually been smart and I've prepared
a whole meal. It was absolutely chaos getting- I was trying to get Runelight to work on screen
and I was trying to cook fricking my- well, technically my breakfast, but I call it dinner.
And I actually have like the world's saddest fricking rose- I think it's called like
rosemary sauce when you have it with shrimp. And- ah. So, I do have membership. As isn't
the finalised world, please, I've not even got through the tutorial. Right, let me just
skip through this fricking tutorial. Ah, my phone's in the way. Oh my god, no, I can't
skip this. This is going to take so long. Oh my- yes, we'll talk to the survival specialist.
Look, that's what I'm eating right now. I- I'm ironically eating that right now. I'm
good. Wait a minute, this game's based on real life. How cool is that? We're going fishing.
Would you fish me up? Huh? Huh? But anyway, good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
I apologize, it's been fricking chaos. Thank you. And no way. Thank you for the tip, Virginia.
There's no way. Literally. Oh, ace of cullin' snow bears in as well. Thank you for the tip.
I'm about to munch on- I've got baked pate, aw. Right, and then I've got shrimp, and then
I've got a rose-ass aw, so I've not made it correctly because I didn't fricking squeeze
the water out of the prawns. Hi, ready? Hi, ready? Hi, acey and snowberry readers. But
if you put all those words together, it becomes ready. Are you squidding me right now?
Strony, you're eating marshmallows last night inspired me to try to write something
to make your heart flutter because I think it's adorable. Are you going to read more
tonight? I can definitely read more. Thank you very much, Grimbo, for the tip. Yeah, I
can definitely read more. Oh, I'm sorry to- I'm trying to eat and eat and wait and do
everything all at once. Hi, we're playing RuneScape, an old-school RuneScape. We're going
to play multiplayer and do quests together. I am called Scottlefish because I totally
did not steal that from a roofling. Thank you very much. But yeah, we're going to do
good. I am not- I'm going to move to a free world, but if you want to make a new account,
we are going to do the free quests like Cook's Assistant and that, where the heck am I supposed
to go? I don't know. I'm not paying attention. Now that you have logged, it's time to light
fire. Oh, okay. Pardon me. Pardon me. Excuse me. I'm going to take a bite. Ah. Hi, Stromboni.
I've got a nickname. I'm not sure I know that. See? So, I've got this plug-in called RuneLight
and it's really good. I think it's really good. If the game needs to be louder, please
do tell me. I actually think it does need to be louder. So, I'm like, screaming over
all the things. What next? Moving on. Well done. Moving on. Moving on. Moving on. I've
completely forgotten how the tutorial goes because it's been so long. I'm going to take
another bite of my food. But yeah, if you want to join in, don't worry. You can literally
make a character right now and be faster than me. I will tell you what world we're on. We're
all going to meet outside of Lumbridge Castle. So, whenever what world we'll get, we will
do a Chicky Lumbridge Castle. Yeah. And then we'll take it one by one and we'll quest.
We're going to start with Cook's assistant because obviously this is a bit squished.
And my goal is to get 99 cooking live. Like, not in this one stream, okay? Not in this
one stream. Whoa, whoa, whoa. I don't know how to do that. Although, I think if fletching,
if you have like a ton of GP, you can actually get 99 fletching in one day or something like
that. I can't remember. I think it's fletching. You can kind of smurf it, smurf it with cheese
a bit. All in one stream, crazy. No, no, stop getting hype. It's not happening in one stream.
Okay, quest journal. Yep, we are going to do the free quest first as best as we can.
And then we might move on to membership quest, but I do want to give
Refling the chance to come hang at Lummi Castle, the glum castle. Any, any lumbers? Any hashtag
I'm taking a little bit. It's super expensive for a member. Yeah, it's really expensive actually
to do the thing. But membership in this game is so expensive. I remember I asked my mum
to buy me membership when I was a wane. And it was like cheap as anything. And she never got me
out because she didn't understand what the game was. And she's like, why do you need it? Why do
I need it? I'm like, mum, I want membership. Ryan. Stay awake from last stream. Let's see if I can
make it to the ASMR stream. No way. Are you, you must have been so many iron reaper that I managed
to get an eight hour sleep after that stream. I don't know how long the endurance stream,
it was like three quid the last time I got it. Honestly, I remember like begging my mum. I was like,
mum, I want, I want membership. But she never understood my games. And then that's when I go
to dad. See, dad, dad knew, dad knew what was going on. He knew the games. I'm like, dad, what
we're doing? I'm not talking, I'm right. Hello, my name is Scottlefish. I still live. I usually
only sleep four or five. Are you guys all insomniacs? I got four hours. Good enough for me. Bro, that's
not healthy. Honestly, I felt, I woke up and I felt sick today. And I was like, is that because
you, you will be told to equip items later. You don't have access to the interface for equipment items.
Oh, okay. One more. Thank you. Right, shovel on note. Okay. Are you squidding me right now? Ryan.
Strani is going all weekend for the 99 cooking. She never burns out. She only burns
I actually quite like that. Thank you, Tim. Shuttle. I think Tim shuttles the way I'm supposed
to say it because there's no way it's like any other way. Right, let's go combat interface. Right.
Yes, yes, yes, yes. Oh, beautiful. Let's stab. Give him a little stabby stab. Stab them rats.
All right, hold on. Hold on. Nope. Too far. Too far. Inbought, inbought. I,
whenever I watch RuneScape streamers, they're always like super zoomed in. They're like, oh,
yeah, look at that. And I'm like, bro, I need to be able to see what I'm looking at. Like,
I can see the health bar. I can see everything. I'm not saying anything up before anyone complains.
Chat sleep. Chat needs to rest as much as me. I've got absolutely no sleep at all. Are you
all insomniacs? You're all literally all holding on for the ASMR stream. I'm getting my nails done
after the ASMR stream. So hope you're ready. Wait, what am I supposed to do? Oh, no, wait,
sorry. I'm supposed to do range weaponry. Can I do it from through the gate? Oh, I can.
Didn't realize old school room shape. Oh, didn't realize old school RuneScape membership is 89.
No, bro. The inflation has hands. I'm sorry, but all these things being like, oh, no, cost 11.
Well, you're not employing your pay. You're not paying your employees more. So I don't know why we're
pretending the cost of living is a thing for these companies. I said also. You're doing your nails
for the sweet eating stream. Yeah. How else are you gonna, you know, to my hands? You need to be
able to imagine my hand wrapped around. And that's terrible. We're just started. I would do a lot of
food filming. Oh my God, I'm rich. We're rich. I've got 25 coins. Are you squeezing me right now?
Brian. You guys have been somnia said the Scottish madness streaming assassins creed
for a combined 20 hours within the span of 36 hours. That's because I had problems sleeping.
Thank you for the tip, Tharya. Oh my God. Right. So you can do voting like if you're like hardcore.
Well, it's not really actually, but it's actually quite quick to get that. Oh, I've just skipped
past the bit that tells you. Oh, what should we vote on? Should fire light a new level 77 demon
bro. I have not. Whoa. These are like the same question, but different. I have not.
I have not played enough runescape. I'm like the basic runescape for it. Okay. Before you think
I'm going to start getting prayer pots out, I'm going to start a what is it called like pk in.
No, I'm not pk in. I'm not doing that. I'm not happening. No, I'm called Scottish. I've got
membership 30 days left. Oh, no, you can't see it because I'm a big ass. Hey, I'm grabbing the view.
What world? Okay. Worlds can hold 2000 members. Okay. We're very lucky, but I don't think there's
2000 recently available to stream snip. So the good thing, oh God, it's probably a bit too heavy.
Please don't show my email and password. That would kind of suck. But then again, let's just throw
this on the way to victory to victory to victory. I'm on the way to victory. So into the church,
I go. Hello, Mr. Hello, Mr. Brace. Any bracers was pking player killing. It's when you attack
players and you sell the goods that they drop basically. But before anyone thinks I'm going
to turn into a pk. Yeah, good luck, mate. That's what happens. I'm doing this tutorial right now.
I'm going to eat my food outside a lumbridge so everyone can get a chance to group up if you
want to start on a new count of Hingo questing together. So please don't panic. If you think,
like, oh, no, I'm not going to have enough time to join in, you absolutely do. I am going to
make it so I eat my foodies. I've got a cola and two bottles of water with me.
Um, as for those of you interested is if this is a and
Oh, where the heck am I supposed to go? It's not blinking anything.
Grabbing the boo. You will be shown how to cast spells when you get there. Just talk to the
magic and assume you can hear them. Oh, of course it pops up. What are we doing? I'll hop on.
We're going to just do basic questing because I've started a fresh account
and we're going to try and get 99 Kooten. However, open up your final menu. Ah, am I done?
Okay, not yet. We're about to teleport to Lummi and then I'll pick a free to play server.
And oh my god, I'm casting the chicken.
You wouldn't cast the chicken, would you? Would you? Who goes there?
Everyone has someone you trust to lure into the world.
Can I? I'm so sorry, but I'm going to confess my biggest sin and you guys honestly aren't ready
for it. I used to be double in money and take people's money. The biggest amount I ever took
was 100 K gold and then I stopped. I don't know how I didn't get banned. I think because I did it
in such low increments. Send me to the mainland. I was so sorry. I used to be the one at the
Grand Exchange. I was like a little kid because what happened was I got freaking scammed. He's
got a fish. Come over here, adventurer John. I got scammed and then I realized, wait, I can just
scam other people to get my money back. Doubling gold, doubling gold. And I'm like, I got all the
money I lost back. It's time. Officers, it's her. Literally, I was like a little nine-year-old hustler.
Like, oh, it's terrible. So if you ever got done at the Grand Exchange because you were a silly,
silly McGee, guess what? It was probably me. We're going to hang out at this fountain at
Lummi Castle right here. We're going to hang out at the little fountain. I am going to Swap World.
Wait, why is it flashing? It might be flashing. Right, what world are we going to go to?
I'll make it a free-to-play world. Whoa. Oh, wait, wait, wait. I think World Shifter's up here.
Okay, um, free-to-play trade. No, it's got 900 people in it already. Do we want free-to-play trade?
There's 900 people in it. Jagex is watching you now. They better not be. I'm in trouble.
We're going to hang out at Lumbridge Castle for until I've finished my dinner and I'm trying to
eat it on my breakfast. What world do we want? Free-to-play is good. Right, we'll just do the
classic free-to-play trade-free world 301. There's 900 folk in it, so we've got all the room in the
world. Take me, are you sure you wish to go to World 301? Yes, sir. Let's cycle.
Okay, I don't know where the heck the reef ones are, so we'll come a little over to the fountain.
Oh no, what are they use? I don't know. We might need to, I don't know, I think publish out.
I don't want, are these reeflings in game? Wait, wait, wait, we're going to go over to the tree
to make sure these are reeflings. Holy crap, are they? Brian! Good evening, Strony and reeflings,
have fun on the RuneScape grind. Evening Alessandro, thank you for the tip. Oh my god, they're reeflings!
Oh my god, who are you? Oh, you're looking at, oh my god, wait, you guys are actual, some of
your actual players though. Oh, why are you so high level? Oh, oh, someone's called Tiny Cuttles,
that's funny. Wait, you guys are like actual, I missed one, that was such a good name. Oh my god,
just yummy. Hello, hello. Oh my god, you guys are like actual skillers and stuff.
Good morning, reeflings, they're saying, oh, that's crazy. Strony's surprised to chat our gamers.
I don't, but I didn't know if you guys were going, oh my god, you stole my drip,
you look like me. Oh, you guys, you get stood on. I see a Strony. You guys are like so high level,
that's amazing. You guys should probably teach me how to play the game. Unfortunately, we can't,
what is that? Why is he standing like that? What does it mean? Am I to rate him like a pony?
Oh, the guy's got the magma cape. I've never done the magma cape before. I have a stupid snowflake
account, so I won't join. What does that mean? I have a snowflake account. Steals her legs,
snowflake by the way. What does that mean? Oh my god, look at your fit, your fit's so unique.
You're holding a puppy, and you've got like little things going on on you. Right, a lot of
your like, over leveled like heck, what is this in his hand? Is that me in his hand? Oh, why is
your name that? Oh no, why would you rename yourself? Oh no. Check or treat, let me type.
Treat. I don't think I get, we want to see what you got, Sans. Shows what you got was to eat my
dinner. Where did he go? Wait, did he just disappear because I looked down for one second?
It says you guys want to trade me, but I don't think I can trade because I'm a new account.
I don't think it works. I think I need to go quest and to like unlock trade if you guys
want to give me anything. Is it in the stream to treat? Yeah, like I don't think you guys can
trade me anything. So don't worry, we're gonna go quest them. RIP, yeah. Wait, I'm getting the fish.
There's so many replays. Hello replays. Thank you everyone that can join. Hey, yo,
we're deforestation out here. Oh, they leveled up. Let's go. Okay. Trick it is, geez. Yeah, look,
accept trade. I don't think you can trade because I'm a new, new, new account. What? Are you giving me
a rope and a fish? Are you telling me? Are you doing that? Should you be tweeting? No way,
you could trade that. No way, I have a freaking rope in my inventory right now.
Wait, can you only give me like World 301? Yeah, this world is full sad. Why?
Oh, the world is full? Okay, wait, wait, hold on. Right, we're gonna move to,
we're not doing, I don't know what these are. The regular bought items can't be traded. Okay,
we're learning. Right, the world is full, so we're gonna go to an emptier one.
Everyone get ready. High risk world. Yeah, no, thanks. Have a bow.
Is there like a really easy one we can get inside?
Clan Wars? I don't know. Do we get grouped on? Are we technically a clan? No.
These are just dead Oz servers, apparently. Are these American?
380, someone says 380. Hold on, 380, 380. Right, World 380. And we're going to Brit Bungland.
Right, let's go 380. World 380. Wait, I'm double clicking. Let me go. 380.
Grand exchanges limited to until you do quests or play for a while. Yeah.
Now you have, now you have a fish. You're canonically strong. Okay, okay. Oh, look at everything.
Okay, World 380. How do you dance? Oh my God, it's been so long. How do you dance? I want to dance too.
I can dance. I'm sure I can dance. Hold on. Hey, let's go. Hey, grind. Oh, you know,
we'll dance. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, man. Look at that. Look at that. Look at that. What, what, what?
Oh, I'm, I'm stunning on them. I'm stunning on them. Look at them dance. Whoa, what the,
what in the pivot axis was that? That was awful. Don't ever do that again. Right, we're clapping.
Okay, now that's honestly grand exchanges limited to. That's not a clan. That's an army. Oh, yeah.
We'll be, we'll be do the refland clan and we'll go PK and like other clans or something. As if I
know how the combat works. This, this only world where the text matters is PvP, high risk, total and
demo. Right, are we ready to do the first official quest or I say that as if I've even hardly eaten
any of my dinner. Hold on. I'm trying to eat, but I'm such a blabbermouth. Honestly, I can't stop.
I'm glad the refunds aren't stacking in the one space. I strongly can appreciate them each. Yeah.
Hmm. I was still, I'm convinced that guy wants me to write them because he's like a horse, literally.
I'm so cute. Still got people doing tutorial. Yeah. Don't worry if you're still doing tutorial island.
I'm going to inhale my dinner really quickly. I'm going to try my best. What is that noise?
You're all making noises. I'm driving the booze. I'm still trying to log in.
You're not giving people time to do the tutorial. Only the players play some of their games.
How many are there? Oh my god. Oh, that's just an NBC hand. Oh, someone just leveled up.
Look at her high level you guys are.
I literally got the pepper, the frog over there.
I love mommy. Oh my god.
You guys are like actual gamers. Oh my god. It's much better than me.
I'm like scared to play the game and I'm like, you guys are all going to show me out.
Quality players determined by their agility and rune crafting level. Yeah. Yeah. No one likes
rune crafting. You're not selling it here. Get your propagandas useless out of here because you're
not rune crafting is the worst. Unless you literally have an entire army behind you to help.
At the end of the stream, you'll be that high level. I think not.
Yeah. Agility 89. You're really good at going in a circle then.
Jeez. My brother was a Rinscape essence slaver for years. Do you pay to like carry the thing?
Just don't please tell me. Banks are for squares. Are you an iron man?
Oh, so there's different types of players you can be. If you're iron man,
it means you don't have access to bank or something like that.
Guardians of the Rift is experience. It's awesome experience.
So will this be a 28 hour marathon? No, no, I don't think it's a marathon. I said yesterday,
I thought it was a marathon, but I woke up and I don't actually feel that well today.
I can't believe it. I can't believe streaming for 12 hours making me feel a bit wonky,
but I don't know why because essentially I would sit at the PC and work on like
Eden for like ASMR or something like that. But why is it when a streamer feels sick?
Like it doesn't make sense. Feel weekend stream height, honestly.
Free cuttlefish mustache right here. That's awful. Oh, how did you...
What? Are you just cuttlefish right in front of us? I didn't know Rinscape had emotes like this.
More active for streaming. Maybe because you did it three times this week.
Me? Isn't every strong stream technically a marathon, honestly?
Damn, how does one become an essence run slave? That's good money for that, I worry.
The members emotes go hard. Strong party. Heck yeah.
There's so many reflings. The servers are like who on earth are all these people? D-Refling.
I'll read out your name if it's refling related, but I'll try not to accidentally say anything.
Who is leveling up there? Freakin... I can hear someone leveling up, but it's always going...
Hello? Jack the Ripper's coming to get us lads we're done for. Maybe it was your screaming
yesterday, bro. I was so annoyed. I listened back. I didn't realise how angry I got. Like I got angry.
It's a scale cape or more? Oh my god, he's got the fishing scale cape.
Oh, je comprends, je comprends, wee wee. What is this freaking UFO over here? What is that?
Oh, is that prey? Is that questing? You've done all quests. Oh, you've got all the jelly.
Oh my god. Wait, what's the cooking one? Does anyone have 99 cookies? What's the cooking of more?
I can't wait to get it.
Oh, look at us all. Well, bing-ching-ing, d'enjouement, bing-ching-ing.
How do I change servers? I'm on the runelight, so it's plug-in, so it's up here,
but if you're not on the runelight plug-in, it's down the bottom somewhere. Smile.
It's on the cog, I think. I have two baked potatoes. I've not even finished the first one,
and it's freaking totey. Like it's so small. I'm trying so I can't eat and talk and be entertained
at the same time. Quest cape, quest cape. Ah. Max cape is shaming us all. Click the top right
X, then you'll see worlds switcher on the bottom. The door icon to hop worlds is what they're saying.
Refillings are so MLG pro, honestly. Like, we're not even gaking them.
Oh, you're so green. This refillings, like, literally so green.
That's amazing. Maybe we should...
Amala to tell us to all go buy green capes for scrawny. And then we all just walk around
with green capes, and like whenever we pass someone, they'll be like,
huh, what's going on over there? Why are they all doing their thing?
Wishes to trade with you, so I can't accept anything outside of, like, regular trades.
You get... you're giving me your Krusty cum sock. No! No way! I have a Krusty cum sock in my inventory.
How did you even get that?
All right. Gently used. Literally gently used. Right. I'm gonna eat. I'm gonna save maybe a
five minute countdown, and then we're gonna start with Cook's insistent, and we'll take it from there.
So for those of you who haven't made an account, we are on World 380. And we're outside Lung Bridge
Castle. When you spawn in, we are literally just... you'll spawn in this way, and you've got...
we're the left of the castle. We're just hanging out here, because we don't want to bother anyone
that might be spawning in over here. But scrawny, the character has pink hair. Or am I seeing pink?
Main has ginger hair. Like, I'm a junior.
Which thing? And then I've got green top, and then pink, uh, thingy. Prepared to get...
Billied nerds!
I'm trying to eat so fast. It's hard, honestly.
But I hope you guys have got hydration and eating. I don't know if it's an endurance stream yet.
Okay, but I have.
Ginger hair, cute outfit, and a rope. Yeah, yeah. You can get me.
380, yeah, 380. The refling in the game, of course, is gonna be...
Don't stop until you get 99.
Bro, you think I can stream until 99, Cookin'? I don't even know how to, like,
maximise Cookin'. The closest I ever got was, like, 80, but I'd rather do it live with you guys.
Buying girlfriend 50 gold. What happened to party hats? I remember people were, like,
renting party hats in quotation marks. I don't know what that means at all.
Delicious coke. I say delicious as if it's just not a regular fizzy juice.
Well, actually, it's, like, one of the most popular fizzy juices, so...
They decided not to have exclusive one-time items. Oh, even though they're tradable?
I guess they didn't, like, give enough out? Possible?
They can... they became common. Oh! They made it common.
You go to a good place for Cookin', and you cook till the number says 99,
or you run out of money with some of the fish. Okay, you're done.
Oh, people are getting, uh, minigames.
I was, like, I'm saying, come along with me, Miss... I miss Fauna. Wacky wacky, I miss Fauna.
Max Capers. How much playtime? 232 days says one. 314 says another.
I can't believe my little... my little reeflings are adorable little nerds!
I can't believe it! You can do just a feckin' adorable! Yeah, you like ringskates.
That's so precious. I'm glad you found a game that you really enjoy and can, uh,
throw yourself inside. It's... when you find that game, it's really nice.
Anyway, Assassin's Creed Brotherhood, let's get started.
Okay.
Yesterday, Avatar, No Capitalist Simulator. This is all really a trust.
Someone says 63 days, and I haven't even left this area.
Uh, someone says 1650 hours for a total of 1,800... I can't read numbers.
Big number. Big hours for big number. Thank you.
Hmm.
Oh, more reeflings?
Have we got more reeflings joining us? Yeah. Someone's got... oh, someone literally
is called Sway Sok.
A snowflake among snowflakes. Wait, what am I missing? What is this? Is this like super
RuneScape terms I don't know about yet? Or is this literally, uh, take the word heart
and remove the H and replace... remove the H and E and replace it with an F.
Relax. Snowflake is called Dark Humour. Is that the joke or am I missing that one?
Respect for the Iron Man.
Snowflake accounts are accounts that have extremely restrictive stipulations.
What does that even mean? You've somehow... you can't... Snowflake is a special account.
Wait, the Venezuelans are the snowflakes?
Game is not DJing enough. We need to make it harder. What the heck?
I think the skull and crossbones means this guy's a p-care over here. I'm okay.
Can only do content in a region.
Jeez. One guy's playing the game where if he takes damage, all... Oh, I know!
Uh, the Swamplatex guy. Yeah. I've not actually watched that series.
The No Hits run series, but yeah. Region locked. Oh, settled. That's his name, not Swamplatex.
I have still not finished the first fucking potato. I'm actually getting annoyed now.
Why is the food not getting away off my plate?
I'm inhaling it. I'm so sorry. I'm just gonna have to send it.
I can't. I'm getting too distracted trying to, like, talk into the...
I'm sending it. This is the fastest freaking eating you'll ever hear of me.
I've caught another bit of potato. I've never done this.
And, um... Okay, I've had enough of eating. I'm already bored of it.
I should weigh myself, honestly, just so I don't lose too much weight.
Because I stream too much. I was actually wondering about that because I've not had a proper meal.
I'm, like, ages out. I'll cut, I'll cut, I'll cut. Done.
I can't give life of a fucking plate. I've tried to eat it. It's taken too long. Right.
Okay. I was trying to eat a baked potato in prawns, and it was just taken forever.
Oh, I've had enough. Right. Is this everyone who wants to show up?
Can chat, talk to me, and tell me, is everyone here that wants to be here?
Talking with your mouth full, ASMR is trying to really...
It's fine. It's stop. If that counts as ASMR, then I've got a ton of content for you.
Okay. Is everyone who wants to be questing, is in the game right now?
Is anyone in Tutorial Island? Someone says they're late.
Okay, we'll wait. We'll wait. We'll get a few more minutes.
Right. If we've got a few more minutes, it's time to start telling jokes.
Why did Ernest the Chicken cross the road to get to the other side?
Oh, thank you. Thank you. If you didn't know, there's a quest called Ernest the Chicken. Thank you.
I feel your pain. Yes. Do re-log in on your questing account to render the other side.
I'm here. I've never opened this game before. Okay. We'll stand outside the castle this time.
We're just going to be right outside the castle.
If you want to start on a new quest on the account just to have the shiz and giggles,
we are going to do a main quest. Oh my god, there's so many reflings.
Like, oh, it's over. Thank you so much for joining me and being the law. I'm like so fucking happy.
Like, I don't realize I'm like, oh my god, that's a lot of this playing.
Right. Don't forget the riveting tail of lily pad labor dispute, honestly. I'm done for some shingles.
Okay. Why is his name Ernest? I honestly didn't know. I can't even remember. I hardly remember.
I'm here, but I've never opened this game before. What world? I am on world 388.
Um, the mods have pinning. Can mods pin world 388?
Free questing. I might work some unable to participate, but have fun surrounding reflings.
Oh, thank you. We will. We will. I don't think mods can pin. Okay. Can I pin? Can I pin? Hold on.
Ow, I don't know. Where's YouTube? Can you open up one stream? Strony cartels.
Tape it in. Oh, I'm live. I'm live right now. Tape it in. Oh my gosh, I'm live right now.
Pin message. There we go.
Strony, after the bloke completion, what do you think about the bad jokes
completion? Honestly, we should. Wish us to trade. I'll take anything. I've got a
crusty sock in my inventory right now. Oh, should I? You're giving me a chef's hat because I want
cooking. Yes. Yes. Put the hat on me. Please, please, please, please, please, please. I want
the hat. I want the hat. I want the hat. I want the hat. Oh, check it out. You can even see my
bunches around. Oh, look at it. Oh, thank you so much. Look at the hat. Oh my God. Check it. Check
it. Check out the drip lads. Yeah. Yeah, I'll show you. Check it out. Oh, I'm going to, I'm going
to stale on them. You ready? We're going to stale on them. I got that stale. Stale, stale, stale.
Put it away, put it away, put it away. Level one cooking. Level nine, nine cooking. Here we go.
It's everyone here that would like to be here.
I drink the thingy. Is she cooking? Very snazzy. Drop check. Certified cooking stream. Okay.
First quest. Open up our little quest adventure menu where the heck is that? I can't see because
iPhone's in the way. Excuse me, iPhone. I'm here to do something. Right, the quest is called
Cook's Assistant. Oh, oh, here it is. I'll read it out for you as for those who use it
are blind. Cook's Assistant. I can start this quest by talking to the Cook Lumberge Castle.
Difficulty, novice. Very short. Release 2001. Jeez. Storyline. Stand alone. No requirements
and no, no. Wait, someone else wishes to trade. I don't, you guys can't give me like main stuff,
I am. I'm gonna head to bed early and I'll use the stream as a sleep bed. I hope I don't wake you.
No way, I've got a penny. No, I have a penny as well. Oh my god. Wait, wait, sorry. Hold on.
Sorry, camera angle. Oh my god. I'm a real freaking woman. Oh, let's go. I look so good.
Thank you for the penny. Thank you for the chess hat. If you want to gift you games,
how do we do that? You don't. I buy them with my hard earned cash. Cold hard cash. Right,
let's go Cook's Assistant. I'll turn off running. We'll just walk. Right, you ready? Oh, Lumberge
Castle, do you mind? I don't want to. Come, reflings. You can follow me if you want. Ah,
wait, who are we fighting? Why are you fighting that per man? Right, oh my god, women's simulator.
Time to head to the kitchen. Oh my god, there's so many of them. Right, this Cook is like,
why are all you people in my kitchen right now? All right, yes, Cook. What's wrong, Mr. Cook?
Oh dear, oh dear, oh dear. I'm in terrible trouble with Miss. It's the Duke's birthday the day
and I should be making him a big, lovely birthday cake. I've forgotten to buy the ingredients.
I'll never get them now. He'll sack me. What will I do? I have four children and I go
to look after. Honestly, me with the... What? I have five babies, but one of them is a goat.
He has four babies and a goat. What are the odds? Yes, we're going to help Cook's Assistant. Yes,
I'll help you. Oh great. Oh, my little quest helper just popped up. Where do I find these
ingredients? Uh, I think I remember where they are, so I think we can just walk away.
Do I need to pick up a pit? I think... Do we need this jug? Wait, are we all going to be fighting
over the same jug? Do we not need a jug for this quest to put the milk in? Save yourself and run,
buy eggs here. 100 cold coins, sell an egg. No, do we not have to pick up the big egg and like the
milk from the dairy? Oh, am I going crazy? Isn't that like one special big egg and one special?
I've got 25, best I can offer. Real cheap.
People are thinking you are doing a drop party or something. All the folk following. Oh, no idea.
I'm like, yo, you guys have money? I can go get some jugs and drop them. Man's running a scheme. I
respect it, honestly. Are you guys grabbing all his equipment? Okay, right. We can take off and
get the egg, so we'll go to the front of the castello. If everyone has accepted that quest,
we'll go to the front. I think they changed it. Okay, right. Oh, no. It does look like we're a drop
party. I'm broke, so I can't afford any eggs. Don't worry, I'm going to take you to the egg factory.
It's me. Plop, plop, plop, plop, plop, plop. Okay. Oh my God, we like a drop party so badly.
Right, I'm pretty sure you get eggs across the river. Chickens aren't going to stand a chance.
Yeah, so the cow milk and the eggs are across the river. If you follow me, oh my God,
strontilates eggs? I was going to do ovate deposit. I might even pretend otherwise.
We call these people hurt in the jaw flings. We're going to milk a cow. Milk the cow.
Milk the cow. We need it straight from the teeth, you know?
A normal egg works just fine. Yes. Has YouTube ceased the culling? I think so.
We actually are submitting for monetization today. Can I milk your cow or do I need a bucket?
Oh, I milked it. But that's because I had a jug. Wait, did I milk it or am I going crazy?
She goes, Teehee, you've never milked a cow before. How could you tell?
Because you're spilling milk. What a waste. You need something to hold the milk. Oh,
oh no. Oh no. Where'd you get a bucket in this game? Right, we'll go get the eggs then.
Eggs first. We'll deal with a bucket problem in a minute. Buckets are from the tutorial.
Worked for me. I don't have a bucket. Oh no, I already have a bucket of milk. What the heck?
I already have a bucket. I've already got a bucket of milk in my inventory. I don't know why she
said that to me. Cheeky rat, honestly. Right, egg time. Egg time. We go get the eggies.
We go get the eggies. That's the only thing about the RuneScape plugin. I can see the price of
everything. You guys want to watch me beat up a chicken? That's right. Violence! Violence!
Rage against the machine. Oh, I just killed it with Kung Fu. That's right. And I know three
other dangerous ones. I didn't drop an egg. All right, okay. Just let's all beat up the chickens
and get eggs. Beat the chickens up. We're going to gang violence these chickens. Literally,
the whole gang of us coming in. Someone's casting Shadow Wizard Money Gang. We love casting spells
on egg chickens. Oh my god, there's like so much. It's just hard to see anything. Oh my god,
I need to like zoom right in. Beat that chicken up. No, you stole my chicken. Wait, I'm going to take
this egg. Right, I have an egg. I have an egg, so I'm going to stand here because I've got one. But
make sure you get an egg before you move away from the section. Have a good day starting. I will.
If you have an egg and you have milk, you're allowed to stand at the gate with me.
Oh, be them. They're level one. Show them who's boss. The greatie, hidden the greatie.
Sounds again to get into the game wizard. Do we need caps? Or are we nob本ies redancing
there it's a chicken massacre this date will go down in history as the chicken
I he jumped in for joy or is he jumping for joy I made it to where you are said
hi and left oh do you need go work show that chicken with boss be more be more
right oh no the gates close sorry we need to open the gate to let the
refunds come in and out there they're a bit slow like me how many so I think
we've still got a few refunds behind that are getting eggs he had got a few
stragglers that's okay that's okay you guys gonna get them eggs jugs ahead hey
yo oh you dropped to jugs oh for the refunds that skip tutorial island there's
a bucket in the house by the way got a few more oh his heads just straight up
off okay I didn't even know runescape did cosmetics like this I guess cuz I've
runescape three cosmetics like this I've got egg and milk good good that's what
be that in pop gang violence on that and be a be that in pop that's what you get
that's what you get for coming around these parts when we're doing cooks
assistant is there any more stragglers or is that everyone these I think these
are just actual I can't believe it I think these are just actual players
it's all my reflings is anyone behind I don't think anyone's behind it I need
head oh I shouldn't you're playing your level three you might be everything
that's coming along I love woman right I think that's everyone okay next we need
to go to the flower mill we are gonna cross this lovely little bridge okay
you're welcome to follow if you click on me you could follow and you don't even
have to do a thing I'll take charge we don't take that can be arranged there is
another chicken pan near the windmill oh I didn't realize oh no he got caught in
the bridge I'm sorry she doesn't know the bridge lore it's an evil bridge is it
oh no we are walking and the windmills up here oh there is a chicken farm
outside the windmill but crap by myself I couldn't make a new camp but my
can't stop pretty fish what you never done cookies system before we like it
when you take charge story did you like my post yesterday I was actually kind of
hard to shove together we're gonna grab some of these I have I just real
playing them doing it yeah it was amazing would love to join but jog eggs
locked your account well thankfully there are gonna be more multiplayer right
everyone pick up some wheat yankers make sure you got one bit of wheat go on
reeflings I will teach you the how good it is to look at all harvested oh my god
I've got you use look like slaves oh no this isn't good you really come like
running some sort of like a factory or something is everyone got a bit of
flour are we a wee bit of grain or wheat it does not look good that does not look
good honestly instead of a like people are like no no reflect no no you know
let's say I read that in game oh close the door on the reefing who did that
right everyone climb the ladder we need to go up to the top we are not a cult we
promise literally people thinking it's a drop party and we're all just like
harvesting right drop your wheat into the hopper and then you pull on the lever
at the top of this wait are we pulling it for each other okay I think that I
think it's still instance yeah okay and then if we go down to the bottom yeah it's
waiting for us and now we have everything we need wait wasn't the point to
have an army of sleigh oh why do you walk like that that's actually really
freaky I'm sorry but why do you walk like that honestly is that like a thing
why do you walk like that oh that's so creepy I don't like it it feels like
something that's changed like chasing yeah wrong lever crank how do you increase
render distance I can't see anything I have no idea I'm using runelite plug-in
so I can see like this far but I don't need to like focus on this really wait do
we need to pay the sleigh to be slaves no we do it for free I think to the he
wants you to mount him ah he's scary it's thanks to the banana they're wielding
the banana makes your legs open up oh okay okay when I said it out loud it
makes sense that his legs do that is everyone got their weight I think so
there's slaves and then there's like I think everyone's got their weight just
they make sure all the reeflings are following yeah okay we're gonna make it
back to the castello
you're strong independent man cha
when do you drown them in the sea I don't want to do that I know it's a part of
my lore we are weed oh it's not another word that sounds the same we I'd like to
harvest some wheat I'm gonna smoke some wheat
when you're drowning we should go port sarum invade the sea shanty at some
point yeah we should but we'll literally just blast the music on full she's taking
them to the river I know we're going to the Castello to hand in the quest item
I'm not only strong but I'm also fat and ugly hell yeah we are not a hive mind I
promise what is that what is that what is that cosmetic what is on your heat you
look bizarre right everyone let's totally not freak out unfortunately corners are a
bit rough for the follow mechanic so you might get caught in a corner it's very
plausible here's the a bunch a bucket of milk here's a pot of flour and here's
some fresh eggs oh you've brought me everything I need I'm saved thank you so
did I get to go to the juke's party I'm afraid not only the big cheeses get to
dine with the juke well maybe one day I'll be important enough to sit on the
juke's table maybe but I wouldn't be holding my breath oh steady on
let's go congratulations you have completed Cook's assistant you are
awarded one quest point and 300 cooking XP total quest points one oh we're
actually we are so MLG we don't even know it oh let our cooking level four you
see that juicy juicy juicy call it juicy jay because we doing it everyone
handed in the quest right next quest hmm what's a really easy quest
uh that's free is earnest to chicken easy level four that's like halfway
already exactly we're almost there like I'm not reffing the gear for nothing
uh what's the easiest next quest X marks the spot someone says
oh sheep shearer definitely sheep shearer right let's do sheep shearer next
uh we can start this quest by talking to Fred at his farm in northern Lumberge
so we are we're actually just there I'm like is it gonna show me that's me okay
that's Fred so literally we just need to go up again okay we're going to do
sheep shearer not to be confused with what the Welsh are associated uh that's
terrible um actually I could talk about that the reason why the Welsh are
associated with that because it uh it wasn't it's illegal to steal someone's sheep
but it wasn't illegal at the time to mm-hmm a sheep I'll wait outside to get everyone all
you need 23 inventory slots pause pause pause pause hold the line hold the line what's going on
we need 20 inventory space right get to the top of that castle and shove everything in your bank
we are not letting a gold coin go to waste in this operation get up them stairs right
now we are going to the bank if you check if you click on the quest the plug ensures you
what you need for the quest ah me who is ignoring it wait why why is quest helper open
wait did I oh it's because we've not accepted the question right get upstairs twice and then
everyone get to the bank and empty your inventory we need sheep shears for this quest so you can
probably just drop everything I'm not even getting bank that bank man's like oof the Sunday
lunch uh Sunday lunch oh oh no no I don't want to set a pin in front of everyone
everyone can do my pen yes yes I already did the tutorial I don't know why you're telling me this
uh take a hydration check if you haven't hide it yes yes yes yes yes yes mr bank or mrs bank
one or the other do not make me set a pin right in front because I can't right there
right we're just shoving everything inside oh like that boom
do I need to hold anything I don't know we can always come back if we need more quest items
say no to banking the English later redefined it by taking it out
dislar wishes all right what were you what were you showing us huh you're gonna flex on us what
you've got what I am you got dragon claws be honest what I am oh no you you can't give me that I'm
a new account you can give me that wait why would you trust me with that kind of no why oh my god
that's going to the cooking fun get that in the bank we can get interest on that right now oh my god
that's going to the cooking fun get it in get in the bank put them all on the bank oh my god
oh my cold payment thank you for the money oh my god well when we when we do our finisher
quest and we actually start leveling up cooking I'll I'm going to take a look at a guide if you're
finished at the bank I'll wait for you outside Lumbridge okay outside the castle we'll just stand
away outside the castle as long as your inventory is empty and we're going to do sheep shear quest
he was communicating on morse code with the emotes on the screen oh where they actually
um oh my god that's going to the money fund uh I don't know what the fastest way to do
cooking is I think it's sharks I want to say it's sharks but sharks are so expensive because
they're hard to run okay let's make sure all the reeflings that I still tell terrifies me to this
day um cooking is wines I thought pay to play is it really wines and then but it costs money okay okay
okay we're learning we're learning I really hope that guy gives us shears or I'm gonna cry wait
why do I have no weapon drew on me I'm probably gonna get rolled in battle if we have to do a
battle thing you can proc it you can profit if you do cook thingy except trade were you were
you gonna flex on his dragon claws next a wizards hat Gandalf's hat oh you wouldn't give me Gandalf's
hat me when my stream is late wait hold on wait wait wait me when my stream is late
a streamer is never late or early he arrives precisely when he means
we're doing the cooking I think cooking looks better with the bunches yeah you can't even see my eyes
Gandalf bought cringe what how dare you oh Gandalf bought cringe okay okay all right I think that's
all my reeflings my little reefy reeflers why why take the banana off it just literally hunting
around killing rats are your legs tired no right we were gonna make our way to sheep shears let's go
we'll walk because I don't want anyone to get left behind I don't know how many quest points I need
um in order to do like to be unblocked strongy the blue oh would that would
I be strong even would I be strong in the green surprise exam oh someone's got an MPC
MPC event oh the the farmers in here it should be here the quest starts surprise exam
oh this reeflings so tired oh no he's lagging behind reeflings oh no he's going for the shoot
right um talk to the farmer first shears 100k no that's terrible there's shears in here
shears 100k talk who's closing the door in the reeflings wait who did I talk talk to Fred the
farmer Fred's in the second room here that's pretty scourging I'm looking for a quest
okay yes we can shear your sheep we're to avoid the thing because there's one sheep that's not
like the others okay I can do that good now that's one oh we do need shears hold on a minute
hold oh no Fred gives your shears okay the farmer will give you shears see that see that
reefling out there that's doing that hustle for 100k uh he just gives you it for free okay
uh okay we need to spin will back it oh we need to go all the way back to Lumbridge
Lumbridge castle after this anyway right everyone hop over this little thing here
make sure the Welsh aren't doing this quick guess to that do you see the thing in the pen
we're gonna look for there is there's the thing it's like a person role playing oh it's a penguin
hello can I shear it or does it just back off oh why is it just around the thing
no don't hurt the sheep you can shear sheep for free you don't need to perish the sheep in order
to shear them refunds you're so you're so aggressive right I've got one you need we all need 20 so
we're gonna be here for a hot second we're all gonna like streams we're gonna be sniping sheep
shearing I'm getting stream sniped on shearing sheep and runescape go they're not gonna grow
back quick quick quick we need to do it I need to be the first one to get all 20
okay there's another one there's another one get right get right I'm gonna hog them I'm gonna
hog them by doing two at once no no no no I need to be the first I need to be the first if you've
got 20 you need to stand outside the pen so we know the first person did it is I'm getting a lot
I'm getting a lot I'm getting them oh I'm getting them come on I'm at your first I'm at your first
I don't know if you guys are like starting faster than me
get right get right was that one two three four five six seven eight nine
two I'm on ten I'm on ten I've got ten more no you guys are sniping the sheep too fast oh my god
you guys have ping advantage stop you're cheating I didn't even there was a way you can get in the
pen from there I know the reflets are gonna beat me oh god another one get right get right
this is so dumb but I love it
literally all of us are chasing these perches the sheep are like I've just grown that roots oh oh
and world wars literally forget like gilinor games forget winter is it hot winter taught or
something we're literally stream sniping sheep shearing no I can't wait for the cow grinding
honestly we'll probably need to get levels up together like so we're not like in danger of dying
stop you saved me I can't believe you freaking sniping these sheep per sheep were forced to be
stripped over no one who is perishing the sheep you don't need perishing to harvest the wool
the penguins are part of the fun members quest oh aren't they I didn't know that
one two three four five six seven eight nine ten 11 12 30 40 50 60 17 we're 17 I'm actually just
going to do full inventory I think get sniped get sniped I was before I was before I'm actually
so much better than you guys at runescape even though I'm hardly even played this game
who's leveling up their combat you're really beating these poor things up oh get right get
sniped get sniped get sniped I got it get sniped literally I saw you I saw the way you were walking
over to that that sheep life is hard in runescape world honestly but wouldn't it be fun like this
is imagine if all you had to do was like shear sheep and then you get paid coins for at grand
exchange you can go like get food and stuff I'm actually camping the sheep right now I'm like
camping it wait you guys are cheating you're right behind me I'm like camping the sheep come on I
have faith oh this oh I must have 20 no the refling one someone's already outside and you're outside
as well or did you not do the quest you guys are cheating pretty sure it's a real job to be a sheep
shear I mean yeah where do I sign up to do that I have to work for the sheep right I have got it
so it's no longer highlighted for me I think so I just need to wait until you guys are already
and you've got your 20 and then we're gonna waddle our way back to lumberage castle
if only there was a job in real life that I'm volunteering sheep some sort someone should
coffee runescape honestly I think we're getting there we're getting a few more refling joining
in I think you guys are getting close to being you are getting beaten up someone is half health
over here oh my you got a little more what's that oh you got boxing gloves check them out oh my god
you got necko ears we're going it's it's discord kitten oh oh oh help me the fake out help me the
fake out oh oh oh oh oh it's amazing oh oh oh float like a butterfly stinking like a bee
I'm looking for his father again chest but what
a five dollars per hour to shear sheep oh that's rough
hmm
uh I think some of us are still shearing we're still shearing away don't worry we're still
call us edge shearing because when your legs then they work like they used to bell for war
we're still edge shearing these sheeps
wishes to trade what you're gonna have you're just gonna have a load of cotton
uh you're giving me cabbage and and goblin mail I don't think I can put goblina mail on why are
you just giving me stuff because you can wait it's too small yeah the armor's too small for a human
but I've got kebab oh I got given a kebab let's go been on a night out
necko ears boxing gloves and programmer socks oh did we spot a femboy in the world
oh my god can I offer you an egg in these trying times
that's funny
oh oh what's this wait what is that why is it called 10 0 8 1
um oh it's an easter egg oh I thought his name was actually the number
femboys and migrants gave more likely than you think
what on earth that's great why what are you planning with our legs it's dangerous
why what the what do you do with the egg it says
he's I don't want to eat it examine the egg it just says happy easter grand exchange average
it's worth 10 okay toast macaroni right I am going to stand outside the pen so if you're finished
stand outside the pen with your um gatherings I'll go back to walking speed but we'll see if
the reeflings are all finished shearing we've got a little seller of uh or what was it called
investor we could charge us far too much money uh there's a few more reeflings so wait I'll hang
fire as a five two guy I basically have to become a femboy so there's a what that's that's a wild
sentence as a five two guy I basically have to become a femboy to have it what
and that statement is wailed that's a stable that is wailed
why would you say that why would you say that we're literally the same height oh you give me
pissy I got a pleasure oh don't mind if I do what is it it's a tuna oh we can cook it later when
we have enough for chicken we've got a reefling reefling and another reefling and four reeflings
that we're waiting on oh look I'm sheared away look I'm sheared away Brian hey strony
gotta dip out now for work have fun at work if you're still gaming once I'm out I'll try and
catch up if not I'll try and catch up off screen thank you so much thank you for the tip and yeah
don't worry I don't know how long we're going for today I need to figure out I don't know if um but
you're a girl I got a booty hole um hold on a minute oh I don't know what's going on here
82 over stream do you honestly think I'm capable going 82 hours I mean if you try
I wonder how far I could eat strony teasing strony because she's short honestly true who we got
um it we're it we're item snaper isn't moving I'm not sure if they're playing or if they're
doing something their character hasn't moved so I don't know I think we might very slowly move on
strony more like shawty how do you shawty is like a melody in the morning that I can't keep
from me sing this way la la la oh he just logged out all right I think we can progress reeflings
we're on the move to Lumberge castle uh you can follow me and it should automatically follow you up
there are headless reefling sir gold food running sailing sheep shears 50k
shawty more like shawty you making will like this damn girl whoa what does that even mean
someone says holiday event no I don't know it's not holiday event is it I don't think it's like
winter tall or anything like that oh sorry on the corner sorry on the corner I should maybe wait
okay we need to go up the stairs once and then we have access to the spinning thing that yonk
Cinderella being sure it was average then recent generations came and everyone then suddenly became
six foot I think because of malnutrition uh I believe it there's an event an old school
rinskate going on right now oh okay okay right everyone spin your will and get that craft an xp
we'll spin that we'll spin who it is close oh my reeflings are we all in a bedroom together
we couldn't possibly be so dastardly to oh it's someone keeps closing who is closing the door
on the reeflings be you're literally the door closer right you need to spin all of the will you
got on this little thing over here dips going first so much white string oh my gosh what's
gonna happen I wish can you like sit on the bed like in sims nah you can't do none of that
someone's done press up snakes to the no wait is press up some more how we how we do our thing
which ones press up that have it I don't have it locked whoa there's like tons I've premiered
oh no and everyone knows that I paid money to be premiered all right oh no I can do a kiss in the
bedroom there I can do a little kiss I can spit I'm spinning on the tip right now you just don't
know I'm spinning we well I'm jumping on I'm jumping on that shit get it yeah yeah yeah
this is ridiculous garden in 99 how have you got garden in 99 that's insane oh there's a why is
there a dagger at the bedside table I'm getting nervous I'm getting shaky everyone fighting laugh
at the preem you can make a peep in runescape chat if you type aqpw
but I've never I don't know what that is uh yes and we're not gonna leave until we're all finished
is this Emmy's bedroom what because it's medieval again or mercy why um there's nothing that really
indicates with bedroom okay honestly it looks like a dungeon so wouldn't it be sheepsters you don't
keep a knife in your oh the knife next to the bed oopsies uh Emmy always has a knife on right as
everyone spun their wool they better have I'll wait outside the castle but everyone needs to spin
that wool you need to spin that wool okay bedroom ERP sessions over time to spin that wool
right right side the castello we'll wait for you outside the castello don't worry everyone point
so it should attempt those innocent refilling me your will rot in your hands why say such such
things who is a cow oh my gosh who I hope that's not a refund is that a refund that can't be I think
it's just a thinking that's an essay incredibly incredibly uh
unique outfit choice
BRB a scream truck is here I'm going to take a drink of water some of their snowballs
don't oh get snowballs snowballs snowballs throwing at me how do you throw snowballs how do I do that
I don't have it I can only bow please wait are you hurt me no oh it looks like you're hurting me my goodness
it's too bad gnome ball is members what's gnome ball I've never played it before
mm now is this all the weathlands I'm gonna I'm gonna beat it I'm gonna beat it up
oh I take this wow yeah we're definitely gonna have to level our combat so we're a bit more efficient
it's like American football okay okay okay can I be a cheerleader you remember no man people
you can do that in game stop I'm gonna not take a knife I'm gonna not take a knuckle in
I'm a gnome and you be gnome I think that's everyone right there's no way that anyone is
still spinning wool at this point we're moving on to the farm going back on to the farm come on
replaying let's go so what the plan is is we're gonna do the easiest free quests first
and then we're actually gonna take a proper stab at leveling up cooking okay sounds good deal
you can tempt me oh you want my body it's ready man's got his priorities through
mm
ah no stragglers we're like ducklings following the mother duck
because my voice is hoarse that's actually perfect for making that noise
got a little echo going strongy teaching us to cook so we can survive no I'm gonna
cook for you I need night night cooking so all my rooflings can have really healthy meals every
night okay that sounds like a plan right open that door Fred the farmer open that door to
what are you doing on my land I need to talk about shearing these sheep oh how are you getting
on with the balls of wool I have some give them here then that's the last of them I guess I better
pay you then just don't be too friendly now congratulations you complete sheep shearer
you've got quest point 150 crafting and two quest points we're getting so MLG oh everyone's
leveling up their their craft and I can hear all the noises members can now craft cups and polish
buttons I too I'm a button polisher I'm actually have many years of experience in polishing my button
it is absolutely atrocious and far too easy uh next quest what's the easiest quest
um someone said x marks the spots easy actually don't storyline it's very short I can start this
quest by talking to vios in share drum that's a very someone said demon slayer yeah we're gonna
start demons layer okay if we go back where we came from we can do x marks the spot I actually
don't recall doing that quest so let's get going let's get going we're gonna do x marks the spot
the x marks the spot are you level 99 yet we've not even started i'm level four
hello today this is the new bot farm literally do you think jack x is watching over us like what
on earth is going on like why is this event happening where am i supposed to go uh him him
okay in the corner we're like literally sorry I completely forgotten what we're doing
could go vibe and ports around bar for 10 hours oh we cannot just get drunk and start like sharing
stories forbidden stories right it's right here okay let's see what x marks the spots all about
because I don't actually know oh I'm just beating up a man I don't have any I'm like literally oh no
I don't really want to beat up a man oh no am I gonna win I might die here I don't I'm gonna
drop my easter egg if I die oh no I think I'm okay there's a pub fight immediately literally
such a true Scott oh his bones are just hanging out oh that's a shame let's bury them sorry mate so
I'll bury you in the pub he died exactly where he loved it right who am I talking to there's someone
here talk to vios talk to the man in robes hello there I'm looking for a quest
hmm well now that you mention it I could do with some help the name's vios I'm a treasure
hunter from the wondrous king of great current great current where's that across the sea to the
far west it's truly magnificent place interesting so what brings you to Lumbridge I am here on a bit
of a hunt the hunt is treasure back in my home of great me I came across a scroll I believe it will
lead me to something of great value alas I've hit a bit of a blocker the scroll has led me
but here but as I don't really know the area I'm not sure what to do next maybe you can help with this
sure we need a spade take the scroll it should lead you to the treasure I seek once you've found
it meet me at my ship it's docked near ports around oh we're gonna go to ports around anyway
anything else I need to know you probably want to spade I find they're pretty much always needed when
it comes to treasure hunting check the general store if you don't have one I'll be sticking around a
little longer okay thank you right everyone to the general store I have 63 gold so I can share it
out the general store is just this from across the street just go across the street I do have I do
have 63 coins so I could probably buy uh right let's talk to him can I help you yes what are you
selling I would like one oh no wait of course wait can I buy it buy
oh no is this limited is there only two spades left for you guys
it's not looking good bro you need to buy spade off that guy but it's not looking good
are you beating up the bouncer shit a certain dominant
99 prayer yeah good luck with that unless you guys are gonna be my bodyguards and like feed me
dragon bones which I don't even have the money for yeah 99 prayer ain't happening
oh no there's no more spades right I will trade the spades okay don't worry we're all gonna share
a spade okay we'll share the spades so don't worry if you've not got a spade just come outside
and we will share the speed uh my map is telling me I need to go down I don't know where sorry I'm
new to the quiz within the town of Lumbridge lives a new a man named Bob who walks out of his door
and takes one step east seven steps north five steps west and one south once he arrives he digs a hole
where he buried his treasure yeah um hi mom hi right I'm back what did I miss we're currently
doing x marks the spot so reeflings don't worry we're gonna share spades I'll share spades with you
oh okay this is why we like the runelike plugin all the the reeflings are already telling us where
it is and they've got a cat where did you pick that cat up right we are going to talk to evil
bob no we're not evil bob's in the way how do I dig here oh I need to slide over the spade
oh wait what
behind the back of the castle right who needs a spade how do I how do I trade someone a spade
who wants a spade trade me if you need a spade I'm I'm called skullfish
trade me if you need a spade I'm just a drop and I'm digging a hole
okay reefling ah okay if you if you need a spade but we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna pass it
around okay we're gonna trade spade okay if you are a reefling that has a spade go to the
oh can I not trade that waiting for other player other okay there you go
the community spade literally um if you need a spade please stand by the church and a reefling
will trade you if you need a spade stand by this church and a reefling will trade you okay
if you need a spade stand by the church stand at the wall at the church if you need a spade
okay any reeflings that have a spade can you pick on someone who's at the church wall and trade them
your spade please and we can share the we can share the spade
take me to church I'm just a reefling come in your bed pick on them that's so evil
yeah if you have a spade pass it over and then they can dig the spot there and then we'll just
keep doing that until everyone's picked up the scroll just lined us up against the wall that's
right who am I touching first that's the only reason I'd be doing a line up on my account
it's restricted for trading the spade is restricted for trading uh I think I'm about to get a spade back
maybe we dropped the spades instead I'm okay okay I wonder if it's because I bought membership
I'm spared right reefling you're getting traded how do I trade trade like that I don't know I just
read the word trade right can I give you this are we literally sharing like three right now
okay that's one more reefling with the go to the dig spot it's still it's just over there at the
we house me if you buy membership then you skip oh okay oh like they're digging look at the reeflings
go they're so smart they're digging okay once you've finished with your spade give it to the other
one yeah the ones who are lined up at the church need a spade so just just trade them when you have
a spade on your person and we'll just share the communal spade this is like herding kids
honestly we're not doing too bad oh no no no they're reefling uh by the wall yeah yeah by the
wall no no by the wall yeah yeah yeah where that one is
oh oh there we bit there we bit daft of reeflings but it's okay yeah yeah yeah there
where the one in red is that's where it is where the one in red is that's where you dig yeah no no no
green one one forward green one no no yeah yeah yeah the right yeah yeah that's where it is that's where
you should pick out oh look all the spades like like like someone dropped spade someone says one million
someone says one million for spades okay you're done you're done spade drop party okay i'm picking up
a spade as well because i need it for the next section there's so many spades right everyone
pick up a spade pick up a spade there's lots of spades on the we love spades thank you for dropping
the spade i'm a dwarf and herding the reeflings to their demand i mean happy lovely cuttlefish
love seeing strony experience my addiction for the last 16 years has everyone got a spade
like there's so many spades on the ground now we shouldn't we don't need to share
there's three more by the church
all right if everyone's got a spade and everyone has called is so you have to open the closed
girl first and then dig for it in this little dig site here and then open it up again and then it
will reveal that the this is lumbridge castle and this is behind the castle this is where we were
hanging out at the start of the stream
someone's lit okay if everyone's got a spade we're gonna go behind the castle now if you've all dug
it up there'll be like one reefling that like i have no clue what i'm doing right now i'm just
happy to be here so we're gonna go behind the castle the castle strony can you explain
real escape to me as if i was a general manager explaining to a new hire uh incremental game
oh look the reefling's already here to tell us what's up you know what what happens behind the
castle now we just dig it up with your spade and what did i get i got a mysterious what i got
feel mysterious orb examine an orb i found while treasure hunting for veos okay now
where do we go solve the clue scroll dig uh i like to dig behind the castle just outside the
kitchen door dig northwest of dry nor village jail just by the wheat farm wait there's more
i thought we were done wait are we about to go like really i think we have to go through here if
you've dug up the orb then we need to now quest halfway across the map we need to go where dry nor
village wow okay we have to go a little bit right who knows right is everyone following
all the reefling no reefling got no that's an embassy reefling got stuck on the wall
you're reefling then find yourself right where you definitely want to follow me for this next
section unless we're fall can i just follow the reefling and the reefling i'll take me there
honestly i'm a pure laziness yes if you guys follow me i'll follow the reefling and it's just
one big conga line all the way to dry nor village are we gonna oh we're gonna get so caught on these
trees there's no way can't they get freaky in the castle i think i'd do it behind the
reef door it's like a really big thing
i think it did i've got a few scripts that are like that for the girls coming out
and it's like actually mersey has one this month um i don't want to ruin it take us to the dig say
i don't know where it is you taking us to it taxi to drink do you know where anyone taxing
she's gonna get all we're in lock and music tracks as well conga conga conga can you do the conga
but we're making it this is the world's worst drop party we're dropping speeds out here oh look
there is because i'm not paying for this the navigation is horrible we're at least an unsatisfactory
unsatisfactory um thingy my boba that sorry i mentioned my eyeball i always think that itch my eyeball
you've picked up a treasure scope we're gonna open it we know
this uber's been a one out of five have you guys taken ubers i'm just i would be so scared to do it
where the heck do we need to go now i can't see it can't oh it's only over there it's fine it's
literally right over here the market it's not big deal it's literally straight over here uh yeah
let's just go for it fun fact click on the map for the shortest route to your destination
idea for asmr wait eyeball itching oh my eyes i can make my eyes make noise like
make it like it's pretty gross okay let's see talk to the zero no you're not an mpc we need to
we're digging in in piggy kaka use the spade please why are you not working is it because there's
spade oh i'm spading i'm literally hitting you with a spade right now okay everyone
in the space i need to take you away so we can so i can dig this freaking pan use spade on
why why is it not letting me do it it says use spade on i love mommy why is it not i'm not being
dumb you have to dig not use oh almost oh right i got it got it got it got it got it
it says talk to vios i'm sorry i'm so dumb using dig should be the same thing it's unfair
but it's a doing word right we are going to go to port southern to go talk to the guy
which we just need to basically do a u-turn like a okay u-turn time u-turn time so we just
need to go up here because none of us have agility so we can't use this underwall tunnel
literally you pay membership so you can have shortcuts only that you have the grain to get
the shortcut might as well be an mpc
uh taxi we've got a taxi
i know some of the reeflings are left behind
yeah come around the wall do a u-turn around the wall and it's literally right here
sorry i know you some guys render distance may not be able to see it all but we did it
there's third quest
so
oh we all celebrate okay we can finish our quest how's the treasure hunt going i found
excellent oh i've got an ancient casket
i don't know about three total quest points we've got an antique lamp 200
call oh we've got a clue scroll do we all get the same clue scroll near the open desert i
reside to get past me you must abide go forward if you're there for you for when you pass me
you'll be sweating by your hair no
dungeon master that's not is that an easy quest was our next easy free to play quest
hmm that was
i got one about an anagram of who i need to speak tonight oh my god this music is so good
it's so good you should someone did a like a base remix of sea shanty 2 and it's so good i love it
uh what's the easiest
push uh potion what's the easiest mission quest that we could do i'm not sure
absolute banger i'm gonna rub my brb i'm gonna go rub my
uh
you're trolling me that's not a quest
i don't know i'm sure there's this like headless quest the restless ghost i think that's it yeah
the rest of the ghosts let's do the rest of the ghosts because i'm pretty sure okay we need okay
just teleport back to lumberj so open up your magic book and you should have a teleport should
say lumberj home teleport you open up your little magic page i don't even can see it over my hair
oh my hair's so big i can hardly see my inventory but just teleport back to lummi we're gonna do
we're gonna draw it in the ground who put a cow over here i don't even know how you did that
but yeah teleport to lumbridge open up your magic spell book and it's the very first one
it should be on cooldown because we've been looking about okay i'll stand here and i'll wait for my
oh no i know another one no go away go away with your stance okay yes your hair is big
it is i'm covered up my queen my big A3 uh no more silly songs i love the way you see cow
a cow a cow how'd you say cow who oh you can also say a highland cow that's true wishes to trade
with you hmm what do you offer me what do you offer me tomato and cheese oh can i cook that
what do i do with a tomato and cheese sandwich yeah oh there's the cow again
i'm not absolutely stunning on him what good food i'll eat it the next time i get into a bar
fight by accident okay hopefully all the reeflings made it to uh teleport that was your first time
teleporting who is doing a snowball fight okay let me take us to the next quest i'm pretty sure it's
over here sorry i was bumping my desk did you hear that that cow a literal woman i think they heal
one that's all i need in a bar fight one cheeky bit of health
right oh no it's in here sorry it's in the church i'm sorry i'm such a fake gamer
it's inside the church i apologize it's not in the graveyard uh father ira
here father who art in heaven hallowed be thy name i'm seeking a quest uh i'm looking
for a quest i'm looking for a quest that's okay i need someone to do a quest for me before starting
this quest be aware that your combat level is lower than the recommended of time um
um i'm pretty sure you don't have to fight so we're gonna send it okay
we're gonna send it access the graveyard through the south guys to reach the swamp i'm sure if you
told him that uh i said i'm sure he'd be willing to help my name is father eric by the way please come
eat you black wax take her traveling through the swamps i've heard like a bit dangerous okay the
stronger reeflings are literally gonna have to pick on the animals that pick on the weaker
reeflings okay because i'm gonna get picked on as well i need what get a ghost speak amulet
but we're though oh and this shack up here right we need to go down to the shack so let's go
through the graveyard reeflings together strong literally why is he father dead no because all
like all prayer men are like ours i've forgotten the name of them the prayer men i well i'm not
sure if i want to go through the swamp i think we might need to go around um unless we've run
through the swamp i don't know the music's getting different i'm just a small weak reefling yeah if
anyone gets attacked on the way you're gonna have to like help them out and stop them getting
attacked basically because we're too weak for this get with me swamp what are you doing at my swamp
oh a priest aye that's the name it's a priest prayer man completely if you want that word the
music and this came so high link today they're adorable youth i actually had an extended family
member that owned one um and it was like the gentlest giant ever i never got to meet her it was
like a female highland cow god that's the most scottish thing i could see i had a family member
that owned a scottish cow yeah a highland cow which is you know scottish father airdrick sent
me to talk to you i suppose i'd rather talk to you though and what problems have you got himself
into this time it's got a it's got a ghost haunting his graveyard all that silly fool i leave town
for just five months and you already can't manage so well i can't come back and exercise it i vowed
not to leave this life until i've done a full two years of prayer and meditation two years to sit on
your own right we need to go talk to the ghost we now have an amulet so we're gonna you'll get
given an amulet make sure you put it on your person okay make sure you do not waste your sprint
weaker leaflings because we need to run away like from this fight immediately two years without
internet i'd be absolutely losing it i'm sorry i'd be i'd just are you squint me ryan hey stroney
if i wanted to share a interesting prompt for you to read but it was too long for marsh malo how
would i you like me to share it with you uh i don't think i have any other way are all the
leaflings coming here leafling you're so you're so behind i'm gonna have to i'll wait for them to
spawn them i don't want to but i don't want us to get attacked by the big routes i'm not sure thank
you for the tip and on if it's big i think paste bin is a safe website right let's get the heck out
here for these rat scouts or the frogs at the swamp hey drony hi hi thanks for joining
two years of isolation is wild literally like i'm sorry but if i was isolated i'd just straight up
day and night no stop and say i'm sorry but i gotta do something to pass the time gotta do something
to pass the time so i do not know how that brings anyone closer to meditation could a paceman link
work yeah i think paceman's probably the only thing right i think we need to be ready to run
away so get ready to turn these running boots on okay but talk to the restless ghost hello ghost
how are you not very good actually what's the problem then did you just understand what i said
yeah no tell me what the problem is whoa this is incredible i didn't even expect anyone to ever
understand me again okay okay i can understand you but do you have any idea why you're doomed to be a
ghost well to be honest i'm not sure i've been told a certain task may need to be completed
so you can rest in peace i should think it is probably because a warlock has come along and
stolen my skull if you look inside my coffin it's no they're i briefly just closed the coffin as soon
as you said that okay okay he's missing his head we can see this in his head he clearly needs some
head oh yeah that would be such great relief okay return the ghosts skull where do we need
what we need to go to the wizard's tower
what the hell i don't remember that no way i don't remember it's actually quite far away
a reefing was to show me something what do you want to show me reefing other player has accepted
oh you're giving me fish to cook wait you're giving me this now wait i think you might need
to hold on to it because if i die in this quest you need to hold on to this okay hold on to it
thank you but you need to hold on to that because if i die i'm gonna drop all of that we'll do a
few more quests and then we're gonna actually start leveling up cooking like for real for real okay
but thank you so much but do hold on to that because i'm gonna end up perishing looks in coffin
so no head exactly right are we all here i think so it's when you guys stack it's really hard to
see like if we're all here hey it's the price gaugeer bro i feel like i'm getting lured hiya
do you trust me do you trust where we're going it'd be such a shame if you go lured
what did it be oh someone sent me a marshmallow and they're like i'm gonna be mine broken by you and
i'm like uh soon soon wait is this not where the mage tower is oh no there's enemies ahead
that attack us okay everyone get ready to sprint there's wizards and robes here that are getting
ready to attack us at these trees up here there's you trees please get ready to run if you're a
weaker wiefling we're gonna get absolutely wrecked i'll tell you when to run okay but it should be
coming up it should be coming up wait isn't there not you logs here am i too late isn't there
no you logs here and wizards that beat you up here i guess i must be misremembering i'm such a
fake runescape gamer that's verac oh should be safe meet you guys at the mage bank take the bridge
let's go we're not we're north okay whoever's following sorry little wiefling you need to come
around jump up jump up and get down you shall not pass uh excuse me pardon me uh come through
oh my god well fun right be careful weaker wieflings we must run away when we do this okay
put your gold on in a minute hold on hold on get ready for freddy search alter and run
run like your little life depends on it run on your retentacles search the all are search the
all are wieflings wieflings scare once he spawns in run away wieflings run away run away run away
go up the ladder weaker ones go up the ladder go up the ladder go up the ladder as soon as you
get the score you need to go up there's so many that like that skeletons get absolutely right
oh we made it wieflings we made it we're safe we did it we didn't get wrecked i'll wait for you
outside the mage castello we did it today wieflings we cheated death it wasn't a match for us yeah
oh my god so many of us the scaly didn't know i'm literally it's closing doors you're being so
mean to the wieflings not only are you jacking up prices artificially but you're closing doors
oh my god there's so many of us oh he's beating up that wizard oh the shadow wizard money gang
they love casting spells death by dark wizard is a rinscape right of passage honestly though
no troll under the bridge yeah it that's no balls is that all my wieflings did we all make it
hopefully no one perished sailing head what that's a good girl story you thought you thought ain't
that kind of stream ain't that kind of stream i think i'm feeling better maybe the asmr stream
i give permission for you give it a try right okay wieflings let's go all the way back to the
ghost oh unless wait follow the rabbit follow the rabbit the rabbit will take us to where we need to
go uh honestly that rabbit outfit not gonna lie i'm i'm digging it i'm actually digging that rabbit
over like i mean you can see the hips definition you can see the the the the the yiddies it's all
looking pretty good and then headless refilling oh no you're at my render distance whoever's back
there headless refilling look at the size of them grippers oh what is that someone's got
like a thing on their back i honestly didn't know how many cosmetics there was in the game
if you get us beaten up by baddies because you've taken this path
okay i think we're safe every flinch is hovering in the background hey it's
constantly coming in and out of render distance okay hydration check
i hope this taxi's better than the last
oh wow oh no
rat attack
walking us to the edgeville dungeon wait there is a place called edgeville oh my
gosh that's where we should make the home oh i was gonna play i was gonna play hide and seek
and if i touch you then you're out uh right where do we need to go oh we need to go to the
the graveyard guys yeah there's literally a place called edgeville in this game
there's a plugin for hide and seek is there actually
oh that's so smart maybe maybe next stream i'll like get the plugin and we'll see how it works
i don't know this sounds like hide and seek i'd rather lose but every time i find you all you
hear is plop plop plop and then move on to the next refilling plop plop plop over okay uh we need
to put the hedge on the coffin and all is good we're gonna use the skull on the coffin
with use it on the car
it's not uh it's not cool oh cutscene release thank you stranger
oh he's away oh he's in the water oh he's having enough he's in the water
whoa we got one cave prayer for that that was actually pretty big right we've got four
points no jeez we got a name prayer
what i didn't level four combat currently i didn't say anything though
hide and plop oh yes hide and plop i want to hide and plop good release oh that's
with a lot and everyone's leveling up um rep sleeping viewers yeah sorry hopefully no one
actually uses this to sleep though um i wonder if there's also a kumburu uh right what's the
easiest quest next or are we actually gonna have to level up i think we might have to get stronger
because everything's like um pirate maybe goblin village if we buy everything in advance for that
goblin quest i forgot the name of it romeo and juliet is good should we try romeo and juliet
romeo and juliet also an amniolet that's useful for the future right stronghold of security time
i've never done that one romeo and juliet is no needed stats okay we're gonna do that one then
i can start this quest by talking to romeo and varrock square where the heck
oh that's a big walk not gonna lie that's like really far away not gonna lie okay we cross
the bridge and then we just keep going all the way up to varrock i've already lost where romeo is
oh he's literally in the square of varrock well we don't have teleport stone so we're gonna have
to do it the old-fashioned way uh i heard it drops the goal in the amniolet i didn't know what that is
follow someone says follow just oh oh taxi okay follow the guy with the magma cape
wait make sure we get out of the graveyard first because we might actually get stuck on the gravestones
yeah you'll get careful you get stuck on the gravestones okay if you're gonna tax sales can i make
a cup of tea amniolet to make a cup of tea that little voice is getting for this is a magma cape
winky it is isn't it a magma cape whoa what is that wait you got a special accolade is that
a special accolade to this thing oh it's a fire cape i mean it looks like magma lava so however
named it is wrong we we must go directly into the dark mages oh wait i can't make a cup of tea
because i'm gonna get hurt by the mages for the weaker reeflings we're about to pass some
wizards outside of a rock that will attack us we need to be ready to run
go west near the farm oh so oh he says he's gonna go around
i think we have enough people to kill the dark wizards oh can i go quickly make a cup of tea then
watching strony stream
ah whenever i read the like last thingy you know the love heart you know he you can put a love heart
on stream like that little tap that love heart thing it's in the way if i read the most bottom
thing it says watching strony stream is the type of accolade yeah if you tap that heart i can see
when you tap it but it blocks the last message i'll be doing nothing but laughing if anyone dies
oh we'll also be at the bank so is that reeflings still there to trade the fish
there's plenty more fish i can only see it on mobile yeah i can see someone make a flush like
face smiley reaction it's in the way for everyone okay right i was gonna say because it's in the
way whenever i read like the most bomb message it's in the way that cape requires you to kill a level
700 monster like unless you guys can carry me through that monster i don't think we can do that
i've never done it before yeah i had to nuke the heart with an edulander i think you can toggle
away yeah i have to scroll around it it's a solo fight well i'm never getting that
hmm i am here with the fish okay we will be going next to the bank so
we should be okay i think is there any hopefully isn't too many oh yeah good idea to go to the
bushes first oh no these reeflings oh no don't get stuck on the wall reefling
that these are reeflings oh no i don't know if that's everything i might just be someone
there's three dots at the top of chat and no no i think it's okay i think it's there
fire cape would be fun oh no i don't even know how to do that i don't even know how prayer pots work
in like strength potions and all of that work and it's like all temporary but they're like a thousand
and it's so expensive
hmm watch out now all right weaker reeflings get ready get ready weaker reeflings stronger
reeflings beat them up show those wizards we mean we mean freaking we mean business beat them up
stronger reeflings will be the weaker reeflings are gonna stick together this is the best we
can do under the circumstances
run into the circle reefing no they're not going that circle these wizards are stinky
they're no good guys he's telling you fevers he's telling you the Fibonacci sequence because
those are fevers okay i think the reeflings like literally eradicated all the wizards for us in
the way thank you they're all dead literally just absolutely eradicated them i think the funniest
thing ever wow how can i tell it to wow how many quests this are i don't know if we can do all
the quests and jeez low waist right we're looking for r for Romeo uh uh okay we're here right who's
Romeo oh Romeo's inside the shop inside this shop with the green windows inside the shop is
where Romeo is he thought he could hide from us right talk to Rumi Romeo what what is to become
of me and my darling Juliet i cannot find her anywhere have you seen her yes i have seen her
actually at least i think it was her blonde a bit stressed golly yes yes you make us sound so
very interesting and i'll bet she's a bit of a fox around well i guess she could be considered
attractive i'll bet she is sorry all that jubilation has made me forget what we were talking about
you were asking me about Juliet you seem to know her oh yes Juliet
that fox could you tell her that she is the love of my of my long what she's the love of my long
rinse jagged she's the love of my long another lie to be with her what what surely you mean
she is the love of your life and that you want to be with her oh yes what you said tell her that
it sounds much better oh you're so good at this start the Romeo and Juliet quest yeah okay i'll
let her know oh great and tell her that i want to kiss her a give you mean you want to give her a kiss
oh you are good you are good i see i've picked a true professional is he drunk uh okay thanks
yay okay has everyone got the quest we now need to actually we're going to very quickly go to the
bank and i'm going to young call the fish from your juicy juicy donations to me okay oh wait sorry
pause pause i'm in the square i'm in the square sorry i didn't mean to run away so quickly we're
going to very quickly go to the grand exchange because i'm going to empty my inventory and if
you want to give me anything you can okay but i'll uh no don't give me a bond i've already bought
premium thank you so much don't give me a bond though i bought premium right reeflings if you
want to follow me we're gonna go to the grand exchange so if you want to give me anything you
can get your scam messages ready oh no i need to mute public chat whilst we're here
i might need to mute public chat i don't know how bad the bots are gonna be
i have no idea how bad the bots are gonna be
i might have to mute public chat until we go away
buying girlfriend three oh there's like the bots aren't talking okay nothing's happening right i'm
going to put i'm literally oh no no i don't want to sell them just literally gonna shove everything
in the bank uh i think i'll just drop the clue scroll ah you know i'll just put it in the bank
it doesn't make a difference uh put all my coins in i've got an antique lamp i don't know what that
does oh i can't put it away uh i'll rub the antique lamp oh i'm into cooking please
hey 300 xp in cooking okay i'm level seven cooking now feels good man okay i'm a stand
over here if you want to trade me you're more than welcome to i literally start in a farm for uh
it how do i accept accept okay there we go sorry sorry i'm dumb oh my gosh that's a lot of fish
oh 10 million are you crazy isn't that a lot of money are you sure that's a lot of money
oh wait did i just accept you as a friend by accident which 10 million reeflings is this
account gonna get shut down because like jaggex are gonna be like you're clearly like paying for
these like a lobster i'm cake yes thank you for the lobster
oops the the weapon i'm the weapon is 1.2 billion that's crazy sorry i think i accidentally
out of the frame 10 million isn't that not like a how much how much ink how much ink
one thousand crusty socks why did jaggex make that i am they knew exactly what they're doing
doubling money this schmuck just made 10 million doubling money doubling money
that's ridiculous on the contrary we play here oh it's a ring oh can i wear it i'm allowed to put
it on it's a diamond reefling oh my god wait wait can i see it on my finger if i put it on
no i didn't change my persons i'm married to the reefling okay what do we do on the wedding then
what what's the honeymoon i want to i want to know about honeymoon
fishies oh we are gonna be like exploding oh my god that's so much we are gonna be
exploding once we cook all these thank you reeflings oh my gosh okay i'm gonna put it all in the bank
and then we get to come back come back how is it there's not one single bot here that's pretty uh
thingy okay we are doing Romeo and Juliet do we need to do anything we actually don't need any
items at all wow oh sorry sorry there's a few more that wish to trade my apologies my apologies
fishies look at all the fishies you can you can bank not these by the way but thank you for the
fishes we're getting so much fish yes thank you okay how do i accept this
oh i'm getting weeps hey yo you want to grape me hold on a minute oh no sorry the cut of our
bear is my apologies my apologies uh it's a wedding gift uh who did i not accept the trade from
is it you did i accept the trade from you go great wait is Johnny come in tax fraud and runescape
honestly oopsie sorry oh wait hold on i accidentally added a reefling i apologize sorry
it's just because it was show what's the dress gonna look like someone called sweaty socks are you
are you role playing as my sweaty socks i actually have socks on oh it's a necklace it's so pretty
oh they get to put it on amulet of power oh oh oh check me out oh look at that little thing
this puppet that you get to hurry when we celebrate in the wedding on my alternative
twitter eat cuttlefish what would you name yourself like that unless you mean the other way
what you gotta show me what you've got eat cuttlefish
you know you know i'm gonna are you just wanting to
hi strawney sounding beautiful as ever are you declined it right i will put this away in the bank
and then we will finish genomic genotic and elfin genotic and oblin wait why is that i'm doing
all ah there we go oh that's all i needed to do speaking of alt twitters what was your reaction
to them blowing up so mersey stumbled upon the algorithm and then she be did it but i did mine
too late rip um but i mean the video did really well it got like a hundred and a thousand likes on it
and you're really good wait are you are you trying again did you get stage fright or is that the
open ah okay okay right genomic genotic and elfin genotic and oblin we need to genot her
genel's to over to gnor to faldor i think i think she's somewhere here i don't know where she is
talk to romeo i did did i not accept talk to romeo i did talk to juliet in the house west of rock
oh wait they're both in varrock why did i think she was in faldor and where is genotic and oblin
i'm analizing i'm analized oh
hey she's here why would you be in there okay uh right let's go to the front of the grand exchange
for my little reeflings front of the grand exchange front center after this quest i am gonna
falador i hardly even know her
thank you thank you i came up with that myself thank you
reeflings i'm at the front of the grand exchange you can find me over here
so we're making a clan can you make a clan like can anyone make a clan
that video was amazing strong eight
all per eco fish just wanted to feel included in it it got none to thingy
a luring clan he even knows okay is this all my reeflings we're at the front okay this looks like
right ready hot 10 up two three four up two three how do i get in this higher so looks like i get
in the store here unless there's another door no there's a door here okay we just use this door
let's literally right over there hot two three four hit two three four minus two bad joke literally
just going down 10 aura sorry okay open the door hello we would like to come inside your house
don't mind us we're just how have i come the hardest way to get around this house there's no way i
literally pick the most awkward door i'm so sorry i we literally have trailed through the entire house
but the one door stop pranking each other with the door you're pranking me with the door why is
there fishing it's a true draw party get you true get you true get you true we're gonna need it we're
gonna need all the xp i got three four five six i don't know how i managed to do the worst right
go up the stairs up the stairs it smells fishy in here it does right where's juliet oh her room's
all pink oh my god you're such a girl how do we know juliet's a girl hmm it's a mystery hi juliet
juliet i've come from romeo he begs me to tell you that he cares still oh how my heart sorry for
hearing this news please take this message to him with great haste well i hope it's good news he was
quite upset when i left him he's quite he's quite often obsessed the poor sensitive soul but i don't
think he's gonna take this news very well however all it's not lost everything is explained in the
letter would you be so kind to deliver it to him please certainly i'll do so straight away
hey thanks oh i'm so very grateful you may be our only home help me i'll be walking only
you're my only home okay as everyone spoke to juliet romeo and juliet we're just literally
passing sexton messages honestly what's going on here if you have spoken to juliet we can go back
doing the stairs and we're gonna go back to romeo oh romeo where are for thou our romeo
hey who closed that door i literally just smacked my face my i freaking you closed that door and now
i'm tracking outside backwards stop it don't don't close the door you made me whack my face into
stop it let me out of this house it keeps trying to make me go right i'm out i'm out okay we're safe
we're safe you don't want to go through the five doors instead honestly forget doing agility
training it's hard enough to get out of a door that someone else is closing what how did that pop
up i didn't even accept okay our all reeflings here we're gonna go back to romeo he's this way
hardest boss in the game pathing yeah really i'm are we reefling back there
oh did i tell you i really like this meme
i love that meme so much okay we go talk to romeo back in the green shop why is that green
oh cloth right which one did that oh stop stop it stop right i'm in it doesn't who did that was
that you was that you you're you're the one who's right behind the door i love mummy am i am i accusing
you live was that you i don't know who did that i don't know who did that talk to romeo
romeo great news i've been in touch with big juliet she's written a message for you you hand over
the message oh a message a message i've never had a message before really and no no no not not one
oh well except for the occasional court summon but the really really nice message not like this one
i'm sure this message will be lovely yes yes what are you well are you gonna open it or not
uh oh yes yes of course
affection she thinks i'm deceased oh affliction oh i can't read sorry i've not got my glasses on
sorry it says affliction affection oh wait no i've got it right affection
oh yeah still hold affection for me i still feel great affection for you but unfortunately my
father opposes our marriage oh dear that doesn't sound too good at all i want great affection for
you father opposes our marriage and well we'll kill you if he sees you again i'm gonna be honest
it's not getting any better me our only hope is that the father laurence a long time confidant
can help us in some way romeo folds the message away well that's it then we've we haven't got a chance
what about father laurence our love is over the great romance little life of my love
or you could speak to father laurence oh my aching breaking heart oh how useless the situation
is now i've got no one to turn to father laurence father laurence oh yes father laurence he's a
long time confidant he might have a solution yes yes you have to go and go talk to father laurence
for loads and ask him if he's got any suggestion for a predicament where can i find father laurence
laurence father laurence i was oh you know he's not my real father don't you
uh i think i suspected that he wasn't who is did he get hit on the head
well anyway he tells his songs laurence laurence and keep these here what i can't even read that
yeah okay thanks uh okay thanks yeah thanks mate get nice try on the english but you even i can't
read that where the heck are we going somewhere over here he's just uh and then dot dot dot i don't
know what you typed riefling are you trying to see he's one of us for that word he's one of us
no one slammed the door i slammed my piece okay rieflings we're going a little to the left
outside that shop any rieflings left behind there's one riefling yeah i don't think these
are all npcs love riefling there i didn't close the door but i'm ready to accept any punishment
you do with it captain jack phone barre okay let's go we are just following the path i see the
blue marker because of ruin light so we're just following that but oh no oh no i'm gonna get
you strapped on the fence i'm sorry i was a bit i was a bit pre-emptive okay okay that was lucky
easy take it easy easy let's not get any rieflings caught on a fence come on we can do it i have no
idea how oh here's the church where's the church right we're gonna go to the steps over here rare
correct path i honestly going to will they ditch oh should we start attacking each other
we should we do fisty cuffs should we do fisty cuffs in will they and just start beating each
other up until there's like a crowned riefling at the end and then and then i give you a rose as a
favor like because you're like the knight that stood against all rieflings
and and looks are domain like the way for you uh i was in the middle of a ceremony but Romeo sent
me but i'm busy delivering a ceremony to my congregation uh yes it certainly seems like
you have a captive audience okay okay what do you want so i can get rid of you and continue
with my ceremony Romeo sent me he says you've been able to help uh Romeo yes a fine land but he's a
wee bit confused uh very confused anyway uh Romeo wishes to be married to Julia she must be rescued
from her father's control i agree and i think having i do a potion to make her dad oh to appear
passed away dead sounds a bit creepy to me but please continue the potion will only make Julia yet
appear dead then she will be taken to the crypt crypt again we're getting a bit creepy may you
must have some strange hobbies then Romeo can collect her from the crypt go to the apocryphae
tell him i sent you and that you'll need cadaver potion that's what the berries someone gave me
apart from did that riefling want me to be asleep or did you want to be asleep
apart from the strong overtones of death this is turning out to be a real love story
okay rieflings once you have why does someone have a prayer someone has a prayer on don't leave it
on you've got prayer on you're gonna run out of prayer also someone get fun do the pushing
that's terrible guys you're putting your prayer on you're gonna run out of prayer
literally i only have nine prayer points right everyone outside the church
congregate that mass is over congrats on finishing mass
um where are we going oh that's cool oh you can't see because of my hair all right you can
kind of see it see how the bar is like oh you're getting close to being finished uh that's new i
don't remember that um where are we heading where are we heading whoa where am i uh no
can i please go back to the surface thank you uh we're doing it
i'm looking oh there is it we're still in the same town thank goodness
okay uh i'll just follow the HUD for the most part
oh you wish to trade with me i will accept your trade what do you offer me what do you offer me
oh you've rejected how dare you
i don't know how to do with a friend sorry i keep freaking adding people as a friend by accident
oh wait hold on i need to remove you i'm sorry delete rip one tick player flick
one tick player flicking on romeo and juliet quest true gamers here honestly i wish i understood
the tick mechanic i've heard i've seen it like i heard it explained so many times to me i don't
get it i don't get it i'm practicing literally oh there's like little birds making noises on the
game is this the actual priestess the crickets please what you mean just prove i'll just play
crickets right now even though you asked for it like five minutes ago
oh it's this shop okay what are we doing over here
i thought it was only in the day then remember scotland and like can be out until like
it's summer when it's summer in scotland the sun doesn't go away until like nine is pretty bright
oh no i'm closing the door oh okay i thought i was closing the door but i'm not okay let's talk
i am apocrity i broke potions do you need anything yes i do need something very specific about
uh romeo and juliet wait wasn't there a movie called no me on juliet and it was about norms
what do these berries look like wait we need berries oh no someone gave me berries okay
right we need to go get the berries um to the grand exchange reeflings we will go obtain some berries
oh i can't get out because someone closed the door i clicked on the map to get out someone's
closing the freaking right haven't got that room it's not stuck in there yeah my hand hurts after
a few minutes of it doing flare oh you can only last a few minutes huh one hand right let's go get
some berries secret berries i thought it said i didn't need anything said recommended items none
says bring you can pick some from the bushes oh we're to pick them from the bushes i'm sorry
i apologize where's the bushes bring talk where i've just read it bring no i just read where i
can pick the bushes you can pick some bushes southeast of varrock wait where am i supposed to go then
what's southeast southeast like over here feels like i can get stabbed in these back alleys
you can pick my dingle but uh said we're trying to find a freaking bush
yeah that eh yeah that eh that'll tell you my short caller arrived for our streaming
where where are the berries
past the dark wizard okay strong reeflings please go ahead and beat the absolute crap out of those
dark wizards we'll for weaker reeflings get ready prepare thyself
where are these berries i'm looking oh my god the reeflings are just absolutely going to town on them
oh the magic noises oh yes the bushes are ahead i'm fragile in week please handle me with care
trying to find stroneys bushes then right i'm gonna say something i'm gonna say something
controversial i was gonna make a here asmr like here sounds but it was rather rather different
okay right i've got berries everyone everyone collect your berries off the bushes has everyone
got a berry it looks like they're infinite spawn bushes actually so wait did bots run these berries
wait it's cost 400 gp for these berries have we just stumbled on a moneymaker
here asmr not controversial how would that even work i would place the microphone
at hips level i've been here for two seconds and you're already getting controversial actually
i can't you show up in it right i think everyone's got it yeah these berries are
bought it and free to play world smothers with your next winning strat and gg okay let's go
pass the wizards again stronger reeflings you know the drill is everyone got a berry
400 gp oh my god just huge interest on the 10 million gp true true 10 million gp investment
beat them up beat them up reeflings show them who's boss oh that red bead is worth so much money
oh okay that reefling got it oh no take this bead i got it i got it
wow wizard hats are 1000 money why is it so much money we should be killing these wizards over
and over again okay i'm gonna get out here before we're getting trouble i don't want the wizards
to spawn and start getting us strongy for don't have fun can we have a reward that lets us see the
stream stingers stop i've literally not even put them on i just realized i've not even shown you
what my string my stream stingers look like that's terrible
that's terrible literally like what do reeflings look like and i'm like what do you mean i've already
shown you what reeflings look like in the artwork um we've got stingers either and i don't even use
my loading screen and i spent like 600 us dollars on it i'm so i'm like such a genuinely such a
bad video but like i just want to jump in the game who who who did that who did that i managed to
somehow get past right romeo and juliet well done you have the berries i do okay oh oh he's apocratizing
he's apocratizing all over the place enact the plan bring the potion to juliet okay
right i'm gonna stand outside and wait for everyone to get out because you already know what's
gonna happen the door's gonna freaking smack everyone's face strongy seat is a moneymaker who's
at that oh okay wait until the other reeflings are ready like i'm i'm i'm mousin all over the
reef like i'm mousin all over you know you like that oh i got like mousin around
mouse i'm just mousin watch out for varot guards no varot doubt these potions are legal
i haven't made any money though drink the potion for a funny thing i don't want to drink it i'd have
to go get another thing again doesn't make you pass out varot guards don't get paid enough to care
about that honestly one million dollar doughnuts on reward use stream start and screen once for
10 seconds brav honestly spend 800 like no 600 800 dollars ish um okay is that one more reefling
oh we like all level six now or something whoa it's a lot of reefing well no reefling are you
not done the quest properly or is this you've got you've got a chef's hat on which makes me
like what a bit what are the odds that someone just happens to be doing the quest at the same time
when are we going to winter time i've never done winter i've literally never done any
event in runescape because i'm just so bad at it and i don't understand i know that because i had
to hunt it down to get a rare fish oh for the fan art oh oh watch i'm mousin should i even know
stingers were a thing so this everyone got a logo stinger and everyone got an artwork stinger i need
a moment of time oh someone wants to trade i will accept your trade what do you offer me
ah okay i'll i'll accept i did say i wanted your ink okay i got you yeah yeah right we're
gonna hand over the potion to julia winter tot is where the yarrow literally that's what i'm like
winter fell in skyrim is where the yarrow's live right we're gonna open the door for everyone
yarrow ball boom these here oh i'm gonna close the door back so then okay let's get inside the
house please get inside the bush get up them stairs that's it anyway if i catch any reefling
closing doors uh something something bad's gonna happen i don't know i'm not decided on the punishment
your stream starting to you is very beautiful yes but it's very
as well i uh oh sorry i have a cadaver potion here suggested by father lorence if you oh wait
that's me uh excuse me sorry i don't know where that voice came from uh have a cadaver potion
here suggested by father lorence if you drink it it will make you appear dead yes and when you appear
dead your still and lifeless corpse will be removed from the crypt oh a cold dark creepy crypt
sounds just peachy then Romeo can steal and that's a steal into the crypt and rescue you just as you
wake up and this is a great idea for getting me out of here to be fair i can't take all the credit in
fact it was all father lorence's suggestion okay if this is the best we can do then hand over that
potion you pass the suspicion potion to julia wonderful wonderful i just thought romeo can
remember to get me from the crypt why do i feel like we're about to bust her out of the crypt
please go to romeo and make sure you understand the loyal arch is his gormless love lorn
softy ways he can be a bit dense sometimes and i don't want to wake and i want to wake up in the
crypt on my own yeah we're definitely picking up the crypt here oh here's Philippine my cousin
she's in she's in on the plot too she's gonna make it seem like it's more convincing yes i'm quite
what's the bridge boys quick bridge quick nick a car yes i'm quite an actress uh good luck dear
cousin right bottoms up oh she's perished oh no juliet has died you may be more believable if you're
not smiling when you see it oh yeah you might be right oh no let's try that again try that again
oh no juliet's deed i can't do like three different access at one time perhaps a bit louder like you're
upset you know that your cousin just died right yeah okay uh nick a car okay i think i'm getting
the motivation now okay let's just try this again oh no juliet's dad oh no oh no juliet my poor dead
cousin uh well it's supposed to allow screaming oh you can't she's deed
oh poor juliet uh make preparations for our body a bit less than the crypt
i can't this is terrible i don't know where that i can
uh right okay uh where do we go next spring talk to romeo and varic square to finish the quest
all right that man was cornell sanders how are we get how am i getting door blocked this
how have they not figured out this freaking door block honestly stop right i i just went through
that door that's how that's how strong i am i just went through that door okay thanks go to romeo
we're everyone i'll wait outside father not such a random person handed her a potion and she
perished literally oh no juliet you did no i'll say no follow the cute face any cute fishers
any cute fisherman coming in quite the hooker hey
i assume everyone got out yeah the door's been left open that's how i know all the briefings
are available oh there's two doors to this place okay we'll go in this thing
oh i now understand people why are what are in their angular gear
i saw that who's that shadowed guy i saw that you literally are making us walk all the way around
because you closed that feckin door i saw that i literally saw that in 4k it's you it's the freaking
shadow one who's your name identify yourself bye more like slamming to a door
romeo it's all set juliet has drunk the potion ah right the potion great what potion would that be
then the kind of a potion you know the one which will make her appear dead she's in the crepe pop
along and clean your true love uh but i'm scared will you come with me yeah i knew we were gonna come
with you oh come on i just saw the entrance when i visited there last stroney you have hooked me
what get what voice did i give him oh this is pretty scary i would be quiet
oh he's got flowers oh my god cutscene look we're here look juliet's over there
oh there she is i don't remember doing this quest honestly i think i'm
confused of a goblin meal one go over to her and i'll go wait over here okay then
yeah just go she's fine
uh hey juliet and juliet oh dear he seemed to be dead
oh what voice did i give her nikkaka oh romeo i'm filipa oh wow you're a fox
it's a shame about juliet but perhaps we can meet up later who's juliet
no wait what
that's it what oh what hello
i didn't wait so she's actually dead did we actually kill her oh no that's really sad
i actually feel really bad i remember that father laurence messed it all up
we just poisoned an innocent woman wait we're go check wait we'll go to her house to see if she's
there because what so it's a method right we're going back to the house because what
juliet and shambles literally she's she's selling her stonks that was crazy
right the door's still open surely i surely there will be no shenanigans at this door
she's fine is she actually right okay let's get inside let's inside inside inside there we go
you got there in the end just need a little guidance i suppose you're quite pleased with
yourself now oh wait why juliet julieta she's literally getting ran through about herself
all right what did she say i sat in that cold crib for ages waiting on romeo
that useless fool never showed up and all i got was indigestion i'm done with men like him
now go away before i call my father oh oh she but oh can i play piano oh i wish you could play
piano that'd be kind of cool though oh i feel bad wait why can't i go through that door
that's actually really sad i feel kind of bad though sorry juliet we didn't mean it i'm sorry
stop i'm getting i'm getting locked in again i actually getting soft locked in my video game
okay i am going to make a cup of tea and call a pee break and then we're are we got enough level
like enough skill level now that anyone can like trade is nine quest points enough
i think we were gonna do some quick fissure fissure pee break finally let's just say my
perfect one all of yous have been needing a pee for ages a wee break a piddle break if you will oh my god
yeah would you want to give me
oh i'll be here in a kebab are you asking for a drunk stream soon because don't think i won't do
don't think i won't give the people what they want thank you very much okay
oh wait is it gonna log me out and then you can all see what my freaking email is
i will turn i will hate the game off a screen but i may have to log back in again
no let's game audio on my whole volume chat donation in game no right i'm gonna do that just
in case because i don't know if it's gonna show you can set it to 25 minute i've not said it
and okay give me uh like three minutes i'm gonna pee i'm gonna make a cup of tea i do recommend you
get up stretch your legs get some water and then we are gonna do actual cooking we're gonna do actual
cooking now i think because we've hit the quest point thing uh i don't know but okay it gives me
let me cook for like three minutes and by cook i mean let me boil uh a freaking a kettle okay
right i will be a moment okay three minutes go for a go for a tinkle winkle
you
You
Uh, brainwashing mostly.
What was that, what do you mean?
That guy's like, what's going on?
It's like, what's brainwashing mostly?
Okay, true.
He goes, ah, I understand.
Not called brain.
Right, okay, take a little left outside the castle.
Make sure all my beeflings are here.
A little bit of a left.
Don't work on me.
Don't have a brain.
Ah, bless you.
Okay.
Okay, please follow me, reeflings.
I don't want to leave anyone behind.
I want to make sure you're my reeflings.
No.
Okay, we are now going to go to the fishing spot
that is past the graveyard.
Not a cult if we're hypnotized maybe.
Technically.
Oh no, sorry.
I lost some reeflings that we're following.
Oh no, they're stuck behind at the church.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Everyone, get to the fishing spot over here.
This is where I used to fish as a child.
Mama and her ducklings.
Main break.
We're good.
Yeah.
And then look.
Wait, these reeflings?
No.
Maybe?
Not really.
But we can fish.
Everyone can fish on the same tail.
It doesn't make a difference.
How many bots we got?
Oh, these botters.
You can bought a shrimp.
Who's buying shrimp for hell?
I'm starting leading the reefling around
like a big school field trip.
We're all individuals.
Yeah.
We're going to fish and then we're going to get
like cooking level.
What is happening?
Beep, beep.
It does not compute.
One-o-one-o-one-o-one-o-one.
We're pretending we're bots.
Oh, are we such trolls?
Shrimp locked hardcore.
3VP bronze man market sunk by bots.
This is going to be fun to do without access to my bank.
Oh, no.
I don't even thought.
Hello, fellow human.
Hello, fellow flesh humans.
How are you doing?
Fish, shrimp, cook, many, big level, cook, keep, get.
Yes.
That's a plan.
So we're just starting with this.
Everything that lives is designed to end world trap.
What?
Is that reeflings doing that?
Oh, my God.
The bot just ran off.
So we're going to fish until our inventory is full
and then I'm going to chop down one of those trees
and we're all going to cook around the fire together
and we're all going to share little stories when we cook our food.
Like, what people do in communities and stuff?
So who's going to be the...
I'll be the fire master.
Okay.
In this batch of fish, we're going to talk...
I forgot the net.
I told you to bring it.
Now, the only thing about fishing is that it all expires
so you have to move to the next tail.
This is to prevent and hashtag and quotation marks.
This is to prevent.
Oh, hold on.
I'm calibrating.
Did it calibrate?
Yeah, calibrate.
I'm level fishing too.
Oh, the trainer guy should give you a free net.
Hopefully.
What is that?
So we're, yeah, we're just doing this
and we're going to cook the fishy
and then when our cooking goes up,
we can start cooking other stuff
and making other stuff.
That brings even more...
hardcore bro, watch out.
Oh, no, the tail expires.
Give me, give me.
Never seen so many real players.
Oh, that's crazy.
Can we cook strong aid?
Don't cook the cuttlefish.
Oh, I put it in all caps, but it didn't work.
We're all bought some cute cuttlefish.
Calomari, no!
Let's see if they know the secret roofling handshake.
I'm a bot hooked up to chat.
Chat GPT's Johnny Cooks in her own way.
Pretending to be a human right now.
I'm behind a paywall.
Oh, it's fine.
Chat GPT nine goes bravery.
Amazing.
They're like, what on earth is going on?
Okay, we're actually doing really well.
Runfishing.exe, honestly.
I'm character AI.
Oh, you wanna, you wanna what?
You don't wanna kick the cuttlefish.
No, you don't.
Oh, we're leveling up.
I can hear reeflings getting levels.
I'm gonna go grabbing it.
Yes, we're gonna be here for a little while
until we stop burning the shrimpies.
Oh, wait, doesn't that fishing tutor give you a net?
Wait, come back.
You can hear me anymore.
I think that fishing tutor might give a net.
Can I head pat?
You can head pat the cuttlefish.
Bunch of randies.
Yeah.
Oh, we're randy already.
Are you sure?
This random guy is like, oh.
We're a bunch of randy andies.
Instructor Unclear stuck in there.
Oh, no.
Who's making the fire?
I'm making the fire.
Are you already full of inventory?
I'm not even full.
I feel so much more fishing to do.
Just run to the bank.
No, no.
I'll make a fire.
I'll be a moment.
Oh, someone made a fire.
There's a fire there if you need to cook.
I'm wondering.
I'm actually going to do something mildly controversial.
I'm going to move myself here.
So you can see my inventory.
There.
So now you can see my inventory as well.
Yeah, that's better.
And look, I'm touching text.
Um, um, um, um.
Um.
No, no, no.
Don't do anything.
Um.
Okay, I will go here.
So then you can see my thing.
Oh, RindLight just made me take a screenshot.
Wow, RindLight's actually getting cool for that.
I'm level three fishing.
See, that's how much I've hardly fished up anything.
Taking so long.
New Twitter audio, licking chat.
I mean, that audio I made yesterday was pretty cool.
She's now eating reeflings.
I saw a sea over.
You'd let me bite me.
There was an error generating a response.
Oh my God.
Are you guys trolling this guy?
It's like I'm seven again.
They're fishing levels.
Oh my God.
Level.
Level three.
Level three fishing bestie.
I'm just so good.
I'm actually just so good at fishing.
I say that as a fishing spot disappears right in front of me.
Strawny, if we eat shrimps, are we kind of accountable?
You're in for a rude awakening when you learn what fish eat.
So true.
So lame.
Oh my God.
I'm level three fishing too.
So win.
Wait, you can share your fishing rank like that.
How do we do that?
What the fuck?
What is going on?
I'm scared.
What happens if we tell them?
What happens if they're like oh we hate beet tube roosts?
I don't know if you can read that because I was quite far away.
We're Shrimp Maxing!
Shrimp Maxing Gang!
Well, I'm hopping gross!
Oh no!
So gross!
We out here Shrimp Maxing, literally Shrimp Maxing Gang.
He couldn't handle the odor.
Look, we are smelling quite fermenting.
Average MMO player when he sees other players!
Yeah, I'm getting out of here.
And then, and then he'll come play.
But oh, this is all bots and dead.
And then finally meets like a gang of folk.
And oh, yeah.
900 XP an hour.
One tick.
Shrimping for real for real.
What a shoooot.
Strawni's Fish and Error.
Not that you are.
One might say it smells quite fishy.
Drop the strat for one tick and for real for real.
And if you're new to RuneScape, if you hold shift,
you can drop your inventory once you click.
I am a beatbit bot.
Please contact Strawni if broken.
Honestly, do you think the Jagex team are like,
what in the earth is going on over here?
We never see this kind of a...
God, it takes so long.
I still don't have a full inventory.
My inventory.
I'm not feeling it.
Wait, you booped the beeps?
I beeped the boops.
Beep, boop.
Social interaction.
Eugh.
How much?
OK.
Oh, you guys are making fires.
Right, let's see what level we get once we have a full inventory.
500.
I booped the boop.
OK.
We're almost there.
I just need to pick up two more shrimp.
Do it.
Pick up two more shrimp.
Check out that long.
Pick up them shrimp.
Dropping is faster.
I threw them them on the ground.
I want the XP for fishing as well.
I say that as if it's not like 10 XP for a net.
Honestly.
Is strong a slang term too?
Oh, I'm strong in myself right now.
Honestly, I think it works.
Any stronger?
My inventory is fully F.
I'm literally missing one fish.
Like, please just fish it up.
Oh, my gosh.
Finally, you can't carry any more fish.
Just click the raw anchovies or fishies.
And then let's see how many we burn.
We burnt the first one.
Cook the same.
We burnt the next.
Yeah.
Inventory full begin walking.
Sequence find nearest fire, honestly.
I'm at work right now.
I feel like my boss is like, you're on RuneScape at work?
Isn't that dangerous?
Can't you not get fired for that?
Like, please don't get fired because you're
watching a RuneScape stream.
I'm literally going to be online for quite a while.
I don't know how long, but work from home gang.
Oh, OK, OK, OK.
I was going to say, imagine your boss walks past your cubicle
and all they see is me typing in chat.
I'm strong in myself right now.
Like, I'm just getting fired for a visa for worth it.
I hope no.
Wait, oh, no, the fire disappeared.
Sorry, I wasn't cooking that entire time.
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Look, I just get so distracted.
There's so many of you feeling threatened.
How am I supposed to not get distracted?
Oh, are we going to?
Level eight cooking.
Only another 91 to go because it's 99.
Is it technically?
Are you feeling a bit better?
I am.
I think I needed that food and just to kind of wake up.
I'm not sure why I felt so rough when I woke up,
but I feel better.
I've got food in my tum tum.
I've got a honey tea that I can't wait.
Getting a promotion from each of our boss
calls in on the office.
You're all she is based.
Technically, you're also playing RuneScape at work.
Oh, I wouldn't say streaming's work, honestly.
I'd say the only time it feels like work
is if I have to prepare.
Like, maybe for the game shows and stuff.
Level nine, by the way.
That's right.
Read them and wait for level nine.
Boss calls you in the office and says he's watching strongy too.
RuneScape takes no focus though.
OK, and now I am going to hold shift
and drop all these fricking, wait, hello?
Wait, no, why isn't it working?
I thought it was shift.
Is another shift to drop?
Is that am I going crazy?
I'm going to see.
Sorry.
Oh, it just seems everywhere.
Pardon me.
Wait, I could have sworn it was shift to drop things far.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, you guys are going to have to watch me manually draw.
Bless you.
I'm manually dropping.
Please don't look.
I'm so embarrassed right now.
Oh, I'm a bit of an imposter.
OK, it's setting.
Oh, it's a setting.
Is it actually?
Why are we going to not have it on the pen?
The pen, all settings.
But I did all settings.
It's not going to just show my IP address.
Is that controls?
Drop.
Game play.
Oh, this is too much.
I want to drop.
Click shift to drop items.
Beautiful.
I actually got that.
That was so good.
Right, hopefully my email address didn't show up.
I hate.
Oh, that's just how it is.
Right.
Oh, there we go.
Got it.
Right, and then we go back to fishing
because we're only level 99.
I'm going to check the Char View Cooking Gate.
We can do meat, chicken, and all that.
Trout is 15, which is a big startup rate.
So I guess we're doing this until 15.
And then we're going fishing elsewhere.
But as we level up, we get closer and closer.
Oh, my God.
Level four fishing, not to brag or anything,
but level four, all of us.
I'm pretty close.
Level fishing.
Wait, what?
Are you doing a command?
He's tapping a command.
Well, got run.
You catch the shrimp and burn them.
I'll burn them to hell.
Thanks for hanging.
See you when you come back.
Actually, I don't know.
I've not decided if it's an endurance stream yet.
Right now, we're just memeing and dreaming
and streaming and fishing.
And then we're fishing and we're cooking
and we're cooking and we're fishing.
My mind not working.
You just got to trust me for real, for real.
Don't worry, I do this all the time.
Don't worry.
Bye-bye.
Did you see it?
What?
What did I see?
The toenail?
Wait, what did I miss?
Was there something on stream?
I don't see it.
I see you guys.
We're all just hanging out.
Sorry, I've got gains to get.
Bye.
Bye-bye.
I don't have to go.
I don't think I was a roofling.
I was someone that was interested in what we were doing.
See how you feel like four hours go from there.
She literally at the start was, no, this will not
be an insurance human after a few hours.
She doesn't know anymore.
It's hard.
Just the bots hanging out doing a lot of bot things.
He wants to talk about his car's extended warranty.
Literally.
I do not want to talk to you.
Leave me alone, old man.
He's getting harassed by an NPC.
Shadow was rude when he get.
How purple are those anchovies?
Or shrimpies?
Oh wait, anchovies and shrimp are different?
Just tip some money for another four hours.
I'm like a reciprocal?
A reciprocal?
Donnie put text behind my screen.
OK, there.
Text doesn't go over me anymore.
Oh my god.
Leveling up, we're getting them gains.
I did not realize how slow fishing was to get.
My goodness.
Bye-bye.
She doesn't want to leave us, honestly.
Like after the...
So I can apply for monetization.
I'm going to apply after the stream and see what happens.
I don't know how long it's going to take.
But tomorrow's ASMR, so that's short.
And then the taste test and stream is short as well.
However, it might work out better because if I get
monetized, then I'm doing my pop-up monetization stream
surprise thing.
Oh no, I'm fishing where there's no fishie.
I wish you good luck on the money.
Yeah, basically YouTube just reviews the account and goes,
yeah, good to go.
Oh man, my bank is locked.
Can you hit me up again in three days?
I don't know what that means.
Back to fishing.
We're just fishing.
But yes, we're just going to level up as much as we can do
right now.
Any Ring Fit Adventure streams?
Yeah, 100%.
I absolutely adore Ring Fit Adventure.
It was really fun, as long as it's not dangerous for much.
Hard, but I'm pretty sure I got pretty high last time.
Do you have an idea of how many more watch hours you need?
Oh, I made watchers.
The problem was YouTube wasn't updating our stats for one week.
Like the stats are now behind one week.
Like it doesn't make sense.
So only now I can apply, even though after debut,
we had watch time.
Like it's just a bit silly, but we're submitting.
We also think now that we have one confirmed week of stats,
the culling stops here.
So you might be unsubscribed if you're watching in right now.
I don't know, but don't be afraid to like and subscribe.
The stream helps out, you know that jazz.
But we think the culling has stopped.
So a few ASMR group collabs and all that
are going to come out shortly after monetization.
Because the girls, some dummy used my email to make an account.
And one of the passwords I use, that's just a word.
As great news, ring fit my blood.
Please don't push yourself too hard like that one time.
I just really enjoyed it, but I can't do like, subscribe,
and send your bank card details.
Hell yeah.
Just thumbs up right now.
Thank you.
I don't know why, but I haven't been subbed on once.
Maybe it's because I got YouTube premium.
I don't know what caused it, because I did get marshmallows
that were like, no, I straight up got unsubbed by like three
of the girls that did this or whatever.
I don't know if it's also related to,
if you don't watch the girls like shorts,
or if you don't watch any content but subscribing,
then peace out, then YouTube don't like that.
And see it as bot activity, rather than someone
subscribing and being like, I'll come back later and watch this.
Like, not everyone watches YouTube shorts.
Which reminds me, I should have sent two shorts to Emmy
to review, because the editor had finished the shorts.
I'm going to do that after stream.
Solve by watching everyone.
Literally, if you watch their shorts,
or put some minutes and a watch time into them,
then I think YouTube doesn't take you.
I got unsubbed from some other VTubers pre-debut,
but not from any of the girls.
Good, good, that's what I like to hear.
So me subscribing just to support is pointless.
Oh no, like, actual YouTube subscribe is not pointless.
What happened was the accounts were getting called
because they were new, and for bot protection,
we were getting wrecked.
But we think now, because there's one week of confirmed stats,
it's over.
I don't think we got called at all recently,
like today, or when I was asleep, so.
Yeah, so I think it's only going up from here now, thankfully.
I checked the stats of everyone's accounts,
and we should have been at 5K right now,
but it's okay, we'll work back up towards it.
And yes, it's weird.
I know it's bot protection.
I had never experienced it before,
and me or my, it was aggressive on us, very aggressive,
but I do think it's, I genuinely do believe it's over,
especially once the girls get monetized.
I don't think you experience it as a monetized channel,
because that just seems a bit odd,
because they know if you're being watched by bots or not,
so.
Oh my God, my mind's a wrecking.
Okay, I'm gonna slip my, slip.
I'm gonna sip my tea, please.
Don't do anything to the slit, okay?
Oh, fuck.
Delicious.
But yes, I have a very fun collabs coming out soon, TM.
Ah, honey tea feels so good.
I can't wait YouTube to stop doing,
ah, literally, it's such a shame.
I felt so bad for the girls,
because we were like in the Discord,
and we're like, oh my God, we're at 3,000 subscribers,
oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, like,
getting ready to make, but like,
all of us held back from doing a celebration post,
because it just wasn't happening,
and it was such a shame.
I do have a special, like, congrats on 5K
for everyone post, and a 10K,
and then I don't know what's happening after that,
if I should order more artwork or not.
The 10K artwork is absolutely gorgeous,
so I can't wait for everyone to react to it.
But I can't, I can't let anyone know what it is.
I don't want to ruin the surprise.
Level 10 cooking!
We did it, we did it!
Are you squidding me right now?
Brian!
Can't wait.
My wallet is ready.
Ah, Pachinga, thank you very much for the tip again.
You can't wait for what?
The 10K?
It's already, it's free!
It's free to subscribe, young Uber.
How do you mean the...
Oh no, my fishy.
My fire keeps, the fire's pranking me.
It keeps disappearing as soon as I go get it.
I'm on level 11!
It stops you cooking every, every time it sells,
oh, I'm in the fire now,
I'm sacrificing myself for the...
Nothing interesting happens, use it on the fire.
I think they mean the soup with the membership.
Oh, sorry, sorry, my bad, my apologies.
Apologies, mate, I'm not that smart, okay?
I'm like kneeling out of the fire to cook these.
She, honestly, when I said I was cooking,
making veal or I wasn't kidding, okay?
I'm cooking by guess.
Okay, who is making that noise?
Sounds like someone's building something.
Building something?
Back to the kitchen.
We're getting, oh, pardon me, sorry.
Maybe we should be doing the cows, you know that,
so we can get, how to say it, so we can get combat
and maybe we can do a few more quests
that require a tiny bit of combat
so we don't get too wrecked.
Is there a timetable for super membership
or is it still soon?
It's still soon, basically, it's gonna pop up
once it happens, so we need to submit ourselves
and YouTube takes its sweet time to review it
and all of that, and once it's accepted,
it's up to the girls, whoop, by the pope!
Brian!
Brian, speak.
Anon, you didn't put anything in the box!
Thank you for the tip, Anon, I appreciate it.
I'm not gonna call you out
for not putting nothing in the box.
Hmm, but Brian didn't say anything
and congrats if your name's Brian,
you're gonna love these streams.
Ha, ha, ha, oh my God, wait, you must get startles.
I just got Brian, I don't know where.
Hmm, what's in the box?
Nothing!
Wasn't me in the donal, but still, LeMau.
LeMau, yeah.
If your name's Brian, you'll love my streams.
Maybe that should be my mole.
Ah, Brian!
Here's the nothing you ordered, miss.
Stop, no, I purposely didn't say anything
so you went tip again!
I purposely didn't say anything, Anon,
so you didn't do that, you giffy goober, stop it!
Here's that nothing you ordered.
Hmm, meh.
Yeah, you think you're so smart, you little sma,
you little, you setting up the desk right now, huh?
You twirling your hair?
You flicking your feet about the, I'm so smart.
Yeah, I'm such a smart, you're such a smart alec.
You're not smart, you know, on an anonymous?
You're such a smart alonimus instead of smart alec.
Oh, you know, I tried, I tried, okay, I tried.
I don't know, something, something, something.
Brian, Brian!
Brian, Brian said nothing.
Thank you, Brian, Brian.
Brian, Brian, Brian.
The one Brian in the chat right now,
his face is like, so red.
It's a smart fling.
Oh yeah, when reeflings are smart,
I'm gonna call them smartlings.
I wasn't even a joke, to be honest.
It wasn't even a joke, I just said what someone said in chat.
Hee hee hee.
Don't mind me.
I just got here.
He says I just got here at Lamo.
Stop, that is terrible.
I didn't add any more sound effects.
I was busy, I was busy.
I need to think about, what's a terrible joke
that no one likes?
What is the difference between a legume and a chickpea?
I've never had a legume on my face before.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll be here all week.
Get it?
Do you get, actually, A.C. should probably tell that joke.
Why was the pony taking cough medicine?
Cause he was a little horse.
Oh, oh sorry, I thought that was a good one.
My bad, my bad.
Hee hee hee hee.
A horse goes to the bar.
The bar man asks, why the long face?
Oh, okay, okay, no more, no more, no more, no more jokes.
Sorry guys, sorry, sorry.
Two blondes walk into a bar.
You'd think one of them would have seen it.
It's like the goofiest gimmick ever, okay?
Someone says, hey, strongy guess what?
That's right, we're talking in chat and in stream
at the same time.
I chuckled chicken butt.
Someone said they chuckled.
We should level up jokes instead of cooking.
Oh God, are we that bad?
Are we joked?
Sheebie slander?
Wait, how?
Comedian opens a comedy date.
Are you, all right, okay, okay, hold on.
Are you all right?
No, you're all left.
We're getting like five eggs.
Deeper hour with these jokes, honestly.
Wait, are you guys are just giving me jokes to say?
Two fish are in a tank.
One turns to the other and asks,
how are you, do you drive this thing?
I'm just stealing your jokes.
I'm not even delivering them the way a comedian should.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, level 12 cooking.
We can do trout soon.
I feel like I'm taking damage of the emotional cane.
Listen.
Getting your material, these are terrible.
A guy walks in a bar and says,
oh, that was the blonde joke.
Two blondes walk into a bar.
You think one of them would have seen it?
Hmm.
I'm not burning too much.
We're doing all right, we're doing all right.
Oh, level 13.
We're really not burning that much then
if we're getting this fast.
I don't know what level you stop burning shrimp at, but yeah.
Reading the black ops will give me
PTSD flashbacks to second chance.
Honestly, that perk was so annoying.
I remember being Tismo enough
that I remembered if people were using it in SMD.
So I would keep fricking spraying until they were dust.
I could tell you the best knock knock joke
if you want to go on them.
I ain't got a song on board for nothing.
Where do cows go on days?
The movies.
Oh, did you already hear that one?
Okay, sorry.
God, you guys are, you get a tough crowd.
Tough crowd to do, honestly.
Tough crowd.
Some of you guys, okay.
Two muffins are baking in an oven.
One muffin says, boy, it sure is hot in here.
The other says, oh my God, a talking muffin.
Oh, didn't like that one.
You guys are really...
Two hydrogen atoms were walking down the street
when one turns to the other.
Oh dear, I've lost an electron.
Really?
Are you sure?
I'm positive.
Oh, oh, you guys know your physics.
You paid attention in physics class.
Lovely, lovely.
That's what it is.
What do you do when you cross a cow in an octopus?
Cowamari.
I think I'm gonna get kicked off stage.
I'm getting, I'm getting on.
I am, he goes, please stop.
I'm dying.
Right, right.
We'll give that a break.
No more, no more.
I don't know much about real physics,
but I studied VTuber physics.
Oh, did you hear Twitch updated its terms of service
and the VTubers have to be held to the same standard
as flesh tubers?
And everyone like, why did you pick YouTube?
I've told many times, and I'll tell again,
you cannot run a manager account on Twitch as well.
Well matters.
Strony's good jug dropery is one out of 5,000.
Oh, that's rough.
That's a rough dropery.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Brian!
What is the difference between the sea and Strony?
Strony always tastes like fish.
Brian!
You got the, wait, what?
Did I understand that?
Iron Reaper?
Thank you for the tip.
What's the difference?
Oh wait, I don't even take off.
What's the difference between the sea and Strony?
Strony always tastes like fish.
The sea doesn't taste like fish.
Huh?
What?
Like saltwater?
I don't get it.
Oh, you want Brian to do jokes more than me?
You'd rather frickin' TTS Brian make the jokes than me.
Oh, okay.
Oh, okay, I see who it is.
She kept telling us to be positive.
It's hard without her.
Oh wait, sorry, I missed the start of your joke.
I think I just read the end of your joke.
Oops, I just read the punchline of a joke.
Easy.
Brian has some real comedic timing, to be fair.
What?
Brian is better at delivering the jokes.
Sorry, Strony, no fair.
Yeah, I'm gonna fuck you in.
Oh, when I went for a pee, I hardly peed, so I need it.
I'm gonna force myself to hydrate quite a lot
in the next few moments, cause I'm gonna forget.
How many tickles does it take to make a squid laugh?
Tentacles!
Oh, that's a cute one.
I like that one.
I like that one, that's a good one.
Miss Strony, this is my first stream of yours,
and I find it extra uncanny
that you're actually funny saying my real name so much.
Oh, it's because the TTS, the text to speech,
if someone don't knows, his name is Brian,
so I always scream Brian,
cause he interrupts me when I'm talking,
cause I talk so much.
I don't think the TTS has ever interrupted me
when I'm not talking.
I don't even think that's possible.
Brian, that announcement, yes.
Sorry, I'm really trying to finish this bottle of water.
What's Brian's Oshi mark?
Well, we'll make Brian a V-shaver.
We'll get, instead of Neurosama,
we've got Brian Samus.
Two eggs in a pan.
One says to the other, it's boiling in here.
The other says, wait until you get out of here
and smack you in the head.
I need to add, you're making me wanting to add,
like wha wha wha wha wha.
Yes, Scott.
Scott's are want to talk, after all,
and I wish, man, true true.
I have a lot of jokes about unemployment.
Sadly, none of them work.
Oh, who goes there?
How does a squid go into battle, well armed?
Get it, cause squids have eight arms, not eight legs.
People think it's eight legs, but it's not,
but it's cause it's like a misconception
that octopi have eight legs.
Hmm.
Add a boo, you suck.
Honestly, I probably should.
I want to add a wha wha wha, you suck.
Are you squidding me right now?
Brian!
A bear walks into a bar and asks for a gin and tonic.
The bartender serves them and asks, why the big pause?
The bear holds up its front legs and says,
because I'm a bear.
Are you squidding me right now?
That was terrible, reluctantly saying.
Impossible to not interrupt you when you're always yapping.
Scott, help me out here.
I was quiet for once,
cause I was letting Brian tell his little joke.
Thank you, reluctantly saying for the tip.
And the terrible joke.
And...
Oh, I get the joke now!
Oh, no, the joke's actually pretty smart.
I'm sorry, there was like three little dots.
It says, a bear walks into the bar and asks for a gin and tonic.
The bartender serves them and says,
why the big pause?
As in pause in your sentence.
And he says, I'm a bear.
As in big pause.
I'm sorry.
I never got that the first time.
Or if on biscuit impossible to not interrupt you.
I'm sorry, I wasn't thinking, I'm sorry.
Did you hear about the guy who got connected?
Why, OBS?
My OBS just is connected, but I'm still in game.
I'm still here.
Why does OBS do that?
It just connects me for a millisecond and it gives me a heart attack.
Why?
Why did they do that?
I said I disconnected for a second.
I really dislike when OBS keeps doing it.
I don't know if it's my internet or OBS.
We are so back.
Yeah, literally back on stream lots.
Where's Johnny?
I'm back.
I've been sabotaged by the BC boys.
It's time for sabotage.
Do you like when I pretend to be a guitar?
Do you remember that Star Wars movie?
Where that was how they defeated the enemies.
I thought it was the coolest thing ever.
I loved it.
And I cried at the other Star Trek movie that came out.
I said Star Wars.
I meant to say Star Trek.
Sorry, pardon if I said Star Wars.
The Star Trek movie and then sabotage.
How do you call a cow with no legs?
Grim beef.
Thank you.
I came up with myself.
Totally didn't read it from my wreath on Indie.
Karaoke where you just provide the guitar sense.
Eww.
I just heard the cat.
The jokes are too much for the server.
I think I'm killing you guys with the sound board now.
I think we need to maybe give up a bit of a rest.
You got me so confused where you said the Star Wars movie.
That became Star Trek.
Yeah, sorry.
Sorry.
AC DJ Streamer you girls make an instrument noises.
Brian!
Yeah, that's what you get.
That's what you get, Anon.
Thank you for the tip.
Honestly, that wasn't that bad.
I'll level 14!
Over.
Oh, the fire.
The fire playing a little prank on me.
Hold on, the fire's playing a prank on me.
Thank you for the tip.
It was actually not a bad joke I'll give you.
Everyone knows that Star Wars and Star Trek are the same thing.
No, it was me on my song.
I really like, I really, I cried at the Star Trek movie.
I'm like a little baby.
Is it the radiation scene where he goes inside the chamber
and Spock is like,
and
if you've not seen the Star Trek movie, cover your ears.
He's got the original fricking.
Is it Leonard, Leonard Hoffman?
The, you know, Hoffman?
Oh, I can't remember his name.
I can't remember his name.
You know what I mean, you know what I mean.
He was in the original Spock.
Got to meet Spock in the movie and it's crazy.
Leonard Nimoy.
Any Leonard Nimoyers?
Right, are we staying here until level 20?
Are we moving on to Trout?
What are we?
What's the plans, Rifle?
And you guys are kind of in charge here.
As much as I like to pretend that I'm the one in charge,
you guys are actually in charge here.
Do we?
Let's just take a little look at the cooking guide.
Hmm, yes, yes.
A bit of, let's see what we're looking at for the, the meats.
No, the fish.
Okay, I guess fish is under meat.
We've unlocked Trout,
so we could go a barbarian village.
I believe they dropped Trout and Salmon over there.
What do you call a cow with one leg steak?
What do you call a cow with two legs, Limby?
Yeah.
What do you call a cow with three legs?
Tri-tip.
You can see if the crash occurs because the internet would be us itself.
Leonard Nimoy.
Yes, the famous voice of old Zihar Nort from combat.
KH, I don't know.
I don't know why I was gonna say Mortal Kombat.
I still love playing Civilization 4, just to hear his voice over.
Barb Village, the classic, we're in charge, huh?
Can I tell a dark joke?
As long as it's not gonna be offensive.
My password had to be eight characters, so I picked Snow White and the Seven Dwarves.
Oh, that's good, I like that one.
Don't challenge Death to a pillow fight unless you're ready for repercussions.
My plan is to fall strong.
Okay, we are gonna head to Barbarian Village, so drop all your fishy-fishies.
We are gonna rely on...
Oh, wait!
Wait, can we even fish?
I don't know if we can even fish.
I think we need a fishing rod, and we can't even fish because we're too low level.
We're too low level?
For fishing? For fish?
Oh, we need 20 fish!
Okay, it doesn't matter, we're gonna stay here.
You don't have a rod?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, it doesn't change your plan, sorry.
I reached overall level 150, let's go.
Actually, MLG, MLG, you can borrow mine.
Shabby!
And the harem, not to be confused with harem.
How's the harem and the sheepsters going on?
How did the shroom go?
Got a rod right here for ya.
Pants grab.
Okay, I guess we're just gonna be fishing and going for it,
because we can't even do fly fishing to get our own.
But we are, literally, we started on 7 and we're level 15 already.
And that's without getting the big stuff.
Shabby raid!
Hi, harem.
I was gonna say haremby, but rip haremby.
Bunny raid!
Hello, hi guys.
Today, I am playing Old School RuneScape,
which you're more than welcome to join in on.
We are achieving level 99 cooking.
We are just at the bottom of Lumberge Castle near the mines,
and we, I know, I know, haremby, my brain, because of the spell,
and we are currently just fishing to cook,
and then we're gonna move on shortly.
Who's online?
Who's online today?
I actually can't remember everyone's schedule.
Mercy normally comes online in quite a bit.
I wanted to play with you, but my internet is absolutely...
Oh, well, we are at the bottom of Lummi, if you ever wanted to join,
but if your internet is crap in the bed.
Is it not in me?
Is in me?
In me is coming on in an hour.
That's correct.
Brian!
Why are snails bad at racing?
They're sluggish.
Oh, so when Brian makes a joke, you all laugh,
but when I make a joke, I don't get none.
Thank you, Sherm Tank, for the don't know.
Again, everyone's laughing at Brian's jokes,
but when I make the joke, it's terrible.
In me, in me, coffin game!
Oh, we're stream sniping in me.
Hold on.
Is she playing the coffin game?
I want to see her reaction to it.
I was gonna get a highlight reel made of that string.
I'm sorry, strongy.
Brian is funny, and you're a woman.
You're not supposed to say that part out loud.
That's an inside thought.
Because it's actually witty, right?
Right, you're done.
You're done.
Brian's stream, strongy's stream.
Shocking behavior.
Oh, there's an uncut emerald.
Why did you drop it?
You can use that for crafting later.
I'm yonking it.
Mine now.
Sorry, that emerald's mine now.
I'm keeping a hold of that.
You can craft it.
She sniped it.
Wait, do you want it?
Do you want it back?
I can give you a back.
You can...
She went for the uncut one.
Oh, you're done.
You're done.
Oh, you're already 99?
What the heck level are you?
125?
What does that mean?
You want to eat, literally, green and shiny.
I'll take it.
Come on, it's me.
It's strongy, green and shiny.
Oh!
What is that?
Is that a shield?
No.
That's awful.
I can't look at it properly
because of the way the camera angle's working this game.
Look at that shield.
Can't give up.
Strongy, what do you call a man with no arms, no legs,
and lives in a...
In a tiger cage.
Claude.
Cloud?
What?
Did you hear the joke about strongy?
It was incredible!
Oh, thank you.
Okay, I can fish for herring,
but I don't want to do that.
I'm going to be able to fish out.
Am I playing the coffin game so on current?
Yeah.
I'm interested and see what her reaction is.
I don't know what it's going to be.
That joke fell a little short.
Aw, this is incredible.
It's a pine.
Piney.
Gonna walk my dog.
Look, time.
Walk you look.
Hi strongy, how's the runescaping?
We are level 15!
In 99, on the road to 99, cooking.
We took our sweet time,
but we did some questing,
which was a bag of fun.
I have no idea how long we're streaming for today.
Jokes about strongy are usually sure of fault.
Shoot.
Oh, and I'm starting.
Okay, I just got annihilated because I started.
I'm sorry, I can't even make a comeback to it now.
If I wanted...
If I wanted a comeback,
I'd scrape it off your mose teeth.
That's disgusting.
Oh wait, maybe I should have done that.
I probably should have done that one.
Don't forget, level 92 is halfway.
Oh, we're getting close to 92.
I can feel it in my bones.
Feel it in my bones.
Are you actually going for 99?
Yeah, I want to do it live with you guys.
I think it would be so fun if we all do.
And literally, Refling gave me a boatload of fish to cook.
So once I stop burning fish,
I'm going to use them.
And I think that's going to propel me quite a lot.
I want to do it all live on stream,
and it's not going to be behind a member stream or anything.
You guys can...
We're going to need a bigger boat, I know.
You guys can literally come and join me at any point as well
when we do these kind of stream snipe things.
I also give you a boatload of money.
Yes.
A Refling gave me 10 million GP.
I'm like,
Jagex is looking at the account like she's clearly bought right now.
I have zero.
Wait, you want to do it with us live?
Yeah.
ASMR.
I have zero idea how RuneScape plays.
My friends just post images of the animal models in the game,
and they look very funny.
Can I get a Refling pet?
I don't know how to get a pet in the game.
Oh my god.
Is there like a pet that looks like a Refling?
Gold laundering.
Literally, Jagex is staring at my account right now.
Could you imagine if I got banning at Jagex
and be like,
Hey, my account name's Scottlefish.
I know it looks...
I got banned because you guys thought I was like money buying GP or something.
I'm actually just a Vtuber and we're all hanging out.
Please, I'm banned.
Is there a pet cracking?
Oh, I can't.
Oh, Ally.
I just got a shock on my arm there.
That wasn't supposed to happen.
I don't know how I did that.
I think I accidentally jammed my elbow in the nerve crack.
There's nine pets.
How did you even get those emotes on screen?
Gold laundering.
If they ban you, it's because they...
They heard the joke.
Crack and deez.
Nevermind, please don't.
Look, all hail the fire.
All hail the fire.
I'm getting close to the next level.
I keep burning.
Look how much I'm still burning.
I'm like burning massive amounts.
I wonder when you stop burning shrimpies.
Maybe level 20?
I feel like that's like over-leveled.
For the fire.
Wah, 16!
Let's go.
Maybe a pet slug.
Slugs are close to Carlfish.
Yeah.
She is not cooking.
Literally, everything's burning.
I'm like missing out on so much HP.
XP.
There.
Hopefully the fishing gets a bit faster
because seriously, this is taken forever
at this fishing base.
Juke pet is closest to a slug.
Are we sluggy-wuggy?
What do you call a man with no arms
and no legs on your front porch?
Matt.
Congrats if your name's Matt.
Shout out to Matt.
You guys are going to start sending puns
where the finishing line is like actual names.
I got true.
I got true. You can start cooking at 15.
Oh, you got me?
My inventory.
Woah!
Reefling!
That's so much!
Oh my god.
Thank you.
This will definitely go...
We're probably going to artificially inflate.
Thank you, Reefling.
I appreciate that.
I think when we get cooking level 20,
we'll take off and see
if we can
snipe some fishies.
Uh...
How you...
Barbarian Village.
There's normally bots always running up Barbarian Village.
And we can literally pick up the fish
that's on the floor.
My only worry is that it might be
quiet and we might have to swap
to a different server.
Who owns this hill?
We don't know. We're ten ants.
Okay.
You're done. You're done. Get out of here.
I guess the riveting gameplay,
the overruns get riveted and literally
just click and point similar.
But look how many Reeflings there are. Seriously.
This is all chilling.
It's a bit chilly.
Hydration check.
I'm really needing a hydrate.
Oh! That was like bats coming out of him.
Barbarian Fishing Spot on World Through 1
is one of the greatest free-to-play areas.
Okay. We'll probably do that next.
Mmm. Oh, do you want me to be reactive?
Oh, that really didn't...
Yeah. Okay. Maybe not reactive today.
Maybe another day.
You'll have to hate the chat though.
Oh, because it's boss.
Are you squiddin' me around?
Brian!
Brian, that's inappropriate!
Thank you, Iron Ripper, for the tip.
I can so cook some pains, okay?
I'm getting there.
You know?
Got to let me...
Got to let me get a bit more experienced.
Jesus walked into a hotel
and tossed three nails on the counter
and said, put me up for the next...
Ooh!
I don't...
I'm not sure if I can do that.
I'm not sure if we're going to do a sound reaction to that one.
Wait.
The cuttlefish cooking fish.
No! It's the circle of life for fishes.
They eat each other.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, my God. Is the fishing going faster?
I literally caught two in a row there.
I need one more and I level up.
Mmm.
Ah! Went away.
Wait, does that mean you eat reeflings?
Only the ones that want board.
I can bring you back up again if you want.
Oh, like a cat!
It's...
All these jokes are really cracking me up.
Oh, shucks, guys.
I love the way you hate me up.
You're so good.
You're so good to me.
Hello! Hi, hi!
We're playing Old School Brits' Game.
And we're leveling up.
Who's driving this thing?
Mmm.
My only concern
cooking trout right now, even though I'm leveled,
is I'm just going to burn it
all, which is such a waste.
I don't want it to be a waste.
Yeah.
It's a gang, gang, gang, gang.
Gang, gang, gang, gang.
Is that a new reefling?
Identified.
That reefling's beating up that route.
My son had been
eating electrical cords.
What did I do? Grandumentally conduct myself.
Right, right.
You know what? Sound effect.
Oh, I got 4K.
Did I finally reach 4K subscribers?
But we didn't get called this time.
A Christmas miracle.
Thank you for everyone
who has subscribed. I appreciate it greatly.
I will start to...
Once I get monetized, I will start to
slip out the
subscriber
and thank you ASMR videos very shortly.
But thank you so much. Don't jinx it.
I don't know.
Now that we've got our YouTube stats updated,
I'm going to apply for monetization
and then I think the culling just stops after that.
I did the same to Sheebie
and nothing happened.
I think
it's over. I do think it's over.
Did you know
that in every 5 years,
the Red Deer in Scotland have to be culled
over running the forest because
wolves used to be a natural
predator
in the United Kingdom.
But then once they were eradicated,
basically the deer,
obviously their population just went crazy.
Man, I used to play this with my cousin
and friend after school when I was younger.
My name was...
Ay yo, don't put your gamer tie.
What do you call a Scotsman
who is standing in the doorway?
who is standing in his...
Oh, home.
Okay, you're done.
You're done.
Heim is slang for
home
in my bit means my house
in Scots.
I struggle
with Roman numerals
until I get to 159.
Then I just click.
Oh, then it just clicks.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to open up marshmallows in a minute.
If we get any more puns, you're all done.
I tell you more puns,
but I'm not feeling very punny.
Okay, okay, I get it, I get it.
Yo, just one Brian.
Whoa, I'm actually not...
Oh, I took this...
I was going to say I'm actually not burning that much.
I burned two so far.
Did I take part in the deer calling?
I did not.
I just know...
I just remember reading it in a book
and I was like, yeah, that makes sense.
Needs the marshmallows for the campfire.
Why
is Jesus the worst teammate
in an online shirt? Take some 3D...
Okay, you're done, you're done.
No more puns.
We love Brian. Yeah, clearly you love Brian.
You'll laugh when it's his joke,
but when it's my joke, um, crickets.
Wow.
Cooking, best I can do is burn meat.
Literally, I'm burning so much still.
I'm like, getting pretty high level.
I feel like...
All things considered, hold on, let me check.
Um, yeah.
I'm 17 cooking and I'm still burning shrimp.
I feel like 15 should have been the shrimp cut off.
If a shrimp is a one level one, um,
like cut off,
I feel like burnt shrimp is a lot.
Emmy's gone live in 5 minutes,
playing the coffin of her lore video.
And before anyone says,
did your development team just copy that game?
No, actually, no one in the development team
had played the game at the point she was conceptualised.
She was conceptualised in my image,
because
Con of Bro is the best,
and I don't care what anyone says.
Hmm.
Don't be jealous of Brian,
only because he makes better jokes.
I mean, yes, true, but you have other qualities.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Andy and Lily.
Where should you go if you can't stop
reciting Scottish poetry?
Ah, then no one's gonna get that.
Rabby Burns is one of her famous poets.
Who come and talk to me?
Oh, someone wants to trade with me.
Sorry, I missed it. Sorry, I don't know who's sending me a trade-off.
I apologise.
What?
What is that?
Reefling.
Is that gold?
It's gold!
No way!
I'm literally warting,
literally level 17 cooking,
and I'm dripped out in the gold.
Reefling!
Thank you!
Oh my god, I'm stunned.
Hold on, I need to do a little dance.
I need to show it off.
Wait, let me go in the hell so you can all see me, okay?
Alright, I need to face you from the hell.
So I'm on the hell, and you face there.
Ready? Ready? We go stunned on them.
We go stunned.
Hey, that's right. Hey, a little parallel.
See it from the back, see it from the back.
Yeah, that's right, do a little dance.
That's right, that's right, stunned on them.
Dancing.
That's right, gold, gold, gold, baby.
Yeah, we love...
I love the head.
Bang a mot is absolutely awful.
That is awful, that mot.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we love gold, play an apron over here.
Thanks, god, you are cute.
Brian!
Ooh!
Oh no, TTS didn't meet that out.
Oh no.
Or did it? Did I talk over it? I'm sorry.
Brian, Iron, thank you for the tip again.
You can't cook, you can't make jokes.
Yeah, you are cute.
So the thing I got from me.
We started out and we blown them a kiss.
You want to beat me?
Oh, you want to beat me because I've got that gold?
Oh yeah, you do.
Panic. Oh, look at that.
Hey, hey, hit him with the knees.
Hit him with the knees.
Oh my god, that's so good.
Okay, fashion shows over.
Folk straight back to the sleeve mill.
Over again.
Oh my god, we hit him with the knees.
Oh, that was so good.
The drip is so good.
Thank you so much for playing.
You are throwing everything into that head bang.
Honestly.
Blowing out your back.
What?
Blowing out your back?
You want to blow my back out?
Oh my god.
I love the gold.
It so doesn't match my green or purple,
but I don't care.
It's so good.
I didn't even know you could get
golden chef's hat and stuff.
The fact that I'm level 17 in cooking
makes it even funnier that I'm dripped out
in golden chef stuff.
Honestly.
Time's straight.
The richest and most popular
cooking rinse scape, honestly.
Wait, hold on.
No.
It's Emmy.
Is it real Emmy?
Are you guys fricking throwing as Emmy?
Except trade.
Is Emmy here?
Or is Emmy doing this right before her stream?
Emmy, is that you?
Emmy?
Is that her?
Emmy? She's giving me her coins
from Starter Island.
Her 25 coins.
Emmy?
Is it imposter?
If it's Emmy, it would be like, no way.
It's a new account. She gave me her...
She gave me the coins from
Tutorial Island.
Little sister?
Say two?
Oh, I need to give her bad French.
Oh, thank you for the bond offer.
I bought membership for a month. Thank you so much.
Please keep that bond for yourself.
I have membership for a month. I think we're going to try
and do 99 cooking in a month.
Thank you so much for that offer, though. I really appreciate that.
Really do.
Is that a bond?
Is that Emmy?
Do we know if it's Emmy?
She's going to build up stream and she's either
going to be all cheeky and like,
of course that was me.
Or she's going to be like, what?
Rins...what? Rinscape?
I've never played Rinscape before.
I've never played that game before.
Oh my god, Stroneys, why are you coded?
Rinscape.
Scaling costume homie is probably
in there. Wait, what?
Are we getting bullies?
Are we bullying each other?
We better not be.
She's...
Hope on the phone.
Can't wait for the 99 Kicking.
Your fish dates will be fantastic.
Oh.
That was actually pretty good.
Who wants to trade?
Who...who is yummy?
Who is yummy?
I thought it said who is Emmy. I've got Emmy on my mind now.
Oh, oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Refluence, how are you also
reflate?
Bro, we need to take this to the bank like right now.
I cannot be standing with this much money on me.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
What? What? How are you also rich in this game?
Oh, you can't be telling your ages.
A.C. is going to be happy that you're all
O.G. sons.
She's going to be in an extra smug about it.
Agnashia.
How are you also rich in this game? How do you
make money in this game, honestly?
Maybe we should...
Winner.
I'm about to level up. What level?
I said I'm about to level up.
Okay, there we go. 18
Kooten. Okay, that's good.
We're so close to 20.
Maybe we should stick around.
Oh my God, look how much...
Look at the fat stacks.
Like, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh.
How?
Oh gosh.
Right, we do that.
They make money selling the food you cook.
Oh my God, cooked fish runs?
It was...
my non-Iron Man account.
Ah, since I can't trade on that.
Oh, is you can prompt? Yeah, I get it.
I get it.
Is this an original couple?
Oh, it's Lou.
Amy is on her loading screen.
Who knows what she's doing behind that screen?
I'd buy food from Strawni.
Yeah, would you?
Would you buy my homemade ink?
Or would you like it?
Great.
Right.
If Amy's on her loading screen,
mods may you please post
Emicals is linked.
And can you guys please interrogate her
and say is she on RuneScape
or is someone...
someone larping as my little sister?
I want my real little sister.
Amy's life story...
That's awful. Who named that?
I don't know.
Music's so nice and chill.
But yes, Amy is going live
with the coffin of Andy and Laylee.
It's a bit of a reading simulator, just warning for those.
Make sure you tell her to hydrate through it
if she's going to be reading absolutely everything.
Because, oh my gosh.
Hmm.
She said nah.
Who is larping as my little sister?
Giving me 25 coins.
Is that my 20%
that you gave me?
What color is the ink?
It's been described as
glippy.
Someone...
Actually, I said this the other day.
Whoever said it's like
a male jar, you're done.
I don't know who said that.
Hello reflings!
Oh, and you really refling joined the fray.
Yes, we're on World 388
and we're at the bottom of...
We're south of Lumberge Castle
at the mining slash fishing tutorial
area.
Or to the east of the swamp
under Lumberge...
to Castle.
If she knows nothing,
she's going to like it for sure.
Andy and Lele
is a mess up game.
It has very unique story plot.
Oh, please keep going.
You cast your net.
We're almost 20 cooking.
When we're 20 cooking, we're going to move on
to the next place.
Which is Barbarian Village.
I don't know if there's going to be bot spam in there.
I could have sworn I came across a religion bot
before that was spamming.
And I was like, there is no way
someone's paying
for that. It was the most bizarre thing.
This place
has got to smell terrobin.
Literally rotten fish on the floor
everywhere. Burnt fish, cooked fish.
Like, the whole
of Gelenor can smell our operation
front over here.
Wah, hydration, hydration, hydration.
Woof woof
How is our fishing level so low?
What is it?
Our fishing is 12,
but our cooking is all the way up at 18.
They did not have to
look so hard on the music in this game,
but so good.
Oh my god, we're getting flexed on.
Someone's got a fishing rod.
Actually getting flexed on, hold on.
Is that how you pick up anchovies
by the fishing rod?
Well, Amy's going to force chat to get her
down.
There's only,
all I'm going to say is there's only one
way to finish that game.
There's only one way to finish that game.
You should work in the seafood business
on the floor.
Imagine getting followed by
Jehovah's Witnesses, even an old school
runes game, honestly!
There's bots, like, and it's like,
why? You get more XP
for cooking rather than fishing.
Yeah, there's only one
real ending to that game.
And I will accept no other.
Mmm, any food by
Strongly Seafood.
If I see it, I eat it.
Ooh, that's good, I like that.
Could I interest you
in our Lord and Savior? Yeah,
have you heard of our Lord and Savior, Brian?
Honestly.
I think, I can't remember
if I said this or not. I thought
they were just shouting out, like, randomly.
I would just shout, like, the most common, like,
boy names and, like, a chance
for someone to hear their name.
Just play Jack!
And then we just go back to the gameplay
and I play Nothing Happened.
What's another popular boy name?
I have no idea. Jacob!
Oh, there we go.
And then we just go back to the gameplay.
I play Nothing Happened.
Just, like, freak out whoever's listening in
and just be like, oh my god, that's my name.
I don't know.
That's popular.
Okay.
Little inventory.
Okay, now you just pin your own...
Oh, John's the comment.
John!
Andrew, wake up!
Hey.
Oh, Joseph, there's a lot of J names.
J-J-J-John.
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude...
The fire is tricking me again.
I don't know.
I'll see what I can do. I don't know.
I find it fun, like, kind of trolling a bit like that
and you just, like, secretly...
I know! Yeah, see?
I wanted... I'm actually gonna...
I'll spoil this.
I want to do a hypnosis-themed audio
where I get you to forget
your name and respond to wefling.
I think that'd be pretty cool.
But I will put, like,
wears off after like 30 minutes type thing.
I don't want anyone panicking thinking they're,
they're gonna like pair them up, forget their name.
If you say Brian three times in front of a mirror,
you can summon him and he tells us a pun.
Mmm.
19, oh, we're so close, we're so close.
Maybe like one more rack of fish and then we're done.
If I don't burn any,
actually they're really starting not to get burnt.
I'm really happy with that.
Oh, that's someone cutting down a tree.
That's what that noise is.
I just couldn't hear it.
Ripped to all those with this obscure,
yeah, like that's the only reason I was like,
oh, it's probably not that fun for those
who have like obscure name type thing going on.
No strong, you make it so it never wears off.
No, I have to make it wear off.
I'm not really into perma effect hypnosis.
It's just not for me.
Um, rather a bit, a bit scared of it.
Are you slidding me right now?
Brian.
Anakin, start panicking.
I don't have a planakin.
Banana, Anakin.
Thank you for the tip, Iron Weeper.
There was a really popular meme about Anakin
and it was like Bananakin and that was the meme.
And it had everyone in hysterics.
It had them in a choke hold for years.
Absolute shawng behavior, shawng.
Because thanks for the tip.
Anakin, start panicking.
I don't have a planakin.
That sounds like that song.
Here comes Michael Finnegan.
He had whiskers on his chin again.
Sutton, Sutton.
Back to the begin again.
Da, da, da, da, da.
I can never remember.
The best you're getting at me is twinkle twinkle little star.
You'll either take it or leave it.
Maybe Vader some day later.
Oh, I don't remember that part.
I remember the Yoda song where it goes like.
Oh, someone dropped a party hat.
Oh, we can put.
Oh, I've got my chef's hat.
Look, reflings.
Look, look, look.
There's party hats if you want to put them on
because it's a party.
Oh, look at the box coming over from the main.
Look.
Oh, there's a Santa hat.
There's a red party hat.
There's a white party hat.
Ooh.
And there's burnt fish.
Oh, there's one over there and there's a Santa hat.
Ready?
Whoa.
Thank you to ever drop them.
Oh, look, you're opening your party hats on.
Look at your party.
It's a party in the south of Lumbridge.
Yeah.
The little party hat.
Oh, look at you.
Go.
Go get your fancy party hats.
Look at yours.
What's up, party people?
Go.
Can we ask the chat to speak German?
I don't know if the bot filters are non-English words
because I've said it up as an English thing.
Why can't Mickey Mouse flying his plane to Scotland
at Disneyland?
You didn't know.
Just say it does not in Scots.
You say it does me.
I don't know why.
If I have to explain the joke because of flying,
how are Santa hats 16K?
I don't know.
Can't speak German and can't speak Dutch.
OK.
These puns were not I wanted.
I need a refund.
He, he, he.
That was good, actually.
I'll give you that one.
I'm giving you that one.
Yeah, I don't know what the bot does and doesn't like
in terms of TTS at the moment.
OK, we're definitely fishing a lot.
Where is my refling for sexy fire making?
I would like to summon one fire please.
I'm going to dance until the fire appears.
OK, let's dance.
Hey, hit him with the spin, hit him with the spin.
Hey, little Irish jig.
Hey, hey, hey, stop, stop, stop.
Head back.
Hey, hey, hey, get him with the yawn.
That does not look like a yawn.
Yeah, really?
Strongy, you are my leader, Schmetterling.
Leader Schmetterling, but is Schmetterling in English?
What is Schmetterling?
Is that called fishing?
Is that called fishing German?
Is that what it means?
Thank you for the tip, Iron Reaper.
A butterfly.
Hi, hi, hi.
I'm here to the butterfly.
Please make a move.
Put the colors in the sky.
Ah, hee, hee, hee.
Where's fire?
Right, I'll go get a fire.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm on the fire.
Oh, wait, I found the fire.
I'm blind.
I'm just blind.
I need my glasses on.
Sorry.
Sorry, there's a fire down here.
Hey, strongy, do you have a party hat?
I have an extra one.
I have, sorry, to, you know, kind of flex on the peasants,
but on my head is gold in crusted chef's hat.
I must stick to my gold in crusted chef's hat.
Thank you very much for your offer.
Super kind.
You know, I don't want to flex on them peasants below me,
but I'm kind of styling with the combo of gold apron and gold hat.
Wouldn't be super awesome if the player entered
the group and discovered the shroom thingy to come here.
If I play, oh, like someone just joins along.
Well, I don't know if you're, we told some, they were like,
what's going on?
And I was like, oh, some cringe VTuber's shroom in.
And they were like, I'm world hopping.
And I was like, OK, thanks for announcing it.
Literally, no one cares, thanks.
Am I level, am I level 19 still?
I am like two fishies away from 20.
And then we're going to move to Barbarian Village,
which is west of the Grand Exchange.
Strona has power to actually do it in crusted chef's hat.
Weird flex.
That happened to me in Final Fantasy.
Our Marshmallow is anonymous.
Yes.
If you have Firefox, it might be able to translate the screen
automatically.
Sometimes it doesn't, I don't know why.
I am going to make another cup of tea.
Hop on strunnies.
I'm going to make another cup of tea,
because my voice is absolutely feeling it.
What do you mean doing multiple 12-hour streams back to back
is straining on the throat?
Oh, it says 10.
Is that like a RuneScape, like Congrats 10 Balloon?
I saw that.
Wait, hold on, let me make the, look.
Oh my god, he's getting performance anxiety making that
fire.
Look, it's a 10.
He must have got it for 10.
Oh, you don't look at your shirt.
What is, it's like the logo.
Let me zoom out a little bit.
It was the 10th anniversary.
How old is this game?
There's too many people.
Another cup of tea.
You mean a cup of tea for the non-endurance stream, right?
Yeah, surely, as I say, on the four-hour mark,
and we're not even like level 20 in cooking.
Yeah, not an endurance stream at all.
Google Chrome apparently translates Marshmallow as well.
But now if I send the Marshmallow, you'll know it's me.
No, actually, because I'm not opening them up right now.
And for some reason, Marshmallow puts like five questions
from like loads of different times together at once.
It doesn't make any sense.
I don't know why I'd pass it.
Send the most horrendous cringe Marshmallow
and sign your name on the bottom like a gigatad.
I played when I was five on my older brother's account.
Oh, did he like force you to go questing?
That's funniest, anything.
This isn't RuneScape, huh?
It's old-school RuneScape.
Oh, no.
We're getting corrections.
Oh, wow, doing bot run on your brother's account.
For him.
Oh, I said RuneScape twice in the same sentence.
Oh, my God, cringe.
It's a cringe.
See about here.
You're in a level 14 fishing.
I mean, we're getting somewhere.
Oh, no, I think I might need PP bye-bye time as well.
Actually, yeah, a T and a P might.
But not the P and the P, but I need a P and a P in general.
Key quest is how often are these old-school rooms?
I was gonna do a few endurance streams.
I have no idea how long cooking takes.
So I was gonna do a few endurance streams of it.
I was gonna try and finish it in one month,
but I don't know if that's just being far too crazy.
Cut off fish, wrapper needs a T and a P.
On RuneScape, with a refunds, ptsu.
Doing nothing, ptsu, hunting for shrimp.
I can't rhyme, I can't do it.
I don't know how people do it at the same time.
You can reason why they get 9-9 cooking in less than 30 hours.
Okay, no, currently we're not maxing,
but I'll do, I'll do.
I'm gonna do that.
We did it!
30 hours of one tick-clicking.
Level 20 cooking.
Do we still burn shrimp on 20?
With Karab one.
Karab one's a real thing.
Am I being pranked?
I don't think you burn after level 20!
A reefling check.
For those of you who are on a fresh account,
what level are we looking at?
20 as well?
You guys, 20?
Karambuaz.
Oh, she sees, okay, you're done.
I've got 21, I've got 23.
How are you all faster than me?
Okay, we'll go a little reefling.
Okay, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do a P and a T,
a classic.
And we will be back.
Hi, how's the runescaping?
We're doing good!
If you ever wanted to join in,
we're on World 3A top right there.
Why is my latest tipper not working?
It should be rotating right now.
Sorry, latest tipper.
And then we're gonna move to Barbarian Village next
and we're gonna see what happens.
If there's...
Oh wait, no, we can't!
The problem is I don't want to mute the in-game chat
because of the bots.
I'm gonna go to bed, have fun cooking.
Ah well, thank you for everything.
Thank you for the extortionate prices,
for the shearers and all that.
I just realized we would probably have to fly fish
the fish ourselves.
Unless we went to the Grand Exchange,
but only I have accessed all the fish in my inventory
so it's not like we can share it out equally.
The bots on this world won't speak.
I mean, I can't, I just ignore them.
If we have to fly fish,
I think we need like level 20 fishing
so we would be here for a bit longer.
But rest well, there's reeflings that do need to sleep.
Yeah, we would need 20 for the trout.
Oh, sorry, I just like...
We need fish and wane.
Maybe we should pray.
But how can fish fly?
Are you telling me this fish flies?
I'm thinking, I'm thinking.
I'm not sure you guys want to be held here for another...
what hour until we get like the actual level needed.
I'm thinking, but my brain isn't really coming up with any solutions.
It's either...
Nah, there is no solution.
We have to keep being here until level 20 fishing.
And then we can move on.
It's going to be a long road either.
Well, yeah, literally if it takes 30 hours of matter,
like, are you telling me I shouldn't pray this fish?
Are you telling me I've cuddled this fish?
Yeah.
Um, if it's going to be a 30 hour stream anyway,
congrats on 20.
No questing for hourly levels suck.
Yeah, we're also pretty low on combat for fresh starts as well,
which is a bit...
And I don't know what we should do.
Are you telling me I cuddled this fish?
Exactly.
You can do...
Miss the mystery well here.
That quest is right here.
Oh, do we need...
Okay, how about that?
We go for a T and a P and we're gonna do some more questing
just to break up the fishing,
because that was quite a few levels we got with fishing.
So we'll go do some questing.
Um, and then it can be broken up a little bit,
because I don't want to like hurt you too much,
just doing it over and over.
Oh no, you mean we have to stay here and keep chatting forever?
I would hate that.
Oh, wow.
Oh, that would suck.
Yeah.
I'm glad.
I'm glad you enjoy my rambles.
But just as a reminder,
Emmy is live playing the coffin of Andy.
Congrats if your name's Andy and Lele.
Congrats if your name's Ashley or Lele.
Nickname is a Lele.
Um, then we are going to do a few more quests,
free quests just to break it up a little bit,
because I don't want you guys being bored of it or not.
But we will start the cooking grind soon.
Another 10?
The German name for cuttlefish is Tin Tin Fish.
A Tin Tin Fish?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Thank you for the tip, Iron Reaper.
The German name for cuttlefish is Tin Tin Fish.
How do I do it in a German at Haloloitad?
A Tin Tin Fish?
I can't do it.
I can't break it.
Nine.
A Tin Tin Fish.
I am a big Tin Tin Fish.
I'm level.
Congratulations.
You reach a total level of 75.
Oh, I'm flexing on other RuneScape players right now with that.
Flexing.
Tin Tin Fish equals an ink fish.
Oh, that's such a cool translation.
So Tin Tin.
Tin as in tint of a color.
And it's ink tin.
And so it means tinted fish.
The tint of the ink.
Oh, that's so cool.
Wah, why did I stop cooking?
I wish I was that high level, sad face.
He says no one feel well.
He's probably billions of levels higher than us.
Tin Tin Ink.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I am going to go make a tea and pee whilst I fish.
Hopefully this fishing spot doesn't despawn.
And then we're going to do a quest.
Okay.
So I'll be back in like three minutes now.
Give me three, three.
Oh, excuse me.
That was a McDonald's bag from yesterday.
I do apologize if you heard that picked up in mic.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
I'll be three minutes.
Pea and a tea.
Please get up and stretch and get some water or hydration or anything.
Of course that freaking despawns.
How dare you.
Disrespect I've been shown by this fishing spot.
You got Mickey D's yesterday.
Well, okay.
Right.
I very quickly go.
I'll be as quick as I can.
Okay.
Wait, do I need to cover the screen?
I don't know.
I don't think I have to, but yeah.
Just in case.
So you see my email.
I'll be three minutes.
Okay.
I was.
Hey.
Why?
My throat hurts so much.
Okay.
I can do too long when I go.
Pee, pee.
Wait.
Why he's greeting.
Wait, what do you mean disconnected?
I'm not disconnected.
Wait, why are you greeting? What are you saying?
She loves us. What? I never said that, didn't I? Because I went for a Tinko.
You have 30 days.
She's back. Quick, hide the memes. What were you doing while I was away? I've been away for a few minutes.
How was the pee? It was not a lot of liquid again, and I've literally finished a bowl of water.
So, and I had a tea, and I finished a can of cola. I've got another bottle of water here.
I don't know if you can hear my nails kind of against it.
I'm gonna try and finish that and the tea. I'm not really sure what's going on.
Um, I'm being pranked. I've been pranked by my body.
Wait, why does someone say she doesn't love us? Heart eyes? What?
By the way, reeflings are the best.
You say Coca-Cola. I hear burps. Cola burps. Cola burps. We did kiss the homies.
Uh, don't tell Amy that. She'll be jealous. I'm freaking, wait, I just caught an anchovy.
What does it do?
Oh, wait, I'm now catching anchovy because I'm a level?
Oh, maybe that'll speed up the fishing level gain. Okay, I didn't know that.
You put anchovies on a pizza. I don't think I've ever tasted that before. Burps.
Oh, I was so proud when Shabee started burping in her streams. I was like, oh my god.
My literal daughter. Oh my god.
With all the tea she drinks, Johnny will be really so fish-ticated.
That's not bad.
The burps are hot.
I don't understand the appeal of it, but then someone said, think of it about after the aftermath.
Give your run air back, I have no idea.
We get to rate more mouth pranks. Mouth pranks?
Why do you keep on firing as I knew that's why there's a freaking fire?
I'm getting pranked by the spine. Oh, I'm still burning stuff. I'm not level.
I'm, yeah, literally cooking level 22 and I'm still burning.
That's pretty rough after the mess. It's taking us a hot second.
Right, so what fishing level do we need? We need fishing level 20.
Shabee made a burp speed. She's indeed Shiba-kana-bama. Exactly. That's what I thought.
Tea bag in the fire. It's Johnny I kneel.
I guess so many things like, oh, I kneel for all the choices.
The barbed village spot has a permanent fire to cook on. Oh, right. I'll put my tinderbox and axe away.
And then we will buy fishing gear.
We farm until 20 fishing. I didn't know that. Yeah, we're going to do 20 fishing and then we're going to buy rods
because some of us don't have that attachment.
And then we get to go to a barbarian village and we fish and we just keep doing that for a while.
I think maybe we could get 40 doing that because salmon. However, the problem is the cost of feathers,
but the problem's already been solved thanks to reeflings literally giving me an insane amount of in-game currency.
Um, oh no, we're doing a quest. I completely forgot. I apologize. We are fishing level 20 fishing
and then we're going to do a quest that's right here that begins with M. We're going to do maybe
three quests just to break up the little fishing segment a little bit. It's called
Mithylin mystery. Mithylin mystery. Burps are saying you have relaxed come from around someone. I am
some people like get taught it's really rude manners. Like obviously it's rude like you wouldn't
be in a job interview and burp in there. Actually, speaking of burping in job interviews, I'm like
90% sure I accidentally burped when I was interviewing one of the girls revealer now that I think about it.
Uh, absolutely mortified on it. I think it may have been in me. You know that. No, it could not
have been in me. I think it may have been Mercy. Someone I burped and I was like, oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Did you hear about the telling chef who died? He passed away.
Oh, that didn't go that didn't go down well.
32. I think to stop burping burning shrimp level 32 you stop burning shrimp. That's insane.
Brian, Stroney, I hope you're proud. I was reading a comic earlier and all I heard was your voice.
I'm so cooked. Are you? Oh, did that actually happen? Am I in your head? Thank you.
Am I in your head? Is my accent in your head?
Okay, hopefully that hypnosis that reverbs off on the mic because I actually don't I didn't
say a thing that tells me if it's on or not.
Always in your head. Soon world domination, soon the first 99 cooking, okay.
It's more attractive if someone doesn't care about it.
Giving my woods the third group. What? Who? Who is Riefling is this? Come get your Riefling.
You've been in my head for a long time, Stroney. Cryo Freeze Momentum.
See, Stroney, that's why I didn't want the undo button. I want an undo button.
Right, I'm definitely cooking fish a heck of a lot faster now. Catching fish, my apologies.
She's not cooking.
We need to video game OST ranking. Okay, that slightly slows down progress now that we're
also getting anchovies as well. I keep actually trying to use fish on people. I've literally
slapped so many Rieflings with shrimp right now and feel really bad.
People are like touching your legs with my shrimp. I'm like, please take my raw shrimp.
At 21, I can finally churn cream, but we all churn cream together at the same time.
If you look at it, it's kind of like a cute little fishing camp, so Riefling's on.
There's a place to churn cream and lump. Wait, we can actually do it?
Hey, I thought we had to wait for another set for doing that. Honestly, right by Farmer
I don't even know you can churn, but take it. Take my raw shrimp.
I'm really happy that you said you love Germany. It's the first time we've worn something.
Deutschland Uber alles! Deutschland Uber alles! There you go. That's like all the German I could
come up with. Just Deutschland Uber alles. Thank you for the tip ironing river.
Wait, I don't know why. Nope, that wasn't it. Don't do that again. Why?
Hold on. I'm going to try and I don't know why it doesn't like that.
I don't know why it's frozen.
I'm so sorry. My little scroll and don't know things frozen. I'm gonna have to fix that next thing.
Well, no way you can say that. Wait, what does Deutschland Uber alles means?
Wait, if I just said something really bad, I thought it meant like Germany number one,
like China number one. What did I just say in German?
Did I just say something really bad?
I thought it meant China number one, but German number one. What did I just say?
Did I just say something really bad? It sounds like...
No, it's fine, but it can be associated with other stuff. I am so sorry.
Bitter. I am so sorry.
I thought it meant China number one. Let's just forget about it. I am so sorry. I genuinely
thought it meant China number one, but Germany number one.
When you learned your German from college, it's unironically like... Oh my God,
absolute idiot. I'm so sorry. I do apologize for that.
It's the first line of a national anthem. Oh wait, it's the first line of the national...
German national anthem?
It's only problematic if you use in a specific context. Oh, okay.
Shawnee, tomorrow will start to pop out strange fan art of you in a strange and nostalgic outfit.
Just remember, I don't own rights to previous things. That's what you're gonna...
I might not be able to interact with it if you're maybe getting a bit too cheeky.
Yeah, their national anthem from 1930s. Wait, no. I'm sorry. I really didn't...
Which Germany... Oh God, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Genuinely thought it meant China number one. I don't know if you guys ever played
PubG or something, Pub Newgrounds or whatever. But everyone used to come in and go China number one,
and that was basically what I thought I just said, but I did not say that at all.
Don't worry, I'm new here. How do I find where you are on the map?
So when you open up map, you will start here right outside of Lumbridge,
or maybe you started at the quest guy. He's literally right here. You want to go south,
you can always use this cross here and click it, and it will make everything north,
like north point north, and then just come south through a graveyard, and we are literally all here.
So south through a graveyard and south again. Brian!
My heart just dropped in my pants as you just said that.
I'm so sorry. I didn't... I genuinely didn't know what it meant. I do apologize.
I thought like... I thought everyone was like,
yay, because I said Germany number one, and there's a few German watchers,
and no, I'm just an idiot, so yep, there's that. Apologies. Sorry.
Thank you for the tip. I do apologize.
Ah, cringing at myself. I'm like, oh, maybe I should cut that segment out of the void,
honestly. I don't want anything happening, like anything weird happening. Don't stress about it.
Okay, I'll try to get there.
I can't stop laughing. No, I don't laugh at me. Literally, anyone got a fire? Any fire?
Yeah, probably take that out. I want to ask, how are you already so good at this?
I watched someone else try, and they only have two quests left in F2P, but still need attack.
Oh, I'm not good at the game. What? You were literally in it with us. I'm rubbish at the game.
Literally, we have one, two, three, four, and five. We have five quests done.
Oh wait, are you memeing? I watched someone try, and they only have two quests left into it,
but still need a taxi to Virok. Oh right, because I actually played the game.
What's the timestamp? Hold on, four hours and like 38 minutes. Hold on, I need to make more of that.
Four hours, 48 minutes.
Oh, be oh my. Right, there we go, wrote a note. Then it gets chopped up.
We have another 90 levels of cooking in front of us. Don't let your...
your not... Sorry, the love heart's in the freaking way, in the way you do.
You're not Dutch knowledge to stop you.
Hello, ik ben een Nederlander, ik heb honger, ja. Ik wissen in das pond.
Only 13 million xp to go. No, no, no, cuddles, we're laughing with you. I was laughing at you.
Okay, okay. Relaxing stream. Okay, I'm glad you find it chill like that.
Sorry, I'm at the stage where I'm now cringing at myself, thinking I thought that meant Germany
number one in all the contexts that I'd ever seen that phrase. Anyway, I'm going to drink my tea,
and I'm probably going to cringe myself to sleep tonight.
Have you declared war to something with that sentence or opened a bakery for people?
Hopefully the bakery. You're fine. Oh no, is there fire maker going offline? I will make
us a fire, don't you worry. Come, let me go get a tree. I think there's a tree in the swamp
or something. Is there not a dead tree in here? Am I going crazy?
I could have sworn there's like a dead tree in the swamp that you can... Oh, there is.
I'm going to get jumped by a frog, but I'm going to be so quick. The frog ain't got time to attack
me. Oh, I'm full. All right, drop, take the tree, and then run all the way back to the reefing.
Oh, you made fire. Sorry. Oh my god, my wood cutting is so bad. It's going to take forever
to cut this tree. Okay, we did it, we did it, we did it. I have 50, not to brag or anything,
but I've got 50 XP and wood con.
Let's see. Okay, okay, we're back, we're back, we're back.
Just so you know, Germany number one means Deutschland of dying irons. Maybe next time.
Yeah, Deutschland, Deutschland of die irons.
We're learning who said streams and educate your man, huh? Get that on fire.
A whole 50, literally. Not to brag. What if you moved on to higher tier fish?
So we're currently trying to get fishing level 20, and then we're going to do some
questing just to get overall XP. And then we're going to move on to higher level fish,
just to kind of break up with a bit of fun questing in between.
I hope I don't pass out too early to the confidence of this company and me so hard.
Learning that Scottish Cut official of Germany, yes, this is educational content you should be
seeing on for.
By the Pope, I don't know for yourself.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Thank you for the tip, iron reefer, hardy har har. No, no, bad Brian. Don't read that out loud,
Brian. That's naughty. It's naughty. There'll be no world wars. If anything, I'm actually a field
medic. So I'm here to stitch you up and give you all negative blood when you're perishing from blood
loss. That's literally bad boy, Brian, bad boy. Don't say that out loud. Oh my gosh.
No AI, the AI uprising. What's going on here? Oh, I'm itching my little schnozer. I'm going to
take a sip of my tea and see if it's...
Oh my god, it's the perfect sipping temperature, truly a British moment when you
enjoy when you appreciate the temperature of the tea.
Who are we on for fishing? Oh wait, I'm on 18 fishing. What are you guys on for fishing? We
must be getting close. We can do the quest very shortly. I'm going to put all of this in my bank
though. I am not questing with all of this money on me. Sorry, don't kill some of the money. I'm zero
negative life. The perfect cup of the perfect time, perfect dunking. Oh, what are they called?
Apparently custard cream's got named the best dunkable biscuit. Oh, you're lit. How are you
guys higher level than me, honestly? You're all cheesy, don't you?
Did the Scott have a British moment?
Unfortunately, I do seem to share some traits.
Can I even light logs or is it going to take forever? Because I'm such a low level in fire
making three, four. Oh, it took me four times. Honestly, that wasn't that bad.
15, but I had to step away a few times. Oh, you had to step away because my soundbore jokes were
just too good. Remember the one time when Facebook released an AI on the internet and
learned from the community that turned into the biggest thing going wrong?
Oh, it's four men in uniform to carry my little soldier home.
What should he do? Should have been a musician, but he didn't have the money for a guitar.
What should he do? Should have been a politician, but he didn't have a proper education.
This is not the song that I... Did we do it? We're almost there. We flings. We're so close to 20.
We're so close. By the way, do you have a plan for stages of cooking levels or would we do it
Chill and Spontane 99? I absolutely have no plan whatsoever. I've returned with logs for my fire duty.
I honestly have no plan whatsoever. We're going to move on to Salmon and Trout at
Barbarian Village after we do some questing. And then after that, I think it's just jugs of wine.
And we're literally going to be hanging out like maybe at the Grand Exchange on like a very quiet
server. Oh, level 19 fishing. There might be a quest we're going to...
Sorry for letting my inner German out, my quest. By the way, do you... Oh no. The fact that she didn't
correct the message does mean that she already chose to go straight to level 99.
Yeah, that's the plan anyway. We're going to do some questing just to break it up.
And then we are going to jump back into it. I want to see if maybe we could do level 40 today.
I don't think I'm going to do a full endurance stream as much as I love to harass you guys
and destroy your sleep pattern. I don't think we're going to do a full 12 hour stream today.
Also, my freaking VOD broke. Apparently the VODs break on 11 hours and 55 minutes,
not on the 12th hour. So the end of my VOD got chopped away and it just cuts off.
15 trout, 20 is... and 25 is salmon. Oh, we can make apple pies? Oh, I have a muffin!
I have an apple muffin. I forgot to eat it yesterday.
Yeah, something's like not really... YouTube VODs are on my list, especially the longer ones.
Yeah. Oh, is it displaying again correctly? Maybe it changed. Yeah, they told us.
That is a sad and frightening, so speaking super fast.
M&M's got nothing on me when I'm saying bioreflums. Okay, I'm like...
That explains why all the other VGVs stopped 10 minutes before the 12 hour mark.
Yeah, so unfortunately, we are having to bend the knee to the VOD overlords.
I wonder... I suppose they had to give a number, like it doesn't matter.
Circum... wait, I thought it said circumstance. Sure, you're not a mumble rat. Oh, I'm a mumble
rat. I can assure you that much. I'm annunciating my words right now. I'm annunciating. Any annunciators?
Oh, come on, catch that last one.
Anything to do with this inventory full of shrimp? Drop them! If you go, you cook them on the fire
and then you drop them once they're all cooked. It sounds like a decision made for some technical
reason over... Yeah, I assumed they had to put a number on it, but they couldn't just infinitely do it.
Although there's those accounts that used to infinitely stream music. Was it Lo-Fi Girl
or something like that? They just constantly keep going. I'll chug them all. If you go into
sentence, you can hit... I think it's like controls or something, and it's like use shift to drop,
and then if you hold shift, you can drop your full inventory stack really quickly.
Okay, level 25 cooking. I'll take it, like we're getting there. It's... if I could stop burning
this stuff, if we stop burning, we'd be like literally flying through the levels. Right, 20 is
maybe one more deck of fish away? Lo-Fi Girl never saved Vods and didn't let you rewind,
that could be why... We are learning. Okay, more of my tea. I keep forgetting.
And these fishes are hiding from me.
So I assume it costs money to get some of these Asterix costumes, because
these are like full of costumes. I have to go in 10 minutes. I can't stay on Firejoy forever. Yes,
that's okay. Don't worry, we can take over. We're probably doing by Quest next. But thank you for
your service. Wait, hold on. 07. Thank you for your service on Firejoy. 07. We salute.
Yeah, Wi-Fi... Lo-Fi Girl is more like a follower radio channel. Yeah.
The only MTX in Old School RuneScape is Bond.
You can stream them, stop, but when you end the Vod, it will only save the foot 11.55.
Hmm. Well, I'll need to know that for the Donathons, because Azuras is first.
20! I'm finally fishing level 20. That took so long.
I can drop them. Okay, we're level 20. We're gonna do questing once I finish this batch that I've got.
And then we'll go to the bank and drop off all our items and see what this Quest
mini thing is all about. I don't know if I need any items for it, is it this?
It began with an M, so let's scroll down to M.
Let's scroll up to M's.
Mystery. What do we need for that? We need... Oh, we get a reward. What do we need for it?
Recommended items, none. Enemies to defeat, none. Okay. Right. We'll definitely do this.
Nicely. Oh, she is right there. Okay, that makes perfect sense by that reefling. Suggested that
silly of me. If we're going to do some quests, we're going to the city, then we're going to the
city, then the door closes as well. Close pack. We're gonna put our items away first before we
continue with the questing. I actually have to go to... Don't worry if you have to go,
thank you so much reeflings for hanging. I appreciate it. I am going to try and get level
99 in one month for cooking, so there will be plentiful opportunities to come hang.
I'm also going to do it during the week instead of on the weekend as well to give
the people who work on the weekends a chance as well to come in and join in the fun.
Okay, everyone who is fishing, if you want to cook the fish, we're going to take it to the bank,
if you want to cook it the new, and then we're going to make our way to the castle, and then
we're going to come back and... Oh, my fire. My fire perished. So get cooking, good looking.
Oh wait, that's the song. Hey, good looking. What you got cooking? It's shrimp on a fire.
Shrimp on the Barbie. Oh, we're so Aussie out here. Can you go back to the mystery
area after you finish? Oh wait, should we just do the quest?
Reeflings have done the quest. Should we just do the quest now instead of going all the way back
in like here again? I finished my tea. Do they actually eat a lot of shrimp on Aussie land?
I don't know. Just do the quest. Okay, we'll do the quest.
I'll wait for everyone to finish up and do their thing, and then we'll start.
So let you guys cook. Those who are fishing, you can un-fish and cook, and then we'll start
with this quest, and we'll pick another one. We'll do three quests, I think. I either need to do
stream split recording. Yeah, for the donathons. I know you need to do back to back, so I'm actually
going to have to get like a video put together for Azura to play when she goes to sleep.
Hopefully her PC doesn't explode midstream. Should be a way to sleep in the thing just
catch some fire in the corner of the room, and she's like, okay.
We eat prawns. Are you squidding me right now? Who goes there, Brian? Do you read Patreon messages?
No, so none of the talents have access to Patreon messages because it's like direct
messages, so they don't have access to that stuff? No. So no, I read Marshmallows though,
your mother won't come to send a marchi. I'm drinking water now after finishing my tea.
Okay, is everyone almost ready? I'm gonna drop three inventory space. I'll just drop
three anchovies, why not? Right, we will talk to this lady. I'll put walking on. Let's see what
happens. Help, help! Start the quest. Sure, are you guys ready to come over? I'll get to 20 later.
Yeah, we can always come back and do our thing. Thank you for the tip though, Anonymous.
You really are shy. You could ask that for free. You didn't have to give me money to
ask that question. You guys are always welcome to ask and chat. I know it can be never again,
or you can ask in Marshmallow, but I might be sold to respond because I'm not reading Marshmallows
right now. Thank you for the tip, but save your money at the same time, seriously.
Ray, are we ready? Are you my refillings? You are. You're not quite ready, hold on. Oh, sorry.
Right, I'm accepting the quest. What has happened here? We were invited to a house party on the
island not far from here. Something felt wrong about the whole thing, but we went away. The
house seemed pretty creepy, but everything was going fine. We were having a good time,
and that's when we got attacked, and I tried to save her. Huey brought me enough time to find
an old bolt. I went back to get him, but it was too late. I'm scared he won't make it. You have to
do something. They can't get away with this. What do you want me to do? That cycle is still
out there. You have to bring them to justice. The boat we escaped on is just over there,
and you can use it to get to the island. Okay, I'll see what I can do. I need to fight, I hope not.
Can reflings see this boat over here?
Can you point in the way? Let's check that you're all here.
He's got a refling, got a few. Okay, end of the boat, end of the boat.
And joins. How bold of you, considering she has a plan. Stranny, I was wondering if you were
following some kind of, uh, gay deciding to do... Nah, I'm just going for it. We're literally doing
quest and right now, like I'm already getting distracted from the 99 grind.
Okay, I think that's all my reflings. These are actual plots. Okay, into the boat we go. Yippee!
There's a chance you ask the question and check out typically better chances, I don't know.
I know, but you still do it for free. Just like keep... Like if I miss it, then ask it again in
like a couple of minutes. Oh my god, there's so many of us doing this quest right now. We're
going to overload this. It looks kind of familiar. Ooh, where are we? Oh, okay, we need to take a
left refling. For those of you who don't have the plugin, we're going to pick up this bucket right
here on the left. Oh no, is it instance bucket? Why are we taking the bucket? Pick up from the bucket.
Is it an instance bucket? Oh no, we can all take it. Okay, that's good. Okay, drop.
Okay, everyone get a bucket. Pick up your bucket. Sits right by the fountain. Oh my god,
the beacons are lit. Gondor calls rage. Okay, and then we have the barrel of rainwater.
Interact with it. We need to search it. Okay, there's like lots of noises going on.
Whoa, party on, bro. Oh, it's like that movie that I've not seen. Whoa, the wind totally just felt like
some breathing on my neck. Oh, not cool, bro. I feel woozy, gurg. I see the light.
It's not my tame, glurg, glurgle, gargle. Oh, that's a bit. I don't know what movie he's from. I've
not seen it, but I've seen it. You know what I mean? I've not seen the movie. Help me.
Man, you're taking a while to perish. Sid collapses on the ground in a crumpled mess.
As he falls down, you spot something shiny fall out of his shirt pocket and into the barrel of
water. Gosh, that was horrible and so drawn out. Oh, wow, he's still going.
I think he's actually gone this time. Who are you? Why are you doing this?
Hmm, he didn't say anything. Scary movie. Oh, it's Scream. Oh, I've got to find a way
into that house and stop this maniac. I wonder what it is that I saw fall into that barrel.
Search the barrel, reflings. The barrel's full of rainwater. I can't see what's in there. Oh, right,
click on the barrel in your inventory and use it on the barrel of rainwater. You fill the bucket
from the barrel. Okay, now what? Now we search the barrel. You find a key at the bottom of the barrel.
Uh, are you seeing strong? Okay, now we go to the front of the house.
It's so scary. Oh, it's making the noises.
Chop down. No, open large door. Okay, here we go. The bunny went ahead. I saw that bunny.
He closed the door behind you. Let us in the house. Right, there we go. Oh, the door all closes. Hold
on. I think the door all closed. Oh, does it all close? Wait, I can't even get in. Is this open
large door? No. I think we're all trying to get in at once. Right, I'm not clicking it. I'm just
okay. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Oh, all right, I'm getting there. We're getting there. We're
getting there. We're getting there. Hold on. Hold on. Why am I not going inside? It's not
because someone's doing the door thing. It's one at a time. Right, okay, that's fine.
Okay. Oh, okay, I'm in. I'm in. I'm in. Okay. Oh, that took us a hot thing there. Right,
let's get the other refunds in. Everyone in. Everyone in. Okay, a few more. A few more
refunds. A few more stragglers. Can you come? Can you come? One more. One more. Can you come? Can
you come? Click that door? Right, we're in. We're in. Right, everyone, touch the table in the entrance
way. Oh my goodness. There's a knife on the table. Touch that table. Oh, we're touching the table.
Okay. Once you've touched the table, touch this door. Oh, the door. The door. Oh, cut scene.
Knock, knock. Who's there? Oh, no. Gurgle. Oh, he said you're next to me.
Oh, he's using cheat see doodles. What's this? A note. I guess I should read it.
Let's go get the note. Oh, he left the note. Okay. It should be a note to your left.
You take a copy of the note. Let's read it. Isn't murder just the work of art,
beautiful yet haunting like the blade of a knife as we wander through the valley of death?
Oh, spooky. Oh, okay.
Is this on the other side? Oh, okay. Everyone enter this room. It doesn't really look like a room.
Oh, it's a some room anyway. Oh, look at this painting. Wait, why am I getting turned this
way for the painting? Hello? Hello? Okay, examine painting.
Wait, what am I supposed to do? Oh, use the knife on the painting. I didn't
even know I had a knife on me. Use the knife in your inventory on the painting.
Beat that painting up. Show it. You mean boss. You slash open the painting revealing a hidden
storage compartment. Search painting. You find a key hidden inside the slash painting.
Okay. If you found your key, come back out into the entrance wave. You've got the key
from the painting by cutting it up into the entrance way. Okay, just a few more.
Use the knife in your inventory on the painting in that room.
And then once you've got the key, come back into the hallway. We're doing it. We're questing.
They have a higher pit than you. What's a pit?
Are we good?
There should be a knife in your inventory. And then you can highlight it by using right click
and then slash the shoes of it. There you go, you key. Alrighty. And then we go through this door
right here. Oh, there's a refund party in here, clearly. Oh, someone's spooking us behind the door.
Okay, once you enter this new room, there's a little Orbe thing to the left. I don't know what
it does, but it's highlighted. Examine the unlit candle on the wall. Oh, we're to tinderbox
the thing on the wall. Tinderbox the unlit candle. Oh, wait, do you guys need a knife for a tinderbox
or is it like in this room? Do you guys need me to trade this? There's a bunch in here. Okay,
okay, that's good. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, literally all on the shelf. There's a tinderbox
on the shelf if you need help. You light the candle. So light the two unlit candles. Oh,
there's a third one as well. Oh, excuse me. Excuse me, Mr. Video Game. Oh, I just touched my fish.
Hold on. Wait, that sounded odd. I think she's more happy of the fact that there's
20 people doing the same thing. Literally, Jagex is like, what on earth?
Ah, I'm sure they've had it before people go questing together.
You light the candle. The room is sufficiently warm. The fuse should now have dried out. Oh,
once you tinderbox all the things, do the barrel?
I don't know. And get the heck out of the room. Get out of the room as soon as you light that
thing. Hold on, let me run. Give me that room. Give me that room. Give me that room. Give me that
the thing about to blow. Oh, okay, okay, okay.
All right. Hey, it's the shadow one that kept closing the doors on me.
that's known or not, if this is in life, why are you so excited if I touch the doors and
tables? I'm just like it's so fun being like oh my god request them together and for those
who don't have room light I'm like I'm the quest teller you know so once you've let everything
and blew it up we can all go outside in this section so I'll wait for the reeflings to come over
yeah they're like having to get out the room because it's blowing up
I just find it really fun getting to play games together
so we're getting the god sword right? I don't know what the god sword is
we are all here merely by coincidence there's absolutely nothing in common that we all have
is there anyone else can say?
are you squiddling me right now?
Brian!
it's 1am I have to tap out
sleep well
enjoy the rest of your stream with the reeflings
thank you so much Pajango please rest well
maybe see you in the morning I don't know if this is endurance yet
yes there's four candles in that room to light on the walls you take a tinder box from the shelf
a little tinder box on the shelf and then you light all four candles in the room
and then there'll be a powder keg that you can light here just on the outskirts of that room
it will blow a hole in the wall but you need to yeah you light it and then leave the room
okay so it blows up
and then there's you
or the other well that door
I mean you're not wrong I don't know if it blows up if you go out on that door but the other door
or did it blow up?
boom okay there you go I blow up I think you're
that's all the reeflings I don't see anyone else hiding in that room
can you come over if you yeah okay reeflings let's go next let's go no we're doing it
oh if you click here um on the foot uh on the minimap up here it'll put running on so if it's
brown it means you're walking if it's golden it means you're running uh your stamina will regain
eventually so don't worry oh suspiciously let's observe this suspicious tree over here
please stop this just let me go oh it's kind of messed up we're going to play a game do you
like to play games yeah no yes whatever you say just then it hurt me whether you get hurt or not
is entirely up to you your fate is in your own hands what what do you mean leave her alone you monster
uh scuttlefish how kind of you to join us now if you see another word I will enter right now
sorry where were we ah yes of course the game do you like quests lisi uh sure I like quests
do you like scary quests uh huh what's your favorite scary quest I don't know
you have to have a favorite uh the one with a vampire in it who lives in the big house
good good and now for that game I spoke about I am going to ask you one question get it wrong
and you die but get it right and you live how is that fair oh gothix please gothix isn't that
a type of armor oh gothix please no please don't I don't want to die then think hard about your
answer you like vampire so this should be easy for you the question is who is the vampire that resides
in south mish I would be perishing um I'm to say nothing I'm not I'm not to say anything he said
he's gonna slash her if I say anything oh yes yes I know it count drain or ha in your face you masked
freak oh lisi lisi lisi I did tell you to think hard about your answer count drain or is in fact a
vampire and he does reside in his manner in midi didi but that manner is in west midi didi I was
talking about count check thanks for playing no no you tricked me this isn't fair ask me another
gorgol the writing in this game is
I think it's because I'm are you leaving us no okay I'll take the note
do you like general take the note please that monster oh I can't, I can't really click on
the note oopsies take note you take the note what does it say it's like music to
my ears the glory sounds spelling out your fate oh okay get into the once you
pick up the note there's a piano where to do something with it someone is
throwing Easter eggs everywhere play piano okay once you're on the piano
Delta echo alpha Delta did we do it right oh there's a compartment can I play
for real oh you can't you can't play this one
oh I think my inventory's full hold on I think there's something I'm supposed to
grab play piano search piano search piano oh once you play that Delta's just need
I don't see a delta button oh very funny very funny oh it spells are dead do you
like metal this baby metal kind of now I like always tea from doom doom yeah
doom 2007 BFG is probably my favorite if that counts as metal song is everyone
got the key if you got the key come up the hallway a little bit oh wait we're
oh no we're supposed to go back okay if you've got the key come out of the room
let's see if there's any who's not got the key got the key got the key
someone's I don't know if someone's in that cutscene with the guy
spelled dead on the piano from the left side that has to make it it's that's an
hello there's a refling here but I don't know if they're in a cutscene or not I'm not sure
I don't know what's happening with this refling I think they might be AFK
but everyone not oh I don't know Miku you're Miku are you mine
I think so okay I think so you're hanging out with us uh I don't know oh oh did you get the key
do you need to do the piano bit I don't know oh right spelled dead on the piano and then
search the piano and left side spelled dead if that makes sense
damn there's no tear remote there is in game wait where is it cheer cheer okay that's the best I
got sorry I was AFK I'll catch up yeah just spell yeah yeah there you go you got it you got the key
if you touch the piano and then on left spell side and then you should get key
I think everyone's got the key
everyone's got the key right let's go come back inside the house from the side we blew it up on the
powder cake oh it's a room full of reflings oh no just me in a room full of reflings
okay come back into the entrance hallway oh we're getting stuck on the door
hold on hold on hold on oh right hold on you again it's him it's him that's doing it
it's him that's not getting freaking stuck wait how'd I come around
I'm literally can't progress stop it I can't even get through or is it one by one oh maybe a one
by one hold on I might be accusing someone of closing the door and I think it's one by one
oh right oh sorry sorry I just I'm sorry refling every misinput misinput
oh it's a misinput okay should I be letting her imagination run wild honestly honestly
okay so one by one door take your time take your time it's one by one door
right here you come stop refling let us come in
everyone's got a better ping than me okay I'm in I'm in I'm in
okay then through the other one by one door
oh it's a cutscene accusing her own beloved loyal refling why am I the only one always
left cleaning up after everyone shuffle hello anyone there Russell hello lacy said scratch
hmm well I guess I should go check it out no point saying in this nice locked room when I could go
outside into the creepy darkness seriously the walls and doors seem too thick for Mandy to be able
to hear you oh and I don't think there is any need to take this big shiny weapon with me in order
to defend myself nothing bad ever happens when people go check out noises in the dark outside
the house you have gotta be kidding okay well here I go
oh
bandos kotsu hello anyone out here
see I knew nothing would happen must have just been a squirrel or something running about
oh well back to the dishes phew that was lucky
oh he's behind you
no why me that psycho he was just toying with her
oh we're getting left another note I think this is talk to killer just look at my camera
we're in a cutscene and he's hiding away again another note this guy really likes playing games
but this is going to be the game he won't win okay there should be a note on the ground for us to
read now here at first these words each murder you witness helplessly from start to end as you
fail to solve the final letters of this quiz razor sharp like a gemstone is the blade of my knife
the last time you hear will be your screams echo hita and hita I will have the final word
in this thriller okay we need to go back into the hallway from the one by one door so we need to be
patient
okay there we go I made it through
wait what was that
oh that makes sense hard right is there a refland just out there chilling are you
not doing the quest are you just being chilling out there being chilling are you not sure what to do
okay and then one by one we painfully go through this door again
now we're getting waving hello hello okay we need to check out the fireplace okay or also
known as the heart oh wait this is chop down tree examine the fireplace with a knife use the knife on
the fireplace you use the knife to pry open a loose brick in the fireplace revealing a secret
panel search fireplace you find the panel switches inside the hidden compartment
each switch is crafted from a different gemstone
oh
click sapphire click diamonds click zen yates click emerald click on it and click ruby
blue white orange green black red you hear a click sound you find a hidden key okay that one's a bit more
sd ze autumn how are you specifically that i love riddles in this game must have been the wind
would you be upset if it was ink you were cleaning it's
oh man i can't believe this i can't find my old character anymore i wanted to bring in a high level
character to help out i don't worry also there's a boss fight now i don't have any combat
the final letters of the note
oh
he died has a final word in this
okay okay that's actually wee bit smart uh i'll give it to wee bit smart just to
leave it leave it smart right one by one door one by one door one by one door
cheeky one by one oh wait is everyone done with the horse god you guys were so quick at the heart
okay cheeky cheeky one by one door i said let me in stop you don't even need to come in this
room you've already done the quiz bro i don't have high enough pain i can't get out i actually
don't have high enough pain to get out i'm not even i'm not even being funny i genuinely my
pain is so bad i can't get out rub i don't know what to do my pain isn't fast enough to respond
the background keeps reminding me of the godfather i've never seen the godfather
is it gay fail to solve the final letters of this quiz fail to solve the oh okay okay it works okay
uh right uh once we're back in the engine's way we one by one on the door over here we're spinning
on the door last three flames here you come and then we go boom
oh we got a cutscene i wonder if there's a way to make the take figure show yourself you coward
monkey monkey is someone gonna get stuck
so we meet at last i have to say i'm impressed you worked out my riddles well maybe you aren't
as smart as you think you are oh really all the dead bodies suggest otherwise and what did you do
to stop them nothing people think you are some big hero but no you're not all your adventures are
the same nothing but opportunist what are you on about well i did have this big speech planned
out but quite frankly i don't think you're worth the effort it would take to deliver it so this is
the end of the line for you it's time for the final act the showdown the finale let's see if you're
up for the challenge probably not i'm too oh if i die did i lose all the money that's on my hand
push mirror
the mirror can't be pushed any further what you on about
oh no i missed wait is there like a timer
hello oh logic puzzle wait i need to like
and then push from here
oh what he changed i don't know which one he's coming from
they just have to guess
i'll forgive him wait i can't see when it's coming
is it that one i think i'm too late can can you just randomize to this one where i've already
set it up please that'd be great game wait i'm supposed to run about that fast i don't think i'm
that fast i'm freaking too late and oh right okay there's like a weird shadow thing but i don't
know if i'm that fast seriously i'm not that fast oh
bro
did i just need to camp at one he's too fast
oh my god he's like so fast
hold on oh please be it
oh no
uh right okay wait i don't even know where it's coming from
oh right okay shadow shadow okay he's doing it again from that one okay okay quick quick quick
oh is it oh shit i'm too
please be this one no that the randomizer is so cruel you know for a fact you can randomize
elsewhere okay another one another one wow dang right ouch okay okay okay okay we can do this
one two and three wow just in time
i flopped out oh i think i may have underestimated you
you lost that your own game and now it is time to see who you really are under that mask
wait no you but why why on earth would you kill all your pals why beg me to come here and help them
you just don't get it do you so big headed so used to it all being about you about saving the day
well i'm sick of it what do you even mean adventurers you're all the same everything
always has to be about you i don't understand of course you wouldn't because you can't see
past yourself believe it or not i used to be like okay at least to be like you i hear about
some dance alone distress and go to help have my moment for me to be the hero for once but you
you and every other adventure every time i get there to help is too late it's already solved the
disaster the disaster is averted reward has already been claimed every time you and those
adventurers steal my moment but not this time this time it's all about me i'm the star of the
show me me me me me me well not any longer the show's over and there will be no curtain call
oh but there's always a curtain call he he he he
he
what how there was two
of course every good show needs a good support and actor and take off your mask darling take
a bow you've earned it of course my love it's sad no it's not it's harvey i'm sorry
you but how you were almost heckin gone i saw your wounds no what you watched was what i
wanted you to watch a masterful performance if i say so myself but wasn't it for you
everyone loves the limelight and who better to share it with them i beloved abigail
but your friends they didn't deserve to perish perhaps not but neither did i deserve to be cast
back into the shadows where i deserve the spotlight yes well we deserve the spotlight
and now i have my starring role our starring role gelinor will forever remember this night
and what i've done here no what we have done quiet hui this is my moment
no this is supposed to be our moment it isn't just all about you either we're in this together
stop ruining this hui i have worked so hard for this and i'm not gonna let you take it away from
me well i'm not going to be push aside either we were both in on this is equals we were never
equals how could you possibly compare to me you're egotistical selfish no my love
no what have i done it wasn't supposed to be like this but you just couldn't let me have my moment
why herey why i loved you this could be my chance to take advantage of the situation
okay pick up the knife i'm not going out her empty handed yeah pick up take the killer's knife
yawn and i'm not go wait equip the knife pick up the knife and equip it and then
stab her take that hack and slash well thanks sarah doleman that's over i should get out here
just like that are they still alive i don't think he's in a very talkative mood are they both
okay okay let's get out here let's go let's go
the crying says oh you'll never escape me
you dare try and ruin wait what mpc spot isn't she supposed to be parish try and ruin my moment
oh wait no here is hurt because of you is definitely to you oh wait now is now it's time
for you to join oh you're not killing anyone else oh again absolutely she's spanked by the
no this can't be she she just got specked whoa that was close
mandy how are you alive or what should get shanked i did i did get stabbed but i was born with a
rare condition called dextrocardia dextrocardia what dextrocardia it means that my heart is on
the right side of my chest not my left like oh that's so specific so when the killers thought
they stabbed you in the heart they actually missed well missed the heart yeah i did still get stabbed
though i'm actually feeling pretty woozy oh yeah right yeah i will wait outside the house after seeing
to this stab wound you should come talk to me there okay okay okay
hey right outside the house if my roofing oh no are you guys stuck on the mirror section
are they stuck on the mirror section if they're still in here or are they just in the cutscene
someone throw in their snowball i'm starting to think you aren't throwing snowballs anymore
no witnesses the rooflings never talk my medieval fantasy game with me oh my medieval
fantasy game with medical term there's still one more roofling stuck in there are you stuck on
the mirror quest beyond it i'm on team finish faster than throwing it i need to read it out
i don't think these are snowballs i'm getting covered in or something
should i have fought abigail uh you pick up a knife oh did you just leave you might have
to go back inside and redo that mirror section sadly we'll wait it's okay
i mean did you shank her i oh the refunds out is that everyone all the candles for all the board
oh we're talking about humors and bail okay that's all the refunds everyone into the entrance
way turns out you can't fight her nah you don't actually hurt abigail yourself right and then
we talk oh no it's one by one door oh it's our biggest enemy it's literally our biggest enemy
right now one by one door the game's like sending me away right i'll i'll wait for the reeflings to
go first i'll let the reeflings go because they've been they're playing with me without having a
both time no witnesses the reeflings will never talk fair and square the actual end boss of the game
i don't think they're snowballs either but they may contain some terms in common
hold on okay we need to talk to the mandy right here oh hi scottles fish hi mandy how you feeling
now much better thanks i'm lucky to be alive thanks to you no small part well we saved the day in the
teams thank you too here i found this in the wardrobe i've seen i don't want to take it so please take
it we did it we got another quest for level eight crafting and we got rubies for it i like that
he he he well i think we're ready to go back is everyone ready once you've collected your mission
the question is what quest do we do now there's actually we'll do the free quest we'll solve the
free i'm level nine crafting i went oh yeah you're just rubbing in my face
uh looks like everyone's spoken to mandy almost a few more we funds
someone's really enjoying just talking to them all the way
uh is everyone i'm just trying to check are you coming too no yeah no maybe
okay right all aboard the boat
who do i talk to to finish the quest mandy she's outside that uh castle
yeah we did it we did it wait wait let me do a celebration of more can i jump in there
we complete the quest
me
all right let's see here
uh okay i think we should go to the bank and put all our items away and then we'll pick
what quest to do next what's a free quest that's easy goblin diplomacy is pretty easy
erinus the chicken i think you need to have combat uh i think you need combat for erinus
sleep well good night those who have to go
good night shrani and until later i don't know if there's anything easy
erinus the chicken is probably the easiest we've got right now i think we may need to level so
that's not really why we need to level out just our runaway segment
hmm all kind it's all a refund here i think
yeah i've got some stuff to try not to get food but for those who have to go don't worry if you
have to go understand it's not possible we'll do erinus the chicken and then we're gonna go back
to fishing hey sorry we're gonna go back to leveling up cooking
okay is everyone here i think everyone's here i don't know if that other reeflings still stuck
on the island possibly i'm going crazy didn't mean to just see him back on the island
wait there is a reefling that got stuck in that quest i think
it's called scrawny sea
oh no that was you i think okay see you later bye bye reeflings thank you for joining for the
ones who have to leave don't worry if you have to leave in game right if you want to follow me
if you could if you hover on me it should say follow uh and then we'll i'll take you to the bank
and then we'll do erinus the chicken i don't know what is but we'll do it anyway oh i'll walk sorry
i'll walk i always forget to walk they're a reefling army honestly
see you later alligator in a wild crocodile
yeah i want to i want to go to the island why won't you let me go did you guys see that
steven hawken meme that sounds really terrible but
hmm that's what the meme was so when it came out that steven hawken went on the island
someone like did a quote and it was like i want to go to the island why won't you let me go
um oh i just live in the prime world i know the stream isn't over yet but when do you think
the next runescape won probably in a week's time my endurance stream is skyrim for next week
but i am going to try and get 99th uh cooking where am i trying to go i don't know why i need
the map to go to the bank and over the bank is uh my next i'm going to try and finish 99 cooking
in um in one month i want to finish 99 cooking bobby lee or whatever yeah yeah that was it
no it's just going to be vanilla skyrim for my endurance stream next week
endurance stream next week is skyrim and runescape uh i don't think today we're going to do the
full 12 hours because i've actually just quite a lot of 12 hours go upstairs on the top of the bank
how are you everywhere am i going crazy or is this a bot or is this a reefland that like is just
no like how are you leveling up outside here what we didn't even get here i'm going crazy
i swear that's a reefland right empty everything inside uh i guess you can just drop the
notes from that minigame
uh and then erin is the chicken i'm actually going to equip my sword and shield and i like pretty
sure i got unequipped for some reason and i don't want to be completely defenseless
when i'm out there i think you just draw destroy you guess
wait am i not allowed to destroy the notes they'll just put them in the bank then
okay i'm just putting the notes in the bank i don't know why
no that's me all right okay okay okay okay i could just what i was like i'm sure that's
a reefland genuinely anyone want my three gems since i can't bank um oh god me me me me me
send them to mommy who's uh who said that me me me me head uh i can't trade you what
i won't let me trade you oh well at least you can send it to me i don't know why i wouldn't let me do that
me me me me me me oh my god my my my no
we should fight the level one five two chicken at the gale is that is that real i don't mean to
alarm you but name and cook and make take someone said it can take 30 hours if we max it
i can't trade for another 52 minutes that's okay uh right um erin is the chicken
we're gonna do erin big big erin need the chicken buck buck uh show on the map
we need to go oh outside this location here i don't know do we level up i feel like we need to
do a bit of combat well we go kill cows for like i'm not even kidding we'll go uh kill cows for
like five minutes so we're gonna go across the bridge and get cows reeflings come down to the castle
i'll wait for you at the front of the castle make sure you have a sword and a shield equited you
got it from tutorial island 100 hours are five strong streams of frogs in the lake honestly
so
maybe cool right we will just go outside the castle uh and i'll make sure everyone i don't see anyone
coming down the stairs from there i think everyone's on you guys are quick i don't think
there's anyone i don't see anyone okay we're gonna cross the bridge five streams must be
short ones honestly i just five streams uh i give me one second i'm getting
me
right we're gonna go into the cows pen and we're literally gonna go nuts and destroy
and all these cows up ahead okay just so some people get nine in cooking by at skill 33 with
6000 grapes and turning them into wine is that the fastest ice pee maker i thought it was sharks
but sharks are expensive me oh someone wants to trade sorry sorry i didn't see the offer
what do you offer me poison are you telling me killing them oh my god what did you do poison
and fish food reef land that's so mean i got given poison and freaking fish food tell me tell
me you don't like me without telling me you don't like me reefland sheesh right let's absolutely
destroy these cows even if you just get a few like to level up i guess even a tiny bit of a level
up is better than nothing something about not being able to burn wine wine making is the fastest okay
based for reefling someone said okay just get the cows just attack the cows at all willy nilly
and then we can level up our combat a bit because our combat is so low that we're like
really vulnerable to pretty much anything destroy that reefland mods slap them silly
mods remove this man sis just call things
why are you following this noob just call things okay i love that answer is there more cows over
here oh there is there's like tons of cows okay and don't worry you can attack everything in this field
level up oh i said enjoy
we will hunt them down mods put chewed up gum in this in his best shoes
mods make sure his pillow is always warm
yeah see we like literally already we're getting so strong we're just beating absolutely everything up
why did actually how did they know i'm a noob is that the way i dress i'm literally wearing
a thousand gold drip and they called me a noob not to brag but my combat levels five right now
like i'm sorry but but runescape players quake when they see me i'm sorry just quake when they
see me they can't help it their timbers are shivered whenever they see scottl fish login online
oh i've only got four health i should maybe be a bit more careful honestly
oh i've only got three health maybe i should be really careful uh
hmm i'm not sure i can maybe fight the baby cows if i get beaten up by a cow i'm gonna be
really embarrassed okay oh my god a baby cow destroy it combat level five literally
we quiver before you as well but for different reasons
oh my god the way that we think like rolls over as well it's so sad i'll plant some bums
all right i can only attack baby cows because i've only got three hp i swear if any reefling
perishes against cows i'm gonna be embarrassed for result okay oh sorry someone said they wish
to trade sorry sorry let me beat up this baby cow and then i'll accept the tree
oh my god i'm on one hp no way this baby cow is gonna get me mods
i need to get out of the field oh my god i'm one hp in a dream hold on right let's try that again
okay i literally i'm the one that's gonna perish from the cow hold on let me uh
accept this trade i was so sorry chin up offer
oh no can you not trade that's okay if you can't do it in time uh i guess we'll just hang about here
yeah we're just gonna hang about oh they're cooking meat cannot trade yeah i'm a new account it's
cause like i'm not cleared enough do you have meat excuse me little reefling uh can i get some of
your meat please one bit of meat so i can heal just one meat oh you not got any i saw you cooking
though i do not have any oh wait i can make some if i pick up some off the ground wait a minute
hold on a minute i can do it man i'm an independent strummer use the meat on the fire and then eat the
meat it's genius i did it okay we can go back to sleep and let's go we'll get a few more combat
levels like this chickens can only hit zero so that's good for you accounts now we need a challenge
for the coup
uh we're now attack level four oh my god we're getting so strong
they can't handle us when we enter the lobby i'm gonna actually cook again because i want to heal up
i'm gaming so hard right now oh no i burnt it oh i thought we were like high enough level
not to burn level on me honestly uh i don't know what combat level we are we're combat level five
surely that's enough for questing surely kopium let me know wild strongy can survive in nature
like it's rough out in in nature it's rough i just need to heal and then i can start walloping
everything again there boom uh let me keep them pack or is it better to like swap between like the
same thing so cows can burn it's genius why do the farmers randomly let you perish their cars
honestly i'm not even sure wait i think it might be faster to do like strength and then i might get
like a combat level faster i'm not sure if that's right though i could be completely wrong
about that wait there's like more cows over here we can just annihilate yeah there's like tons over
here best to train strength or maybe defense because like i've not got much hp points like
owl oh sorry someone wishes to trade with me drop some meat over here if you want a strongy
since i can't trade the reeflings feeding me oh they're feeding me thank you reeflings
that's a lot of meat jeez you're a packing is that six whole meat for me it is thank you
i'm a bite into it oh wait i'm already full health wait i only have nine hp or no i have
10 hp that's like tiny azura remainder azura duly is going live i i'm unsure what game she's doing
oh my god check out the outfit check out the drip let's say dripped out in the colors
we're getting there we're getting there surely and no freaking head bang oh my god you know
what that reminds me of i think the reason why i laugh so much at that is because of this
right hear me out hear me out where is it let me find it
i think that's why that makes me laugh so much because it looks so ridiculous
that's the only reason i think i like the head banging a moat the most
this is absolutely ridiculous
wow i don't know it's level six combat enough to like not get attacked all the time i look sucky
sorry i look sussy sorry i didn't mean i said that wrong i didn't mean to say it like that
oh i'm level two strength check me out oh sorry someone wants to trade with me
i'm sorry i missed it i'm sorry i'm too i'm too fatigued too fatigued i'm too enthralled
with perishing these cows to get some level ups very be sucky i'm sorry look i've got things on my
mind you know the marshmallows i've been getting recently oh yeah
okay accept trade what show me what you got oh it's a strength potion and cooked salmon
okay i don't know how long i only wanted to be here for like a wee bit and then we'll
straight back in to leveling up cooking because i'm like accidentally save questing a little too
much what i wanted to do was get some level so when we do airness to chicken we don't all perish
i think we can run a wave for whatever is going on oh yeah you know all right
um i just didn't want us to perish really quickly when we did airness to chicken
i don't know what is there is live with um thank you very much we fling for all the food supplies
as well um oh what almost like up my strength level up level up combat level six unstoppable
truly unstoppable they cannot they cannot strength potion for stronger uh okay i took a sip i took a
sip everything's gonna i don't know how long it lasts wait where's the effect i don't know how long
these things the pots last i've kept up this much of a fight i fear what bills are capable
she can now destroy baby cows with ease i truly am evil truly i don't know how long it was
yeah strength potion yeah top left the fist so strength boost
60 seconds no it does not last six seconds that's so small when you heal
oh salmon heals a lot actually we need to start like a salmon ring
is it normal to heal multiple multiple strong voices simultaneously in my head i hope not
if i left the echo on one boosted start point drains every 30 seconds that's so quick
oh i'm no strength level four i'm rolling these coos there's no echo okay it's just a reef flings
finally losing the plot oh i now can have a live in hp okay maybe we should have done a bit of
training a wee bit earlier but look we're leveling up that's the main thing we're getting there
i don't know if we should maybe go for like five
hmm echo isn't on i think he's just becoming extra strongy pill so it depends on how strongly
your potion is supposed to do as there is playing one shot like how strong he sends excited every
time she unlocks levels it's so satisfying it's like oh you've unlocked a new level but yeah i have
i'm such a big girl i'm so smart it's in my tea
hydration check
i think the echo effect if i was playing a video game doesn't sound that good like
this is for example what would sound like like oh i'm just killing this food right now
and it just sounds mental it sounds like you've lost the plot fine uh you've actually lost the plot
it's not it's not sounding good you know there that should be it back to me
i think i got an unsubtremisors channel it's very plausible everyone's youtube links should be in
my description right we'll do five defense we're almost level seven combat let's go
oh my god serenity
how are you doing how is your stream even though you're probably exhausted and the last thing you
want to do is get a ton of heck in comments and be like i'm on the way to shame oh no no no
and because it's a holiday hopefully it was good though and you had fun hi raiders i'm strongy
cuttles from vealer and i'm currently doing my stream snake game of the day of the week sorry
um and we're playing old-school rinscape we're in three world 3a which is free to play and we're
just leveling up our accounts a little bit because we are super weak and we're i'm scared to send us
questing because someone might fall down uh what level is your attack my attack is four strength is
five and defense is one i'm currently doing defense right now uh just to try and get overall
combat level sweetie bun raid i never saw old-school rinscape before oh it's basically
an incremental game and you just click and like literally this is the graphics i'm not even kidding
like check me out i've got a gold plated chef's hat on gold apron on like this is the graphics
tell me this is not like you you've not seen anything better just a minute it's a sweetie
bun raid bun bun raid help i fall and i'm literally dropped out like why did i get a message and be
logged in 30 minutes but yeah we're just leveling up um because we want to do some questing but
can't eat weird i always saw the youtube makeup that's not the default graphics that's using the
i don't oh at least even worse than this oh it's been six hours already i didn't realize either
hi hi sorry for stealing all your time guys time flies when you're having fun time flies
this is peak graphics you you do not get better than this the year is 2024 you you can't be look
let's admire the daisies right here let's zoom in a little look at the daisies man look at that
beautiful you can see every poly what's that a poly thing like every triangle
oh all the triangles are made out
oh i've reached a total level of 100 ooh our accounts are getting better
yeah we've started on fresh accounts so all that go censored it did hold on let me eat a salmon
well we're at combat level seven oh we are getting potent okay anyone look polygon that's what i mean
yeah polygon but if anyone looks as funny i'm gonna get them level seven go and get them
they can't handle they can't handle it lara croft polygon chest honestly
okay think we're getting there we're getting there maybe we do five on each
eight combat means we can survive a little bit of a hit a little bit of a punch if you will
triangle oh that should be
and then wherever erin is chicken starts i'm actually unsure
wow level four did i put my combat we're at seven point six for combat i like how it shows you the
increment as well like to be like you're getting closer i'm pretty sure prayer counts to your
overall combat level as well so i fonder the triangles um so i don't know if we should do some
i've never done is it the altar it's like dragon bone altar run but they're so expensive
and i would need personal guards like all the way over
see that's the fastest way to level up prayer i believe but yeah
yeah watching stroney and emean spritz playing a game on my own almost feels like a friend
isn't there no sensory overload doing that i feel like i'd be like i couldn't handle it
i feel like there's too much going on it's emean join her game so far
i already need a p again i feel like whenever i have a t she's loving it oh i'm glad
that's what i like to hear see on your picture oh i'm level four health sorry four hp
where i think there's everyone at least like level we've got level six reflin yeah that's good
okay apparently if we get level five in attack we're getting leveled i've got level 10 reflin
over there we can't tell we've got level six as well yeah we're getting a bit better getting a bit
better we're definitely not to be trifled with even though we're not level 10 combat yet but we're
not to be messed with how do you pee so much yes although i honestly do not know i know that caffeine
makes you want to wee wee all the time so i think that might be because i'm having so much tease from
my throat yay we're like doing little mini tasks as well
someone wants to trade you wish to trade i accept your trade what do you wish to trade me
oh i don't know if i can wear this actually i don't know if it's too strong like i can't wear it yet
i trade absolutely nothing oh no it took my apron off oh my god i have to pick between drip or
function i think i have to pick between drip i'm so sorry do you want do you want your steel plate
body back i need sorry the drip is for life i'm for real for real the drip is for life like i mean
check this out i mean check it out no it's all good okay sure you want to trade with me when you
treat i swear if it's more poison what is this crossbow oh
whoa wait a pink skirt are you dressing me up i can't believe reeflings are dressing me up first
cosplay stream confirmed oh oh look at the long drip i said tihi the tihi you're not going to see
or put a little crossbow ball tips on whoa okay okay wait i think the scammer is better
what is it called i still get it it matter it's gonna matter okay i've got a scammer i'm not
afraid to use it yeah even in the game she has a dumpy honestly the pencil dress
yeah i mean look at that wow look at them polygons oh yeah it's all coming together
right we will start erin is the chicken man i think oh there's an amp if i pick up a beat i'm
pretty sure beat that imp up or i'll beat it up don't worry i'll get it i don't want i don't
want because the kev's in the way okay now we beat the imp up yeah yeah yeah yeah beat him up if he
drops a colored bead we can use it for the wizard quest i just realized i never killed it so i can i
can't tell we'll never know what it dropped oh wait did it drop something oh it did okay we need it
for the wizard tower quest but play the fron you need like four different components
what are the consequences of death in this game i think you keep your three highest
priced items or something like that right way we flings are i'm gonna stand at the gate
and i'll wait for everyone to come over so if you want to stand outside the gate of the
cow pen we will go do erin is the chicken next and then we'll actually do some
uh cooking again because we're gonna need a if we're wanting to wrap up in a month i'm definitely
gonna need to stop getting so distracted we'll do some cooking right all the reef flings out the
pen all the reef flings out the pen and then i'll walk again right where the heck is erin is the
chicken uh erin is starting off four quest points oh that's the rewards able to survive a skeleton
level 20 to attacking you surely we're leveled up enough surely where talk to Veronica outside
of draor manor where is it on the map draenor manor draenor village oh it was like outside
that creepy place yeah here okay okay so how do we progress we go across the bridge and we go up
and then we just keep going along and then we go up again past the wind okay i shall take a
breath and break don't get me oh no wait okay if you want to follow me if you want to follow me
reef fling is there anyone who's left behind you're not i don't recognize you there's a reef fling
getting beaten up by a cow right now about reef flings come outside the pen and you can follow
me with a golden heart i crafted this kamara and shielded myself heck yeah not all the reef flings
like watching this one reef and be up a cow i'm trying don't actually worry if i get stuck i'll
catch up yeah who is this surely you keep talking about it's me seeing surely okay there reef fling
is there any other reef fling i don't know render distance isn't helping i think that's just natural
okay let's if you want to follow me i have the golden hat i'm going to be very careful with my
pathing maybe you can follow me we're gonna follow the wow but chuchu all aboard
i made it to level four wish me luck we're getting there we're getting there
we'll definitely maybe do a bit combat training but yeah
i'll just kind of click one by one to make sure we don't get any like actually stuck on something
how many reef flings do we have in game i don't actually know how many we've had a few went off
line because we have hit the six hour mark um but we do have like a good amount of reef flings
all hanging out we are gonna do cooking though i need to cook jesse we need to cook reef fling
we need to okay i'm following the bunny honestly i should just follow the bunny i'm looking on
right we're just gonna follow report follow wait wasn't the bunny the one that gave me the poison
why would i find it a follow the bunny hope i can join in next time absolutely
absolutely whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa scary oh no a reef fling got stuck
oh no reef flings there i wasn't a k reef fling okay uh if you want to see where we are we're in
world 3a and we're outside the creepy creepy dream or manner now apparently we can get hurt in here
so if anyone doesn't have food do you want to trade me and i'll i'll share my food with you
if you send a trade offer i'll give you some food because apparently we can get hurt but i think
we can run away we just need to run away that's all i crash time to head back in game the forest
is pretty scary okay we got a light set my follow the bunny last time i did that found myself in
wonderland okay uh this reef fling needs some food here you go
is there another or has everyone got food did you all cook meat i think you almost cooked me
yeah oh there's fires to cook meat if you picked up meat from the calls
only now i noticed that the strange horse head reef fling that walks strangely is no more there
we are safe for now from the strange walking reef fling we've got someone giving us a gluck
gluck outside the case been getting been cooking the coups right okay i don't know what happens here
but i think the forest attack oh wait wait sorry sorry the quest is out here talk to the lady here
sorry talk to the lady talk to the lady at the door can you please help me i'm in a terrible
spot of trouble start earnest to chicken absolutely ah sounds like a quest i'll help
yes yes i suppose as a quest my fiance earnest and i came in this hoose
seeing that we were a little lost earnest decided to go in and ask for directions
that was an hour ago this house looks spooky can you see if you can find it for me
i'll see what i can do thank you thank you i'm very grateful okay what do we do we go inside now
i'm scared all right open the large door oh wait requirements for the quest you need
poison and fish food oh no where do you get poison and fish food for the other reef flings
i thought you were being funny other reef fling i didn't realize oh wait you're giving me something
why are you giving me is that a bloop bloop a holy symbol what does it do i wear it it's like a star
anyone need poison or fish food yeah i didn't i thought that reef fling was being funny giving
me poison fish food turns out it's actually for the quest that samson galaxy my life can't handle
another mmo been through for my life so this reefing so this reefing will just keep chat company
we're only doing 99 i don't know how to get poison or fish food uh there might be a reefling
that has enough supplies i didn't realize and every said oh crazy recommended items none or can you
get them in the house there's a spawn for them but they're very slow okay at least we can spawn the
items in the house right i'm gonna very quickly go for a pee i don't know why i need to pee so much
i think i'll make a tea as well sorry my voice is like really struggling
i really want to stream for long
i'm worried about how long i can last during my asmr stream a little tinkle break yeah
a little tinkle winkle the poison's in the house near the kitchen okay so at
at least we know the fish food and the thing he does respawn i'm gonna make another tea i'm so sorry
about all the breaks today it's my voice that i'm getting i'm getting nervous i'm not gonna
be able to make it but for the asmr in the sweet trying stream like oh sorry i just stood on the
mic sorry sorry about that i just absolutely obliterate your ears there and i apologize
i'll be back i'll literally be on minute okay
so
You
Whenever the jumpscare when the track and doesn't catch me coming into the room and I just don't meet and I'm like
You day women after cuddles is a bond and burn scape
Why is that so loud on the music
Thank goodness it doesn't leak the details on the air. I'm glad too
I think runescape know that some people
Stream it what we're doing evil. All right
Uh, what we're doing air nest
a chain
When refling went to go grab some speeds for people don't have one. Oh sugar. I don't have a speed either
Oh, wait
Uh, okay, we're waiting for spies
Trade for spade trade me trade mommy trade mommy mommy needs this thing just one, please
I
Did make another see I'm happy to see my pee was clear
um, I don't think I can do endurance my
My throat is very sore right now. It's very raw and it hurts. Okay
I'm needing your ink to help me unironically so is my throat. So I think what the deal is
When mersey goes live, which is in t minus
Two
And a half hours for snippets will raid into her
If that's okay
Um, there's a spade inside as well. Just woke up. How's runescape going? It's going good
Um, sadly my voice can't keep up. This is when I get really frustrated for streaming. I could happily stream 12 hours right now
But it really hurts. Um, okay dropping some poison and fish food. Okay. We'll wait until it looks up
um
Honey ink tea honestly
Mersey's in two hours. Yeah
All good been having tons of fun and it's already a long stream don't feel bad. Yeah
What do you mean? This is a baby stream for me. Are you joking me?
Literally a two-hour stream, which is like the average for a vtuber is like a millisecond in my time
Like oh, I feel so bad. I'm only going to stream eight hours today. Ah
I mean, what do you mean? I got to play a multiplayer game with quite
Literally like how freaking blessed is it to be able to put a multiplayer game
With reeflings live whilst we're having a carry-on just memin about freaking doing head bang in like I've been dripped out
I've been getting like gifts and stuff people giving money like
I'm it's it's not a job. Like I'm this is fun. Like I'm having so much fun
Oh, I wish there was some sort of secret to like fixing like my voice from vocal strain
But the sad secret is it's literally just shot up stop talking
Oh, which is so annoying
Better to end early than strain your throat. I mean, it's already strained right now, but uh
What do you mean multiple to ever talking yapping sessions honestly, so she happy happy up. Oh my god, a little spooky boy
Oh, did you like Emmys cover
Oh, it's in a mall. Oh, you're young just head off. Oh, that's what I did
I'm waiting for the fish food to load so the others can grab it back. I don't see it loading
Having so much fun just hanging out the reef limbs have all the quests done over it. No, the quests are not done
Please don't worry. We're doing the free quest. Erin is the chicken at the moment
We've done a hand. Oh god my biggest forehead in the way. Hold on. Let me just close this for a second
Here is all the quests we've done. So free quest. We've done cooks assistant
We're doing air big air nice the chicken right now
We did the mystery
The restless ghost Romeo and Juliet sheep shearer X marks the spot
We're finishing Erin is the chicken and then we're going back to update it. Sorry to grind on our cooking stats
Can't expect you to do constant endurance streams day after day. Sadly. I hate it. I don't like doing short streams
I just feel so like
I don't know what the word is like
I have been yearning for this day
For an entire year like for this time. Sorry not for this day in particular, but for this time
um, and it's just like
It's frustrating that the only reason I can't stream more is because of my voice and not because like I'm tired
Or I don't feel well or I don't want to type thing. It's frustrating. It's my voice
That's it. That's the only reason I can't stream like for long because it hurts. It hurts to talk right now
Uh Jesus, you haven't seen the whole song
Try to live up to the name, you know
Uh, I asked for a little bit off the top. Hey, yo, who's the barber?
Man, we gotta go both. Okay. The poison isn't loading on the floor for me
But I think we'll do it. So as long as you guys have accepted the quest, we're gonna go inside now refling
It's taking nice and slow. I think the trees hit you on the way past. So just be careful
You don't stray from the path too much
Assume we're supposed to go. Ah the tree freaking went for me
Open large door
Okay
Oh the there's like haunted thing
Where are we supposed to go get the gauge and tube? Where is that?
Uh, and not here. Maybe it's upstairs
Okay, we uh, uh, I'm gonna wait until
Oh
Oh, that's not good
Wait, I'm just gonna check all the reflins made it in go up the stairs reflins when you come inside
Is that the last refling
Oh
Who's that?
I think that's the last refling. We all need to go upstairs
How are you even there the chairs attacking him? Oh my god, that chair being your ass
Uh, okay that
I'll go up the stairs. Okay. Um
Oh
He like oh someone's beating them up. Wait, where are we supposed to go up here up these stairs to the left as soon as we come up
Nothing's being highlighted for me ruin light. You're failing me. Am I supposed to hear talk to the professor?
Be careful
Brian
It frustrates you because you can't control it and that's the most frustrating thing not being able to control something
Thank you iron weeper for the tip and yeah, just like uh really is telling you to use
All right hold on oh no, I'm mixing up hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on
That's not so easy, well look at them, dip, dip, dip, dip, oh maybe I should be reading
that out.
What would that say?
Roonlake is telling you to use your poison on your fish food, okay, okay I have poison
fish food, right now I won't.
Just hypnotize yourself, Strony trust me I love you and enjoy every second but your health
doesn't pour in.
Yeah, like as long as my voice doesn't break then I'm good to go.
Where, where is this freaking map telling me to go, I'm so good to go, I wanna go.
We were to go outside, oh right okay.
Oh no sorry, close the map, not close one's view.
Right, so go downstairs, okay, come downstairs, poison the fish food and then come back out
of the mansion.
Okay, oh this is a rough one to do together I think so if you've not got it.
The door won't open over here, oh okay okay okay, how do I get over there?
Wait open the door, the chair beating you up?
Oh no they just run around, I thought the chair was like beating you up in the game
Oh there's a rubber tube, I get it, get the gauge in the tube.
Oh my god, open the door, what's that?
Oh I'm actually kinda scared of that.
Wait I can't go in, the door's locked, oh right okay.
Someone's dropped a speed ahead if you need it by the way.
We're taking the long way around.
Okay I'm glad the chairs don't beat you up because honestly death by chairs is pretty embarrassing.
Right open the door, or I'm gonna throw rocks through your window.
Open the door, okay so one by one door but we need to get the key first.
Well she's a stubborn one but I guess she's up till the day she can take care of herself to some fish so hard.
Okay okay we're now outside, this is a very hard one to follow quest-wise.
Especially if you're at a rune-like, rune-crafting guild, stop.
Are you telling someone that we're rune-crafting guild?
Okay I'm just follow the Easter bunny, follow the bunny, the bunny, the bunny, follow the Easter bunny,
search compost heap, I love it, a bit of cheeky vandalism.
Okay we did it, oh what did I do?
You find a small key, okay and now, okay.
Oh there's a thing ahead, okay there's a fountain ahead, I don't know, is that already from here?
I feel like someone's probably stuck in the house right now.
As long as you try and come outside then you'll be fine.
So as long as you've all got the key, come to the fountain next.
There's a fountain through the trees, the trees might whip you but you should survive, like it's literally one HP at least.
Poisoned fish food on the fountain, use on the fountain.
Oh the tree just made a noise, use it on the fountain.
Okay, the piranhas start eating the food then dine float to the surface.
And then search the fountain, there seems to be a pressure gauge in here and a lot of dead fish.
Well yeah you just roll them, smoke them.
Come outside, yes I see, I see.
Okay once we've all stopped head banging into the fountain.
And then we go back into the house.
Anyone got some spare poison fish?
Ah the poison was in the house I think.
Wait we're outside the house, how do we get back in? Why is it making me go around in a circle?
I'm spinning around, get out of my way.
I didn't think for how much time you prepared for this by the way, how is it, is it like you expected?
To me you're having a lot of fun but maybe you have more to say.
On RuneScape? I'm getting whipped by a tree, sorry, sorry Ruflin's getting whipped by a tree because of me, sorry.
I mean RuneScape it took a little second to like get ready to stream out, that wasn't that bad.
Scale it in time, you just have to run in and pick the chip then run out.
Okay should we take it in turns, who wants to go first?
Ah fuck it I'll go first, I'll need a lead by example.
Okay grab the chip and then, okay I got whacked for two so just make sure you get out in time.
Would you prefer to be whipped by a tree?
Is it instance or are we going to have to wait for that to reload?
Oh no you've got it, you've got it, okay it's fine.
Oh he beat him up, he said nah hold on let me do this Ruflin's I got this.
He's going to skillspec him, he's going to skillspec, he's going to do the little twirl thing.
Oh streaming in general has been absolutely fantastic, it's gone exactly the way I wanted it to.
Like I love streams Nathan and I love long streams and yapping people's heads off and it's just gone absolutely amazing.
Just fantastic, for me I don't like the mega super professional streams don't mind me.
Some people really like it, let's go, has everyone got it?
Thank you Ruflin for killing the skelly boy, has everyone got the rubber tube?
I don't think everyone's got it, I don't know if it's been a bit funny but you should be able to go in and get the rubber tube now that you've got the key.
Oh someone's getting attacked over there, there's a Ruflin, did a Ruflin, oh I thought a Ruflin just perished there.
I'm happy to hear that, yeah.
There is nothing like, yeah professional streams, where's the fish food?
Upstairs is the fish food, Ruflin, someone says.
Okay I'll wait here until the other Ruflins are caught up because it's not fair to skip ahead.
I like when funny Scott women yapt to me for hours, simple as, nothing more.
Now people really enjoy professional streams from other people which is great but for me I'm just like...
Oh we're getting two heads bang, yo I'm starting to think this is getting, hold on.
Oh no I can't wait, let me zoom up a bit, let me take one more step for no particular reason at all.
Okay let me take one more step for no particular reason at all.
Because it's absolutely no reason at all.
We are literal children, this is terrible.
That awful getting, hey hey hey he dancing on it, he dancing on it, he doing the split on it.
I love your silly yapping.
Oh my god a ghost is going for it.
Is there a Rufling on the outskirts?
Aw I think I'm too far away to be able to see if someone's at the compost heap right now.
Oh no someone's getting beaten up, oh no it's not him though.
I have salmon if you want a Rufling that's literally protecting us all.
There's salmon juice, whoa what is that? Oh is that for me?
Wait should I do this in the middle? I don't know what he does.
Scottlefish are you there? Should I do it or no? I don't know if the old man's got a good quest or not.
Did I talk to him?
Do it, okay someone says do it.
Oh there you are, I hoped you would talk to me, I get so lonely, I have a present I must get going now.
Oh he just gave me an uncut emerald, I didn't even ask anything.
Oh don't mind if I do, I thought he was going to like whiff to me are we?
Oh I see the poison, whoa poison's like 700.
Well I know where the poison is if anyone needs to know it's by the left.
There's your comment.
Does he need help?
You wish to trade with me, what do you wish to trade?
Oh you're giving it, oh the diamonds, how you call them?
I don't know the rocks in the ground, where are these called? It's not jewelry but they're rocks.
Where are diamonds category? Where's the category of ruby and plaffa and that?
Gemstones, oh my god I forgot that word there.
Jeez Louise, I literally forgot the word gems there, I apologise.
Watch ads showed up tipped and left, or in gemstones, I got out.
Oh god we're all headbanging.
Are you practicing later for when the next 10 audios come out?
Wait where is that headbanging?
Headbanging.
Oh my god we really are a cult clearly, look at us go.
Oh do you need health? Holy crap you need health like right now.
I've got salmon, this should heal you up.
Go go go.
Is there any wreathlings, oh no they're self healing.
Is there any wreathlings on the outskirts? I can't really tell.
I don't want to go ahead in case there's someone outside doing that fountain bit.
Is everyone here? Did we make it?
If there's a wreathling, who did that? Who did that?
That was you?
Okay we're reporting you for harassment.
Interesting we're in sync for me but on stream.
My ping is really high to everyone.
They've had plenty of time, yeah is everyone here I think so.
Hi hi how's stream going? It's been going amazing, look at me and the wreathling gang we're doing questing.
Okay I think everyone's got the plastic tube, they get the gauge and tube, get the oil can next.
So open this door and we'll go through.
Okay I think we're all ready.
Don't have the tube but also got the gauge but you don't have the tube.
I do have the tube.
Okay we need to interact with this blue thing over here but you've not got the tube? Who's not got the tube?
Who's not got the tube?
Tube you just run in and pick up when it spawns.
Go in the closet and get the rubber if you don't have- oh!
I shouldn't have said that.
Oh my god the ShadowbanTV's Twitter, all of our Twitter's looks like a Shadowban, it's ridiculous.
Like how sensitive it is.
Ah.
Oh what's that? It's a big thing.
Oh it's gone.
Did you get the tube? Did you get the tube? I think so.
Alright fun part of the quest let's go!
Let's go- oh the door- the door's fine.
Oh wait hold on sorry I probably just closed that door on you.
Okay search the bookcase.
Search the bookcase.
Oh is that one by one? Maybe a one by one moment, hold on.
Hey let's go.
Okay go down the ladder.
Oh wait go down the ladder when you're ready is that everyone?
Yeah that's everyone.
Once you get through the bookshelf.
Okay we did it the whole gang's here.
No refling left behind.
Oh my god we're beating up the rats literally.
Oh god what do we do?
Okay there's a lever on the wall.
Pull lever alpha on the wall over here.
I assume this is going to be instanced to us?
So I don't know.
And then pull lever Bravo!
Oh the music's all like-
Okay.
Now this gate is a jar.
And English if it's like slightly open it's a jar.
Pull lever D.
Oh I'll pull the D lever all day long.
Come over here weak one.
What did that do?
Okay.
Oh god it's a one by one gate.
Why is there a biggest issue right now a one by one gate?
Oil can has a slow respawn as well.
I think we all need an oil can.
So we're just gonna have to go for it and be patient.
I'm sure you can wait.
I don't know if all the levers are the same for everyone.
It looks like you guys are going different ways so I think it might be different.
World hop when you get into the room and then hop back.
Yeah you guys are really going different ways for me so I think it's different for everyone.
Oh the classic one by one gate it's ogre.
Lever solution is the same for everyone.
How is everyone going to wait?
Are you guys juicing this one?
That way everyone can grab it faster.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay I love this moonlight plugin because if I had to do this by my brain
it would be over.
This is crazy.
All levers are unique in their own way.
Exactly.
Let's see.
Pull this lever.
We're almost done?
Okay I was going to say that's like a lot of freaking question.
Oh wait sorry this one.
I'm going to see if my tea is at an acceptable temperature if I'm going to scold myself on it.
That's why there's one or the other.
All these doors.
Alright.
Am I taking it and then you guys are world hopping?
Okay.
And then you're coming back to this world?
Yeah this track is...
Gen 2 based after old school runescape tracks?
Question mark.
Oh wait I should be facing you today.
Honestly I wouldn't mind that.
I'm kind of down for that.
I was actually thinking of Legend of Zelda Minish Cap
but brought you know to kind of modern standards for Gen 2
but honestly runescape?
Runescape always do.
If we had like a mischievous little brat thing this song
was kind of like...
not circus- I guess it's circus-esque.
Does everyone have an oil can?
Or...
Oh there's a respawn.
Well that took a whole second.
Everyone got an oil can?
Yeah no you're taking it now.
Okay if you have an oil can come back out to the center over here.
If you don't have an oil can wait for it to spawn in that room
or you can do what's called world hopping
where you purposely swap to a new world
and it should be like a new instant.
But if you have an oil can you're allowed to come out here.
Minish is 20 years old now.
Stubious brat.
Eh I would watch Zelda.
That's an idea.
I will uncontroll.
Oh unconditionally support whoever gets sea shanty.
No it has to be like hidden
but when you know what it is you know.
Oh there's a reefling there.
We're not ready yet.
I'll just check if anyone's back here.
Other than that reefling.
Oh there's one there.
And one there.
I was just straight up reefling.
You actually got the name reefling.
I'm surprised no one else took it.
I don't know that thing about it.
I guess we'll just beat up.
We're gonna beat up rats out here.
Okay we're just gonna get our combat level a bit higher.
Oh I just leveled up.
What did I get?
I got a Taksix.
Oh there's spiders as well.
Yeah let's just level up our combat a little bit.
Why not?
Us following her gives me
Ugandan knuckles flashbacks.
This beat only fake queen.
Would you hum shanti?
Yeah I managed to get the reefling name
still five hours in ancient...
That's sea shanti.
We're just leveling up our combat.
There's still a reefling over there getting absolutely...
What are you getting annihilated by?
A rat?
Oh okay that's fine.
There's one there.
There's a third?
Yeah.
We've got Hatsumiku chilling over there.
Reefling there.
Now we have a max roll.
Get some level.
No way that rat just dunked my shield.
I went bonk.
Yeah and we would have chosen
Dewey.
Chocho is Dewey.
You have found Dewey.
I remember that meme went like absolutely viral.
Someone said that was the start of the brain rot meta
when it comes to memes.
Which I found rather unsafe.
Wow.
I think there's someone else that's fighting that.
Here we go.
We've almost got all of our cans.
And then we'll level up on fishing.
I keep saying fishing.
It's not fishing.
We're doing kooten.
My PC's fan just started up.
I get nervous when my PC's...
I'm like what's wrong?
What's wrong?
Oh!
Last reefling that needs to can?
The question mark?
I don't see anyone else doing the levers.
Am I going crazy?
Or are we clear?
Have we did it?
Are we ready to move on?
Are we stunting on as they're dancing?
Okay.
If everyone's got a can, up the ladders please.
Little reeflings.
If everyone's got a can.
Oh wait no!
Sorry!
There's one more.
Sorry.
There's one more reefling.
I'm sorry.
I debated you.
There's one more reefling.
I think they're still doing the lever stage.
I'm sorry reefling.
I debated you.
You can come back down and we'll keep killing the means.
He's getting absolutely beaten up by that rat.
See I'll help you out.
There you go.
Did you get it?
I don't know.
You're moving around erratically.
Is the reefling...
I don't know.
Are you stuck on the levers?
You're not taping.
Go on.
I'll catch up.
Are you sure reeflings?
I don't want to feel anyone feel left out.
VR chat was wailed.
No it's just a feel of weird.
I was going to have to play VR chat to learn how the 3D models work.
I have no idea how that 3D model streaming works.
I don't know if you can use other programs as well.
I'm leveling combat not to brag about it.
You will learn.
Can you say era again?
Era?
Era.
Errot switch and tracks.
You don't need to use VR chat for 3D models?
I honestly don't know anything about it.
Girls want 3D models and I'll pay for it.
That's pretty much all I know about 3D models.
I'm joking.
Just say you want 3D models and we'll get it.
VR hypnotize and interest and...
Oh!
I saw VR ASMR videos.
I thought that was pretty cool
And plus it would cool to see the height difference of the girls as well go on y'all find you
Okay, okay, we're being sent away by the reflying right upstairs everyone we're being sent away
Upstairs, okay, there's a lever here pool another crunk
Oh
Okay, okay, okay, right we need to go up the stairs again. Right. Let's go back here. I'm a sip my tea
You literally talk like a real mummy with the girls they want 3d models. Yeah, I'll just pay for it darlin
There you go darlin holiers. I don't know what it's about, but you just enjoy yourself
It's true. They'll be like I want this. I'm like, oh, you just oh, you get it. See you just enjoy yourself, hen
Uh, right. Okay. Talk to the professor at the top of the stairs. Oh, you found anything yet? I have everything give him to me here then
All his oh you put them
Noises are being made. Oh, he's a man. Thank you, madam. I was dreadfully
Irritating being a chicken. How can I ever thank you? Well a cash reward is always nice
Of course, of course
You're awarded four quest points of 300 coins
Oh really quick other than like the horrific
Issues that was like a really quick quest
Um, right we're not doing any more quests then we're leveling up next
Money, let's go
What is this pressure gauge? Don't touch it. It's gonna explode. Where we do
What pressure gauge?
Mm-hmm. Is there like any other scientific things? Nah, I guess that's it and we just leave
But that
It's in the fountain. That's why you need to poison it. How bizarre
Oh, there's the fish food
I guess that's it. We're already we're already freaking doing this quest. Hold on.
Wow
Oh wait, why why did you not let me out that door?
Open large door. Wait, why does it make me turn backwards?
I keep it doesn't let me have this door open large door
It won't open front door is one way
Whoa. Oh, so we have to like go all the way around again. Oh, okay
Brother interesting take from the deputy. All right, let me let me sip into my teeth
Okay, yeah, I'll go another one by one door. It's over. I like the chairs like chase you
Do you can you even go that way? Oh you can you can come around the this side?
Can you teach me what to play rinse game tempo?
Get right go ahead back
Oh
The tree
I don't want to go into fight move. What's going on? Why can't I move?
Hello
Am I missing why can I not why that tree literally had me in a death grip. Oh my gosh
Mostly was a guy a fan
Don't get skill checked by a tree literally one arrow
There. I think the tree liked you honestly
Okay, we made it but I don't think that's all the reeflings man going outside is dangerous. Literally. Oh, there's a reason there
Right, we'll wait until a cool army. I have an army of reeflings requesting but we're about to go level up or cooking next
I'm trying to try to finish my honey tea before it gets cold
Oh
Okay, um
Next thing we're going to do is we're going to travel north. We're going to take a
A west and then north and we're going to be outside
Uh the village
But we need to go get fishing rods and stuff. I don't think there's a fish shop nearby
So I think we're going to go to the grand exchange and buy fishing rods
Army definitely not cool. This music is giving me a
Fatal dose of nostalgia
Pass so much since the last get rector is
As I get stuck and fling fast and fly I never got anywhere
RuneScape is like either you got into or you didn't right. I think that's everyone. Hopefully question mark
as we head banger way of victory
I don't know about the other reefling that got stuck and sent us forward, but thank you for not holding us back
But at the same time I feel bad because it's like the whole point of this is to the question and stuff together
Right, let's get in the nicer parts of the channel the the evil at bay type of thing go away
Wait, let me finish my tea
Either you got into it and you're still playing this day or you didn't see I got into guild wars instead. I don't play killed
Oh
I thought it gave us feathers, but it didn't I was just an image of a feather because we need feathers to do fishing
I was so into it and was so shy that in typing class
I won't be glad as RuneScape rules and wait for someone to see it and ask me if I played
Oh, that's such a shame
Feathers we need feathers
Birds of a feather
Right, we're gonna take a left and go
Oh wait, no, do we need to go to ports RM?
I think we actually need to go at the fishing shop to buy our rod and feathers
the fishing shops
West and south so we'll go west and south
Just follow me with my my golden my golden stuff. Oh, no, I'm gonna follow them the rabbit
Okay, we follow the rabbit you coming refland
Yes
Uh
You take us westward and then south on the main road
Feathers. Oh, no. I'm not saying feathers on
Oh, we need some feathers. Wait. How did you say feathers?
Feathers
Oh, it sounds like I'm kind of saying a father. I guess feathers
Your father. All right, because in this line, you also say like, oh, that's your father in and it's like, ah, that's my dad
I don't want change
I never played Guild Wars or RuneScape. I want silly Scottish women
Yes
Your we feathers
You'd weave it behind refling you put that you need to put your way running boots on you put your
Ah
Oh, we're gonna do a brawl
Uh at the end of stream
We're gonna hop over the wall and fist fight each other and I'm gonna get a rose and I'll give it to whoever wins the fisticuffs
Oh, pardon me
Okay, in this shop, you will need to buy a rod most of you already have one
You guys so fast. So trade with Garrett
and then
buy. Oh, no, there's only one
That costs five coin. So buy one
Do we need feathers or do we need the fishing bait? Is it fishing bait we need?
I made this tea so honey
Oh, that's sweet. That's too sweet. I can actually finish that all the sweetness is that warm feathers for trout
and
Feathers for trout and salmon
I thought ticking up. Oh it is
Hmm
I don't have no money
Maybe I do
Okay, that's all I can buy with what I've got
I'm not gonna offer anything else. I've got 73 feathers. I didn't think this far ahead
I opened a stream and didn't see you here
wherever
I wish this to trade with you except trade
Eh, I still have a key. Oh, that's gonna be a lot of feathers to spread about. I'm not gonna lie
How do you have so much money?
Right, let me buy feathers for what are these feather path?
What's that?
I don't know if I buy fifth. Oh, you can
Oh
That's so smart inside the feather pack. I'm gonna keep some heels on me
Right, I can give like feather packs to reasons
Why does that not buy when I click at this?
Wait, I'm dropping them. Oh, hold on. I'm being dumb
I can trade the feather
Okay, I've got like a thousand feathers now who needs feathers
I think everyone needs feathers honestly if you need feathers trade me and I'll give you wait actually I should like give 200 feathers each
I'll just say buy 50 and then I'll give 200 feathers
Oh
A lot of spreading feathers on my
Should we get a harpy? We should totally get a harpy. I'm glad to take a feather pack. Okay trade me if you need feathers
I'll try and give you like 200
Whose outfit is that? Is that even a reflim? Are you a reflim? I don't know. I think that might just be someone caught in the crossfire
All right, let's see except and then offer
200 and then we'll go fishing except
Wait, what hold on wait wait wait wait wait why did that not work 200 and
Yeah, oh juice. Sorry
I don't know where that went. I just disappeared into space
Okay, there's 200 for you and then there's two
How do you
And then 200 for you
And then sugar mommy
You say that as if a reflund didn't just hand me all of his paycheck and runescape
Where's strong at now? We're at port sarim. We're on world 3 80
We're currently at port sarim
That's a lot. Okay, my PC just sped up trying to zoom that in
And then we're going to go up to barbarian village to get salmon because there's a permanent fire there
and
I'm gonna do 200
No, I've done it again. Sorry. I keep teasing you with a feather. I've done it again
Ah, that's not teasing me right now
I'm tickling you with the feathers. I'm like, oh, do you want the feather and like tickle you and then run away with it?
I'm like
Like pushing it against your face like ASMR and then like
You need feathers too. I'll buy a ton as well. So when we head over there, we should be fine
So if you need more I can always get like always just trade more
Teasing us with a feather honestly
Hmm. Thank you pretty lady played with me
actually
Uh, has everyone got what the where the heck is the guy? Where's the NPC to buy off of? I can't see there's too many of us
Dismiss. He's not for me. All right, where's the guy to buy freaking things off? Oh, there he is
Uh, I'm gonna buy like a bunch of feather packs and open them up
Oh
My god, I've already spent 10k on feathers. Jeez this game is not cheap the economy's in shambles
Right, that's like literally almost 5k that's more than enough just anyone else you need some too
That work it did work. Thank you. How did you know that our weaknesses are feathers? Stop using your powers on us
I was like never thought of it. Did I do a tickling?
Am I gonna go? I don't think I got no. I think I got you tickling me artwork
You're welcome
Does anyone else need any feathers or are we all ready to go?
We need to thank sugar daddy reflin
The one that gave me poison that I thought was being bred
I realized I'm saying I didn't accept the quest and had to loop with the chick. Oh, no
Sorry, did you manage?
I could take some please
Oh, no, where are you?
Trade
And then offer x-man. All right. Has everyone got a rod not the one that's already attached to you one bought from the thing
Were you giggling we sugar daddy reflin and giggling?
Kill it. What's what's heavier?
Kilograms you look right. It's everyone ready to do the walk the walk
Yes, I finished it. Oh, no, you need some hold up except trade. We're getting there. We're getting there
Wait, no, I don't no. I don't need your rod. Stop. I don't need your rod
You keep your rod to yourself reflin. It's not the time for that
I do have a rod for fishing now. I need some feathers. Thanks
So there would catch up. Yeah, right. Is everyone ready to follow me and I'll take us to barbarian
You need a fly fishing rod for the fishes. Oh, we need a specific type of rod. Of course we do
What rod of alcohol? I've got a fishing rod. I need a fly rod. Hold on trade Garrett
Uh
Fly fishing rod right does everyone have a fly
Fishing rod before we move on to the next location
Uh less than two hour warning for mercy modest
Nope, do you need me
To
Oh
I hope it restocks. You're out
I do have a pretty fly rod pretty flat for a white guy
You know, it's kind of hard just to get along today
He asked for
What's that? He asked for ink. He asked for a 13. Yeah, instead they drew a 31
I don't they're not restocking. They're like so slow to restock
I don't know if I can wait we are we're going to be right next to the grand exchange. Maybe I'll buy some off grand exchange
I'll go to the grand exchange. Yeah, okay. We're going to make it to the grand exchange. Don't worry
If you don't have a fly fishing rod, we're going to be very close to the grand exchange. So don't worry. You can follow me
Follow golden golden me
Is there any more reasons in that shop actually can't tell
Camera I'm sure there's a way to turn off first, but
Right, we'll follow
our
Gated or gate or bunny gate
a little hopsy
Yeah, okay, no one's in the the shop everyone's here
We're going to go to the grand exchange to make sure everyone has a fly fishing rod and to also deposit all of our items
Because our inventory is getting like pretty full of stuff and I don't want to be walking around really so much money
Oh, there's the brawl. This is where we're going to do a bar brawl
Yay, bye
Oh
You can always hover over and then just say follow
Follow
Follow the leader leader. Oh, no, someone got stopped by a mysterious old man
Oh, you should always talk to the mysterious old man. He'll give you
um
I uh gemstone and uncut gemstone
Okay, we're already follow the leader leader our ink shall blot
So I have 10 strong ease. I got some there already. Okay. Okay
Always talk to the mysterious old man got it
Sometimes he gives you a maze to run through. Oh
The series old man giving uncut things. Hey
Yo
The old man can offer to send you to solve a maze and that one gives amazing rewards. Okay. Okay
I know the sign which lady doesn't give you anything good. I'm like 99% sure she gives you about cabbage or something
Um
I like this spinning one
I can't remember what it is. It's like the item spins around and you have to identify it or something
Amazing rewards
Love that maze quest love it
Oh, it's gonna, it's gonna scale
No, it's not getting
Oh, I'm not too too song
It's terrible. It's absolutely terrible
Oh
No
Our biggest enemy a bridge right we're gonna go to the grand exchange to empty our inventory
So we only have feathers and a fly fishing rod
I don't there's a few fishers. I don't know if they're bots or not
As long as they're not talking
Then I think we'll be safe
Because I don't want to turn off public chat because it's fun like having you guys talk like both in-game and in-stream
So where the real fishing begins the seventh grade computer lap day fishing
Is it terrible? No one is gonna argue. She wasn't that one
honestly
Right, we're back at the grand exchange
Where
Right, where's the reefling that has the rods we desire for those reeflings who don't have a rod please
Reach out to
To me
To camon 1000 if you don't have a rod caught uh, I don't know where camon is. I can't
Is that deep?
Oh, there here here there the one in the the one in the smithing cape
If you don't have a fly fishing rod trade, then I'm gonna put my stuff in the bank
But
Let's just hope everything in here other than like all of these
Keep that
Wait, what if I don't go
Oh, no, I'll have a better shield. That's why
And then put that away and then put the fishing rod away and then put the money away
I don't know. I didn't mean to click that. Okay
Okay, we did it. We're ready to fish and cook
Apparently everyone has a rod jeez
It must do a rod
A fishing rod
It's my idea the strange old woman in the forest isn't full with so many strange requests
Uh, I guess we're ready to take off if everyone's emptied their inventory
And you should have a rod and feathers and then we are going to go fishing and level up our cooking eggs
exponentially. Is everyone ready?
All aboard the golden apron train
I'll just make sure in case someone's stuck at the bank right now. It's kind of hard to tell because there's like so many
Oh, no, there's only
Rods out the way to everyone
so few female
And it is what it is
Oh wishes to trade with you. Okay. What's up?
Are you giving me your you give me your banana? Oh, yeah
Wait, is this a thing? Well, no, it's not. Okay. I've just been given the
Did you just finish be honest or ate it? I'm sorry. I just ate it right in front of you. I'm sorry. I just ate your banana
Right, is that everyone?
Uh
Can I store it somewhere or just drop stuff off? Oh, yeah. So do you see over here how it says
uh bank banker
And then click on your inventory and it'll put it in the bank
This empties out your inventory. The only thing you want right now is a fly fishing rod and feathers
banana
It's tweet all over again
I actually had a lot of fun. Thank you. That's me. I don't know what it's I don't know if it's gotten more popular or not
But when I woke up it was like 1000 likes and I'm like, oh
Okay, that should hopefully be
Uh, and then we'll take all the reeflings away. Actually we'll follow. Well, I don't know if all the reeflings are over here
Think you got it
She just ate that man's banana live on public on stream in public in front of everyone
Okay, is that all reeflings? I'm like nine names. Oh, no one more one more. There's one more reefing
Look at that fit look at the feet size
Okay, we now follow
The reeflings I thought was making a threat via the poison and fish fish
That video was good
Okay reeflings, we're going to barbarian village. Uh, hopefully there's no bots talking
I'm probably just gonna click ignore
If there's any bot so we don't have to world hop because this is a pretty quiet world in general
Yeah, it was great. I lost that video
Really
I was like wondering should I like over compliment
Over complicate it and like say like certain words phrase or whatever and I was like, no
Just be super simple about it. So I was
I
Did it
Right, okay. So this is barbarian fishing section
It's normally bought it, but I don't know this may be real people
This is the best like free to play area. We'll do here. We'll lure our fishing world
And uh, how are you a cow? You were a bunny a second ago
Oh
I've already caught a fish. Whoa the fishing is so fast
Oh my god, really gonna be leveling up so quickly
Well, once whatever you catch there's a pair of my fire over here that we could cook
Everyone did get level 20 fishing, right or I've just dragged you over here for nothing
I hope everyone's uh
Oh, you're all up to 20
Uh
Oh, no, I thought everyone was 20 fishing. I'm so sorry
Oh, I'm not level 20. No
No
My suggestion
If you're not level 20, you need to get that net and go back to the thing. I joined late. I'll level in tunes night later
Not me, but I'll jump over and get it quick
Oh, no, there's a banana on the floor random banana
Oh
So any that video in your altar is one of the whole
How many leaks is that I'm allowed to know
If you aren't level 20, I would suggest going
Back to Lumbridge teleport to Lumbridge get your small fishing net out the bank at the top
And then go back to that spot until you're 20
And then coming here
Well, I'm already level 21. Jesus so much faster doing this. It's crazy
Is that 1.4?
As long as people enjoyed it, that's the main thing
What level to bait fish here, I'm not sure I only brought feathers for fly fish
No comment
Okay
Should I do a burp at the end of one of them? Maybe I should they do like a burp version
But yes
If I we're probably gonna be here for like a hot second
Uh mercy's going up in an hour 40. So honestly, I think for the rest of the stream
We're gonna be here. So if you want to level up to 20 cooking you certainly can
It's sorry 20 fishing and then like come back here. Like we'll probably most likely be here
And
Hopefully I can stop burning fish and then I can start burning through the supplies that were gifted because like I think I got like
2000 fish gifted to me. I'll be back. Good luck. Yeah
Have a good time. You can teleport via your magic spell
Get on to
Get to
Lumberge again and do that small thing and then come back here once you've got your fly fishing rod
And I've got loads of feathers on me
Yeah, this is where the ground begins. We are currently at 25 cooking which is decent
I wanted to get 40 before stream. I think 40 is part of that camera animation
I think 40 is 40 realistic before
The mercy goes live. I'm not sure
I'm not sure bait fishing is 25. Oh, that's even worse. How do you get
grapes actually
From the grand exchange. I don't actually know where you harvest them
Tea time
We're actually going to get decent level in fishing. Yeah. Whoa, it's 58 peter fish. That's quite a lot
All things considered
I'm gonna level up in fishing again on this one stalk of enemy door
Yeah
Oh, that's a lot of trout on the floor. That's literally 10 key worth of fish
kxp per hour
If you don't cook the fish, yeah, we're gonna have to stop and use this fire
But this is a permanent fire that we can utilize for ourselves
Which is fantastic
Would it make sense to just buy them in bulk? Yeah, especially if you do that route and just buy 66. Oh, that would be daunting
But it's definitely a possibility
Hmm
I'm wondering maybe we could do react andy content
I don't know if there's like stuff that's safe for youtube reaction whilst we do this
because
Don't get me wrong. I'm entertaining, but I don't think I'm that entertaining for like a 30 hour grind
If I was doing grapes
Oh
So maybe
We put stuff on in the background
78 p for cooking trout. Whoa
That's so fast we're literally 26 already
That is so fast
We need mancraft parkour subway surfers and the bomb in the stream on play
70 is so much when we unlock salmon. I don't even know how much fun it is
I'll stop burning it stop burning it
Just put some surf in the corner
Okay
Yeah, so this is like free grinding as well if you pick up this fish that people drop
Oh, they literally went on two cooking levels doing one batch of fish. That's crazy
I'm so fast
Right, let's leave people alone
Here fishy fishy
We need to be quiet. We're just gonna get to the molly salmon or 90 cooking eggs. Okay. That will
I'll listen to you. Yeah, whenever, but I've lost my mind entirely see tomorrow rest well, please rest well
Gotta get up tomorrow. We can oh fun time. Oh my god. It's rinse scape in real life
I'm trying to get easily watched. There's been nothing by yapping. It's because of my voice. It's so swan
My faceman no dragon harpoon specking on free world. Oh
Oh
Wow
I haven't seen it
Honestly, we I thought we were gonna do 40 before mercy comes on but if we managed to like fish
to high heaven
We might be past 40. I don't know. I don't want to jinx it but
40 on the first runescape stream seems pretty decent work
And we also did fun questing
We got how many first one two
We're so fast one two
three four five
Six and seven well, maybe do
Got overtime tomorrow, so I'm gonna have to so have plenty of listening time
I mean
For anyone that needs to go to sleep or you need to go do some things
Please do not worry. You're not missing out on much. This is literally the gameplay for the next uh hour and a half
I'm not even kidding
We're just fishing and then uh
We're catching the fish and then cooking them and then leveling up cooking. This is literally squirting me right now
Brian
Hey, how strong are you back from work and jumping back on
Where are you at?
Hi tiny spinny
Hope you had fun at work. We are currently in world 3a
And we are in barbarian village. We're fishing so the grand exchange
Varrock teleport and we're at the fishing village
We have a fly fishing rod and we have a feather and we're catching the fish and cooking them on the perma
a
cookie thing
Um once I'm experienced enough not to burn fish
I most likely will cook all the fish that the reeflings gave me because I don't want them to go to waste
Um because that was a lot of money that the reeflings handed me. Um
I don't
I'll cook all of that and see where we are. I think lobsters
I got quite a few lobsters
trout, salmon, all of that. So we're gonna cook all of that
I don't think we're gonna be on wanes by the time mercy comes on
Um
I think tomorrow's my eighth morris stream
So I definitely try and rest my voice so that's gonna be so strong
I'm ready for another 2am yap session. We're listening to the Scottish last
I've got plenty of yapping. We're like oh someone's got a mini
mini quest a two jump
Hot to free power hot to free power
Such a tense gameplay. Oh my god. It's so intense. Wait. I'm not even fishing anyone
That's probably the only thing that kills me about this game like when it comes to fishing and stuff
It's when the boxes move
But it is very tense into um
Like pick up all the fish that are already here and just do that and spawn that
Lobster requires 40 cooking so might be a way. I don't want to burn them
Here we are going to 4am. I'm ready
Yes, so if you want to join in some say hi world 380 um barbarian village fishing spot free to play free to play
a little cheeky free to play um
If I get the runescape
Um, if I do end up getting the cooking cape
We might take a break
But I wouldn't mind doing membership quest at some point because I've never actually done them
And I'm too scared to do them on my own, but if you guys are with me, I'm not scared
Yes, I think tomorrow's ASMR stream and then day after is trying sweet
And then after is Skyrim and I get to rant. No not rant. Sorry. I get to um
Mumble away about Skyrim for ages
Lobsters have a 60% chance to burn at level 40. Yeah, I'm not wasting lobsters. They are
That is rough
That's rough
I don't want to waste a lot. Wait, because that was so much fish I got given
God, we're like leveling up our fishing so easily
Right, we are full. Let's see. Can we get two levels out of this if we don't burn them?
It burns for the first one
Dude, waterfall fires, it gets you to combat level 30. What?
Really?
I know I got some quests really give you a lot of XP, but
Can't wait for days more, but I'm lucky for the time. Maybe I'll pass a bit later. Hmm
Um
Don't worry if you can't make it to any stream like I think the boss will stay up and
I'm not going to be doing ear licking because something weird is going on with YouTube
It's going on a little weird with YouTube and I don't know what's going on. So I'm not risking it
As I gave you all those lobsters you can burn them if you need to
I'd rather not like waste the XP like if it was potential full XP like it's okay to burn these trout for example
Oh
Oh, come on one more and I'll level up. Okay. There we go 20. Oh, yeah
I want 40 before mercy comes online. We're under the clock refunds
But under the clock
Empty inventory. Let's get it ish get it. I don't know if I should fish or if I should honestly
Just put my stuff away and pick up
But if everyone was picking up what was put on the floor then we wouldn't have enough trout to go around
Mmm
Where would be the first day smart? Hopefully YouTube will get off
No, it's like cracking down everywhere on anime smart in particular if you want to call it anime smart
It'll be faster to loot the fish if you just want to do a cooking. That's what I'm thinking
If I just do that instead
Mmm
It's nice to get the level of XP, but I feel I'm gonna like blast ahead of you refunds if I do that
Would you guys be upset if I picked up trout?
Hopefully not
It would blast me forward though like compared to everyone's level
Go for it
Ah
What do I need I just need trout. I can't cook salmon because I'm too low level wait examine
No, I don't want salmon. I can't cook it. I want trout
Right, we'll see how far this gets me ahead if I do this method where I don't fish
Maybe you guys can drop the fish for me and we get fish train going
It's two more
Right, let's cook this batch
I like fish
The fish are so amazing
Basically, if you can't see what they're actually doing there are a few minutes. Yes
I think that's what the problem is why in real life is fine, but anime's getting swapped with it
I say anime beach over animation. You know what me
Anyway, I start blasting
We're fish slaves let's go
Sounds a bit fishy, but okay
Are we gonna make it I think we are
I said
No idea when I said oh
29 already. Oh my god, this is so fast
I'm I'm saying it's fast now because it's going to be so slow later, but like I'm happy
I like only burnt four from that batch as well
That trout is getting cooked to perfection by me
I see trout I see trout
I don't know. There's a cooked trout
Right, I'm gonna have to fish you go fish. Oh wait, someone wants to trade with me. Hold on
Oh, you'll never guess what it's true
He he he
Oh, no, you cancelled. Oh, you don't have enough incidentary space. Oh, no, sorry. I don't know how many I've got left like
Space room freaking yeah
Trade modified blink blink blink. It's so serious. I don't know if that's too much. Oh, no
Is it? Oh, you filled me. Oh my inventory you filled my inventory. Thank you beef life
I'm terrible, but thank you very much. We've flown
It's running out here playing cooking mummy. Literally. I'm feeding you don't get 100 success on trout until 49
That's so rough. I don't remember it being so like that
Mmm
We're already gonna level up again
I don't know when we unlock being able to cook salmon, but it's gonna be soon
We're gonna drop all the trout in the south spot of salmon here. Yeah
If you don't overlap on the salmon, it makes it so easy to pick up
Wow
Are we gonna be 50 by the time mercy?
I
We may honestly
I'm I'm cooking by gas. I'm cooking the best I can
Okay, we had like way more burnt in that batch. So it really is just randomized
Let's empty our inventory and then let's grab all these troops
Oh
Over there Hayden. Oh wait, sorry
Uh, I don't know if you have to take into I can't how much like inventory space I'll have
Okay, yeah as long as you put whatever inventory
Oh my god
Love's recessing
The key to power leveling is slave teamwork. Honestly, we're doing pretty good
We're already launching the 30s
I think we can fly past the 40s
honestly
I strongly have been away from what's the how's it going?
We have done some quests some free to play quests. We are currently at
barbarian village
And I'm currently using the reef wings
Um to slave fish for me. So we're getting trout and I'm currently like leveling up like crazy right now
Every batch of trout is making me go up another level. I'm already 31 cooking
We, um, we're messing around having fun on quest
Uh, and now I'm just doing I'm actually tempted to go to the grand exchange to
Oh, sorry, I'm pressing the wrong button. Um
I'm tempted to go to the grand exchange to drop the feathers and the fishing rod off just to do like full inventories as well
I think I may I'm going to be right back reef wings. Okay. I'm going to drop the feathers and the fishing rod away
That you guys can stay don't worry. Don't get separation anxiety. I'll be right back
I'm mommy's going to the grand exchange and back again. You'll be okay
It's fine
Mommy will be right back. See I'm cross the water. Bye. Bye. I'll be right back
Literally
All right, I just need to drop this off so I can have feel no, I'm not the book
I'm not the birth. I want the bank. I'm trying to see if I can do it through the ceiling
I can't
She's never coming back. I'm coming back. I just need to bank the banker
There there there. See look empty. Look. I'm already running back. I'm running out of stamina. It's okay. I'm a wee bit tired
I'm getting a wee bit tired 45
stamina
Oh
I'm coming back. I'm coming back
We're orphans. No
It can't be you can't be you can't be so look look look I'm back. Look who's that? Who's that?
That's right. I'm on the other side of the water. Boom
I'm coming to pick up that trout that's on the floor there because there's tons of the renaissance of the fire as well
See we have no home see like I'm literally right here
Is there so dramatic? See if all the trout
I'm max a leveling up
I'm going to pick up all the ones on the floor
It's better to drop the trout. It's faster to drop it. Um
Who it's who dares the spots picking up? It's faster to drop the trout than it is to trade me
Right. Okay. Full inventory
We're going to be in the 50s after this. There's no way we're not
What were you doing with all those people in the business?
Dropping trout
Trout oh
Oh, pardon me trout
trout
The fish trout
You don't need to see the tea at the drop
There's loads of words that fail like that
Can't believe it
Check your xp per hour on the bar
Uh
Why is it not displaying?
Those i'm cooking cooked 92 93 per hour burn 23 burn rate
Cooking though
It's not like telling me literally level 20. It's not like telling me. Why is it weird?
Hmm
Okay, it's short for trousers
Uh, oh this one. Oh now we're talking hold on let me drop all these
It says for not fishing cooking. Where is cooking? Where's cooking?
Here cooking is purple. Why would it be purple honestly?
All right, let me grab the all these trout. There's like so much on the floor honestly
I
Can't keep up there's so much
It says I'm gaining 2000 xp per hour
Oh, there's trout trout trout trout no the trout not the fire
Now I've got a fill inventory
Wow, all right, let's see
xp gained 16 hour roughly 2k but it's probably going to go up for a bit because I'm not being doing fill trout and
xp left
Oh, no, it's getting covered up by the freaking layer
I'm coming back in we're at barbarian village at the free play fishing spot
But I think we're definitely higher. Yeah, this is going up
It says we're now 2.3 per hour because we've not done it for an hour but
Once we have it says actually I don't even see that
Of course not it says like it literally says like six actions left and then we've leveled up so
That's really good. I like that and kind of puts into perspective like how much you need to do in order to get next
You can write literally level 33 you can reset
That's the only burnt to all burnt three that time
They don't look burn three that time. I'm so MLG pro
Well, I shouldn't maybe drop the
I don't know when I can start cooking salmon, but it should be sent to him
She needs that raw fish meat. Are you treating me fish?
Oh
Oh, no, I don't have inventory for that. Is that tuna? I'm pretty sure that's tuna
Sorry, I don't have any. Oh, you're giving me three tuna. I don't even think I'm like leveling enough to do that
What are you use tuna on the fire?
Oh, I can oh, it's not channel. What is it is channel?
Oh burnt it
It's 100 xp. Wait, that's more xp than salmon
Okay
Reset it seems to have bugged out. Okay, I'll reset it. Sorry
Oh, I know it's not the bomb. Oh, you can actually see it though
Tuna max and right now man's running. I just realized that you and my definition of fun are completely different
I mean, I'm literally becoming a little chef. I'm able to feed all the reeflings like this now
I
Be getting all the things. Oh, this is have nine actions left. That's so cool that it says like you literally have a number
Because soon it will be like a hundred left and then I'll be a thousand left now. But like that's fine
Her numbers are going way up
Literally, this is like if you like slow and incremental games that feel satisfying
Runescape is definitely for you
Yeah
I've never 99 something
And I want to do it and you guys can hold me accountable for it
I'll let you tuna max. I'm sorry. Who's got trout for me. No, that's cooked trout. That's raw trout. Okay. Oh wait
Is this except ready? You got more tuna. It's the tuna man
Of course, it's fun numbers goes up dopamine. We all get literally
Wow, thank you so much for the tuna
Oh
How is everyone today someone asks?
We're uh, we're tuna max. Uh, no, not sure. Oh, oh, I was talking
Are you squidding me right now, Brian?
We love when number go up. So have some number. Oh
Money's different. Thank you for the tip. Don't stay down
We do love money going up and incremental video games
We're playing cooking sim and it's amazing
hope
Hope your day is going well smiley facie. We always be nice to people
I am burning the absolute living daylights out of this tuna. I'm so sorry. I've just wasted all that tuna
So sorry
I have been here for like four hours
Oh, I keep messing it up. I wonder if you could sell kuchina for decent money. I don't think it's a cheap fish
I seem to think like all right raw trout time
Uh fishing levels, uh, um
What the fuck runes get message saying I'm going to be logged in 30 minutes max six hours play. Wait, is that real?
Wait, you got more tuna already. Wait, you can't have
I
How are you doing?
Are you peddling tuna to me to level me up faster? I feel like I'm wasting all your tuna
Oh, no
Wait, are we finally doing it? Are we are we got tuna slave runners?
Yes, like there was log is real
Wait, am I gonna be booted out or because I bought membership? I'm not gonna be booted out
I have plenty of tuna. I could literally buy a million
Hey, scrawny, am I in trouble for cooking my own food tonight? Does that mean I could just jump into the kitchen? You're allowed to make it
He that is messed up. I'm not a child literally why is the game doing it for a bandwidth issues
If you're a free member, they're like, oh, we've had enough of you
Strawny becomes a master chef, but can't fight a rat. No, it was the cow that was going to kill me. It was a baby cow
And you just log in right back after
That's bizarre. No, I mean, what?
Well, it says we've been up for seven hours or is it because I got logged out when I went away for like a cup of tea in that
I wonder if that's why
Hold on
Is tuna max is tuna max were there?
I've got booted out at one point. Yeah, you've just been dc in a lot. Okay. Every time I go for tinkle winkle
I've been dc'd so it doesn't count
How much do you care about doing the proper way? Um, I think I'm supposed to do wine next someone says hi, emmy
Is the emmy imposter here
Where's the emmy imposter?
Oh, there it is
You changed your name to emmy visa and game level 113. That's a big account. Honestly
Okay, let me grab this
Emmys emmy's a RuneScape nerd
No, it's not the real embers, but someone likes her so I'm glad someone enjoys her as much to do that
Emmy the goat honestly, what's the fit on emmy? Oh, they changed her hair to look like her pumpkins and everything
Give her a skirt. That's supposed to be her blue shorts
Okay, okay
Where is that
We're already level 35. Oh, we should have came here like from the beginning. We didn't even have had to do anything
Yeah, and that baby cow has been caught for a cake
Hydration check I'm actually running out of water
What's mercy one hour
Wow
It gives me like relief drinking water for a millisecond and then I feel the pain of talking again
Let's breathe this raw trip
Raw trip
Oh, sorry, I keep forgetting mr. Tuna man. I apologize
I got like three three space
That tuna man going ham oh my god, that's so much money
Absolutely nothing and then the value on your side is just like losing horrifically
You
I can do one more inventory and then I have to do some room craft from from my clan skull the week. Okay. Thank you so much
Excuse me, man. We had to level up to 20 fish and to start fishing here. Yes. You have to go back to
Uh, the castello. Good luck. Thank you so much for the
Thanks for all the fish. I'm pretty sure that is the ending to a movie
That bill bull was in that haven't watched yet
Um, I can't remember big ones. Thanks for all the fish
Level 36. Oh my god, tuna literally a hundred a pop as well is crazy
Keeps in the bunny suit girl turn into a guy on a remain
It's because they're
Dancing on each other hitchhikers guys. Yes. I've not seen that
Good lord. You're so live. Yeah, we're tuna max and we're currently level 36
And cooking it's that purple one right there
here
We're level 36 apparently your xp per hour is like freaking 56k with the tuna. It's like going off like crazy
So much tuna
You know, it's really nice tuna cucumber meal
Like uncrusted bread. Oh, no, that's delicious
Can we cook for all salmon yet? Let me check use the salmon on the fire
With everyone's opinion on anchovy pizza. Oh, I can cook salmon. Okay. I can pick up salmon now as well
Right, I'll pick up salmon and trout so I can just like do it all
Level 50 is about 100 k xp total
Oh, it's my total xp
I am one fourth of the way to level 50. I'm not sure I can do it before mercy goes online
Oh, I'll be cutting it close. I think
Oh, no, I can I would have to be tuna maxing unless the salmon does it. I'm not sure
Unless the salmon does it
And if I stop burning everything
I'm scooping up all this truth
I'm scooping it up my inventory's getting so full
Someone's got a mini cliff
No, but that is huge
Hey
It's so fast with the salmon as well
Oh five more salmon and then level up again
Oh, come on. You can do it
Two more one more
Yes
30 freaking six
Hey 37. Sorry. I know numbers sometimes
Oh
We are tuna maxing. We are fish maxing out the wazoo right now
Johnny you can do this Johnny
Cook this scale as they start to like there's neither motor
We're gonna do it. We're gonna do it
A tuna is more xp than salmon. Salmon's more xp than trout
But I'm fortunately I'm still at the burning stage. So I'm not like maximizing my inventory right now
I
Can't I don't think there's any other quests that give cooking xp that I know of other than there's probably a ton of members quests
That do have like cooking xp
um
But as it stands right now
We'll do full inventory roster
But once we start once we stop burning then we can do like max inventory
xp gains, which is really
handy-dandy
It took me a little bit of salmon. It's taking my troop. You need my troop
Salmon might honestly be better rates when you factor in the burn rate. Mmm
It's possible
Someone else here is like syncing up the salmon, which is fine. Honestly, it's not like the trout is like bad or anything
I know we'll make it to 40 question is how far in
True mummy gaming here honestly click simulator, but it's so good though. Like runescape's on a scourge
Oh
Look it's like I love how that rune plug in or whatever it's called rune light literally absolutely annihilate now here
Salmon success rate at 38 is 74 percent. Mmm. That's not bad
Every one in four
Okay, who has the exhale spreadsheet an optimal fish cookin
The best members quest for it is the family crest so you get gloves that were just burning. Oh, I've never done
I don't know what that is actually
It sounds difficult though because for something to be such a good item
I feel like they would have put it behind like really difficult quest
Oh, if I can pick up a few of these salmon, what may I do for them?
Rune light is insane. I can never play with a vanilla client again
Get mugged
Suppose if you want like super nostalgia, you just leave it as a
Right, we'll do the trout first because I want like I don't want to
Have higher rate of burning the salmon since it offers more
Do you just stream forever strong?
Um, I just really enjoy streaming and I like hanging out with refunds
Especially on days where we get to play a multiplayer game where we get to be together. I really like that
Um, I'm actually going off a bit earlier than expected when maricy comes online in an hour. I'm raiding into our
And the only reason I'm not doing an endurance today. Hmm is because my voice is very sore
Um, and I have an ASMR stream tomorrow, so I'm gonna have to try and rest it a bit better than
than usual
than the huge
When again is this old
Um
Yes, if my voice wasn't sore, I unironically just do 12 hours again. I'm sorry. I would I said it
I said what we're all thinking you all know. Oh, oh no. I didn't cook those raw salmon
Silly billy. Oh, no, it's giving me the actual salmon. Oh, hello
I'm not salmon maxing. I'm not a real salmon max. So I can't believe it. I'm sorry. You had to all find out this way
Let's do trout
We're doing we're getting pretty good at trout. We're getting pretty good
Over eight hours not jerks. Come on. Nice. I don't know. I feel like
You know when you have like a regular nine and five job like obviously I had quite a few
And I just put it in a perspective like I'm literally memeing about in a video game
I get to like play and like have fun times with you
And it just like
Oh my god, wait, is this tuna man back? Hold on. Is tuna man back tuna?
I thought you had to go do some things with your clan or something
Oh my god, we're tuna maxing again. Oh
Half a million. Are you sure? I mean, I ain't going to say no. How are you all so rich?
Where are you? What are you doing to make money in runescape? What are the ways to
Buy some good fish with it. Thank you
Reef bling. Oh my gosh when the time comes. Yes, when I when I don't burn stuff
How I have three billion on an iron man account. How do you make money in runescape? Seriously?
Tuna man, how
How do you make money on runescape? I don't know how I'm going to put this money in the bank
So I'm not full
The more you play the higher stats you get raid strongy get
Get hella high level so we can do raids
Oh
What's raiding?
Oh, you guys teach me how to raid international bank of strongy honestly though
Oh, I wanted to get a pet that looked like you guys as well. That was another goal. So 99
um
99 um
Cookin and then I want to get a pet that looks like you guys, but I don't know how the pets work
Golly, okay
I'm going to go put this in the bank. No visit
Math wants to chase math. I don't have much inventory. I'm sorry
Oh, yeah, give me them sardines you're giving me
Oh, oh, yeah, we got pike ladies and gentlemen. Get that cooked get that cooked on that fire. Thank you
Get that cooked. Oh
Oh made me 39 economic dragon bitter
Not to be confused with the german word bitter, which means please
The bitter no, I don't think that's what that means in german
Also, high level drops peaking. No, I couldn't do peaking. Oh, I'm coming back. Don't worry reeflings. I'm coming back
I'm mummies. Mummy's putting the money in the bank. I'm coming back. Okay. Mummy needs to pay rent. So I'm putting in the bank
We need to rent that location out for only us
A bitter means please. Okay. No reeflings don't cry. I'm coming back. Sorry. I forgot to say that I needed to go
I'm putting this in the bank. Okay. Look bank
And look at that we're max
Look how much fish we've got
200 raw ship
600 salmon
450 swordfish 500 lobsters raw tuna. Like there's so much. I don't want to burn any of this though
Bitter means you are welcome. Oh, thank you. Sean. That's it. Okay. There we go. There's a sense that you could use them
I don't know. Thank you. Thank you. Sean or thank you. Sean. No, I think as a
Huh
Don't worry reeflings. I'm coming back. Look see I'm coming. I'm coming
Look look look you're gonna render again. Yay reeflings. All the reeflings are here
You've got money to burn all that fish. You're loaded. Holy literally a reefling gave me 10 million
Another gave me a million one. Just give me half a million there
But I don't want to like I don't want to waste it. I don't want to waste the money
Oh
Sorry, sorry. I accept
Sorry, I'm fish mixing. Okay. Where's mommy? Mommy's back. Mommy's back
How much xpd get for this? I don't even know you could fish it here
Can't believe someone went
What I can't believe someone went more dry than I did on a dragon sick
Hmm, how much should we get? Oh my god a for these these are the same as fine
We cease to exist when you leave us. No
Bitter means a bunch of things including both. Okay
My German knowledge is expanding
And now to expand my Puerto Rican knowledge
I don't know how many pets I've got. Can you own all the pets that one?
Oh, they're like a little symbol to show what one there's 24 pets
What how?
Hmm
How does there 24 there are 59 pairs? Whoa
That's a lot
Yeah, especially because I've a chain makes an avoid worker jam. Is that how you attract pets to you? You were jewelry
They're ooh shiny. Is there a magpie pet?
Oh
Actually, I've picked the place clean. That's how much I'm fish maxing. There's nothing on the ground. I've picked it clean
Oh wait, there's a trade. Ah, I'm missing
I've got rubbish aimbot. Whoa. Yeah 17 39
All salmon. Oh, we're all in on salmon salmon cook and run. We're almost level 40
40 is like a melody and
Oh, sorry, I just punched them. I can hear that
It's a little animated there
Strongly only just starts you mean she's already a 1% or something
Wait, really is level 40 a 1% thing like no like hardly anyone gets to 40 and something
Shorty's like a melody and I kind of can't keep grow. Got me singing like
Betty days like my eyes. Is it like my eyes porch stuck on the plate?
Those bars were good. She punched the reef line. I'm sorry
There's a fishing pet, but you have to be on a member's world to get it and scaling pets are especially
He means the money
We hit 40 we hit 40
Actually so good
I might make one last cup of tea
We need a lock in
Lobster time. Oh, no, I'm not gonna waste in lobster. That's crazy
I'm not gonna waste
Oh, I mean unless you give me lobsters. That's different
If you give me lobsters to waste that's different. I'm not sure what my freaking rate is gonna be
Burn them all. Oh, I kicked my first one correctly
Wow
Oh, no
They're getting burned. I know you can't see them over my head my heart
Can I move myself over just a tiny bit more?
I don't want it actually. Yeah. Yeah
Okay, yeah, that's better. You can like really see the inventory and stuff
Learning runes keep learning
If all the boys get 40 fishing must the point will be for pure lobs
Wait, you want to do love wait you guys stay up all night
Just so you can get 40 fishing so we can do lobster runs 120 is a lot
Look at the success rate though. Where does it say? Oh the success rate is going up. It's 20 percent
What's that going? Oh, that's my that's my uh
Oh rest well those two sleep. I'm sorry. I streamed so long
Uh, for those of you who do need to leave please don't worry. I'm literally doing this until the end
We're gonna read into mercy because my poor voice is feeling it. Mr. Proud
There's no way you already have more freaking lobsters for me or something
Oh, okay. Okay. We go pick go pick
This is crazy. Can you get in trouble by Jagex for doing this?
I can stay until 40 fish are for lobsters. That's no, that's crazy. I'm at 31 fishing at the moment
Got distracted watching you forgot to go back more
Good night seekers rest well
Then we can see how much seafood you are wasting. No
Oh
I just meant for the lobsters that one
Long streams are good because I can catch them when I wake up. Hmm
I will sleep when I'm when I'm
I'm beat by drowning by more domination achieve
Oh my god, we're almost 41 all freaking Brady. We just were for him
Sleep as a construct construct as a government. I'll never give in
Oh my gosh
Can we do it? Can we make it 41 already?
One more don't burn them. No, don't burn them. She I'm she burned it
40 freaking one
This is so good
Oh my god, you're already trading with me
I hope I can't get in trouble by Jagex for this
Stuff like this can run the game for new players. So be careful about donations
I have played like I do have a basic concept of the game, but like if you're gonna ask me to do like
Dungeoning and stuff. I could not tell you where the gargoyles are, but apparently gargoyles
Hey, stroney, how do you get a fishing rod? I've never tried this before
Oh, I'm your tiny culls. Um
You would have to level up with that fishing net you got from tutorial island, but you can't use it here
You would have to go back to lumbridge
This is lumbridge where you came from you can use the magic spell to teleport and you have to do net fishing here until 20
And then you can come here for a fly fishing
I'm so sorry little reasoning
There are gates to level up on fishing. They're probably a lot better than my method
But that's why I've always used as a kid
Gargoyles are decent money for mid players, but 75 slurs probably the slowest and
That burn rates looking a bit rough on the lobsters. I'm not gonna lie
Anyone got some feathers on them. So well, I guess I'll go great. Oh, thank you little weaklings
That burn rate is looking rough
Oh
About it
How do you sense the lobsters?
I feel like they're probably breaking through here
We're burnt through the fish already. No, we've not I tell a lie
There's freaking who are you coming so fast like
You you just handed me them. Is there a bank nearby?
I thought the bank was over there. Am I going crazy is there a bank up there?
He's just disappeared again. Is there a bank up there?
Ageville has a bank. Oh, I'll make sure you
Call meville because I don't know if I could trade. I'm so sorry. Wait, I'll trade. I'm sorry. I'll trade. I'll trade. I'll trade
Okay, I'll trade I'll trade
I'll trade I'll trade
Bro's hacking
Can you even hack in RuneScape? That sounds like it's nice and possible because of the way the server is
Call meville because I'm edging. Yes. Call meville because I'm edging
Came up with that myself
You could start using a range closer to the bank rather than the fire rate
Since you're not fishing anymore, probably that's very true
Oh, that burn rate is rough on those lobbies
Every lobster that we burn is a missing like 120 which is like so freaking thingy. I lied. I made it
Wait, there's another reef link. There's a judge, right? Hold on
Wait, you've got lobster runs as well
Isn't this not like thousands like thousands of gold? Am I not going mental? I feel like this is like thousands
Go ahead and run energy needs to recharge
Whoa, we got a four streak
Five in a row?
Yeah
It depends on how fast you want to get this level, but our village is more
Inic, the most cooking ranges
You can make a million per hour
A million xp per hour at strony even if they're sizing you have already been given millions
Honestly, if you tape exclamation mark praise what?
Stop did you make me fall for something obvious?
I don't know
Yeah, I spent 160 on 2k that's like two boss kills. Yeah, you have to take that I'm afterwards. Oh
Oh, oh need drop need drop. Oh, yeah, that was a much better lobster cooking batch than the previous one
The other one I absolutely
Oh
All right, okay, take that
Let's try and do this exclamation mark price let all this sit at our
Oh it works
Are there 150 a pack?
Oh, if I buy if I buy feathers from people we drop on okay 300k
Right don't buy any more fish because it's literally I've got
Uh less than 50 minutes now. I'm gonna go quickly grab a bottle of water
Oh
Oh, I hear burning noises because we're burning the fishes right I got a new ball of war
I'm so hydrated, but I don't want to pee. I want to fish max. I need to fish max. You don't understand. I'm fish maxing. You wouldn't get it
I have lobby maxing you wouldn't get it. You wouldn't understand mom. Mom. I need membership
I'll give it a try be back
Gobble
I've only been listening to ASMR for about a minute. So I'm excited for starting ASMR. Wow
I definitely am not the best. I would say like uh mersey and ac really super professional
And we've had a lot of two stacks. Oh, I was about to say we've got two stack for all of the lobbies not being burnt
Spoke too soon there
Hydration check
You
Know as much as the chef hat and the apron are made out of gold. I don't think it's actually making me a better chef
How much longer before you have to leave is the exact time
Mersey is coming on in 45 minutes
I'm gonna redirect into her because I need to do vocal rest before the ASMR stream tomorrow
And it hurts to talk right now, which is a shame. It's literally the only reason I'm going offline
I've probably done during stream every single day if I kill it honestly
Oh, but my voice is sore and I need to be quiet for the ASMR
Uh tomorrow's gonna be a short no you guys are so quick on it
This is crazy
It doesn't make sense. They're gold literally
Doing some nice hot tea. Yes. I've had too much tea to do because I put honey in my tea. It gets like
Sickly if I have too much of it. So I have to swap a water only
What's your target that you're going for this stream? I wanted to get 50, but I don't think it's possible because of time
I didn't realize how fast cooking the fish was gonna be
If I wasn't like doing those quests, but I had fun doing quests for the weasel and so actually I don't really regret at all
It's I'll be cutting it close like if we're literally like a couple of minutes away, then I'll do it
But unfortunately my voice is like
I'm the most I felt that one literally
I do look stylish though. I mean look at that
Oh
Look at the detail in my eyes and everything the polys is favorite all the going
Honey team's good. Maybe add less honey. I don't know. I feel like sickly if I
It's just not working
I know
Um, you can have those throat sweets, but I don't know if they actually do anything
Or just like make my teeth feel a little sugary. It's like my biggest freaking thing. Wait, hold on. Am I taking
I can't remember who I keep taking off all
I'm sorry for whoever the other lobster runners. Like I like I can't remember between
200 k feathers under me. Damn
Damn
Damn, you're in a wedding dress and everything
All of you black hair. This is you and your little cape. Oh, I forgot to get his green capes. Oops. We'll do the next thing
Can you say throw sweets again? Yeah, throw sweets
They like help with your throat when you feel sick or whatever or if you've got strain again
You're still screaming. Yeah, um, we've got roughly 40 minutes and then it's mercy time. We're gonna redirect into mercy
Oh
I'm making an absolute mockery of this one. I think I'm gonna burn there. Yeah over close to the 44 though
Rikola
Wait Rikola
Wait, what's Rikola?
I can hear that Rikola
A tape of throat lozenger. Oh, it's a cough drug. Rikola is a brand
Oh, okay. Oh, sorry
Here you go
Lobster runner, I can't believe it. Might as well do 99 rune crafting while we're at it. You guys will make it super easy
It's the comical jingle that was very common. Oh, it's a commercial jingle. Sorry
I see I see I see
But not ac smoke but I see
There's a new
New rune craft minigame and it's fun
Anyone else? They won't see the feathers yet. No, you might have to pick them up in case it's too much when you despawn
No feathers
Yeah, hopefully they don't despawn because 20k feathers isn't cheap
Did you time this
How long does it take after dolphin? I thought it was 60 seconds
If it's been 60 seconds, I would scoop them back up again because I would hate for them to no not the head buy-ins
Level 40 freaking four
If I could stop freaking burning them lobsters, oh wow
Well, accept trade accept trade
We're getting there though. Do you have less burn chance on a grill thing? An oven? A grill thing
30 seconds to appear to others three minutes to despawn. Hmm. We're learning. We're learning the ways of runes game
You
Know only
Range and fire are the same kissing chance mostly. Okay, there's no point
I was like, maybe we should move this production line
but
And the the reef ones are just fishing away. They're just having a good time
We definitely need to level ourselves up
Because we're we're the target for like a lot of NPCs like when we're trying to travel through areas
So
Streams end in 40 minutes. Does that mean brush teeth intend? Oh, yes. We have to brush your teeth
Okay, thank goodness I didn't make another tea because I wouldn't have been able to brush my teeth
Uh
If you're having if you want to brush your teeth with us
Um for your enamel don't
Eat or drink fizzy juice
You can have water for like the next 30 minutes, but you're not to brush your teeth if you've eaten
after 30 minutes
Because it hurts your enamel that rather than helping it
I think that's my only note if you want to brush your teeth with us
It's not so fun story. My brother once choked on one of those throat sweeps and helped with the throat throat
Oh, that's terrifying
45 45 we're at 61 eight feet. Oh my goodness. We may actually make the 50. You know that
I
Throat farted when I swallowed it. Did you hear that? That was like an internal throat
Strony is the cuttlefish and the reeflings are her arms. Most people think it's like
One in three
Oh
He learned so much from this education on professional streamer that takes me back to the toothbrush and ASMR
We are so gonna get 50 before mercy comes on a mind me funny
Oh mercy is actually I think she's decorating alternative outfits for us
So
We are in
Have our lobster reserves run dry. Have I perished all the lobsters for sale in the grand exchange?
Oh unless unless unless
There you guys are sweating to get me to level 99 you're actually so kind
I just want to say special. Thank you for those of you who are like unironically feeding me
This is gonna make the school way faster doing this
Hmm
You'd say that strong he's a really good drop. What?
Do you think she'd meet you one of those? What?
What's going on? No stops on this lobster train. Literally
I know the fishing spot
Nearly 1 million xp an hour stop is it?
unblockies
I love stories
I suppose if I didn't burn them that's very plausible every stack is like
What 26 inventory?
Like
I think five tables are shooting it. I don't know
With some tick manipulation. I don't know what's the tick rate manipulation stuff means
I hear it all the time though
It's like, oh, you just gotta make sure you do this on the tick and you have to eat
You have to eat the food on the tick. Oh, can I swap out prayer? I need prayer flick. I need a prayer flick
Like I'm like, what does any of this mean?
You're crazy
crazy
Also for those of you using ruin light if you don't want an item name to show up
Can hold all and write the irons
We're getting them
Being an apron has always been a dream of mine
The game runs on 0.6 second increments called ticks. That's it. Oh
That basic okay, that just like explains everything
That's it. That's all it took one one sense and it all makes sense
Okay, because I was like prayer. I need prayer flick on this
Over prayer flail. I'm like, what?
I'm not I'm even sure that's supposed to be having the games played
I don't know did the devs intend that but they never patched it out. So I guess prayer flicking is the right way to go
Because prayer run drains so fast
It's running smart. I'm I'm I'm getting new brain cells just from streaming. Hmm
Level 47
No
Oh wait, sorry
Two more if I don't burn these if I don't burn this one
46 oh my gosh
We're so MLG pro
Look at me bro MLG pro
I'm gonna come he's rumbling if you could hear that over the background
Wow
I'm literally solid
It's not intended but jaguars just accept it
I was gonna say if they didn't whenever like something gets discovered
Like so this is for the overwatch players, but mercy had a guardian angel leak. Um
And
It got discovered and it was never patched out the game which meant it was intended even though it was never described
So that's how I take it if the devs don't patch it out
It's allowed basically
Once you get to level 92 you're halfway there. Yay
Anyway, congrats dumb dumb. This was the stream I was looking forward
The list ended up probably being one of the funniest really
It's just me receiving like tons of in-game currency for doing nothing
Yes, but please don't worry if you're interested in a more like multiplayer games where we can play together
Um, I definitely am doing like a whole variety of things going on. Um
I would definitely like other ones like um
Jail, no, that's not its official name. What's the name of the game? Uh fall guys
Um, I wanted to give fortnite a chance apparently fortnite. Um has added like different game modes
Um, uh call of duty has apparently introduced prop hunt. I don't know if we could oh, there's a captain
Do we do the captain mini one mini quest?
I don't know if we do the captain one
At the fortnite
metal path
I just shit out my head
It's
Is it bad?
Is it a bad quest?
Is it the captain or is it a good one?
It's quick. Okay, if it's quick, let's try it
Problem is these old time, uh, sure. I'll help you unlock your chest
There are three columns. What you need to do is match up each picture
on the column
A bar a ring and a bowl
Oh got a wee golden ring
Um
What I do would it I already have a diamond ring on from a reefland so I can't take off
Oh, I'm sorry. Sorry. I completely forgot we're trying to lobster max right now. Oops
Uh one one life space because I I'll drop the golden ring
Oh, I could have gave you the golden ring actually because
lobsters trading there the rings your problem now
Captain is the worst random no the sign which lady is she never gives you anything good
Hail divers molly player. Is that easy to say?
Well same which lady and chris master
Chris master is rubbish. I don't like that one
Uh for strutty, please don't play for tonight. Oh, no, what's wrong? It's bad game
I
Get that still but yeah, I think it's kind of drop in drop out
Um, I would like to play among us so I can start screaming at you and I'll be like it's red it's red wavelength
You don't believe me. It's red
But we'll have to we'll have to try and see what happens
Okay
Okay, I'm done
I'm so I'm so emoji look at me like I'm literally hover and ready for the trade offer like yeah
Yeah, give me the trade offer. Oh look your problem now. There you go. Oh your problem now
There you go all yours golden rings yours. Thank you for all the lobsters
I
Among us
You've never played among us deep rock galactica
We can play deep rock together
Can I force you guys to play that mains of maria game with me?
I'm too scared to ask the girls to play in case they absolutely despise it so
Although I may be able to convince she be
There's a mains of mario game. It's like it's literally deep rock galactica, but lord of the rings could it
You want to try warframe is freeing up to four man squads. Oh
I think you can force us to do anything you want to try
I
Haven't ever heard of it and never got advertised well the only reason it popped up for me is because
I'm on lord of the rings side of tech talk
So if there's anything lord of the rings lord that the rings related
Oh my god, we're gonna level up
40 freaking seven
Oh my gosh
This is getting insane xp game oh crap
Thank you. Thank you reeflings. I appreciate it. Literally everyone feeding to me. We're all like fishing away leveling up and stuff
Um, I think we'll play
RuneScape during
Uh on the third week of streams, I think they'll might we'll might do a double runescape to make sure we really get there xp
wise
I'll break it up in between the week just so it's not like a full day of runescape and then one right after it
Because I know runescape isn't for everyone. I know it might be a bit um
Of a snooze fest, but for me it's so satisfying like
Not bigger number
Bigger number big number big number big number
Like it's like really good for me
But I guess maybe watching it. It might be better. Like if it was a compilation or like a highlight, you know
Still do warframe. It's the worst game to be a new player and 100% confusing and there's a neat tutorial
Deep rock season five is a bit of a horror show right now
Number go up
RuneScape is definitely a talking stream like a datzu like back and forth. I like memeing with one each other
I'm like learning about the game and stuff
I don't know enough about runescape. Literally. I like I I wasn't kidding when I said like the best I did as a kid was like
Do cooking and then like probably like do 40 and then that's the best like I actually don't know how the game works
So much lobster rock lobster
Dumb
Uh b52 is anyone
The reefing
Is could you trouble you to play voices of the void? I don't know what that is. Is that an mmo or like single
Or what what kind of game
This reefing is deep one
final fantasy 14
I was gonna give it a shot
um
But yeah
I never ended up playing it
I don't know if it's I don't know if they say the role play a lot on it
honestly
I don't mind
It'll be fun to role play
A role play is what
I don't know what
Oh, wait, sorry
Save heroes is free to play
Super hero animal. Oh, I think I said I wanted to play Marvel rivals
We might play that but I don't know if it's in beta beta beta beta
Um, or if that's it fully out. I don't know. Oh my tummy's wobbling
I don't know what to do
Stroney and our 100 husbands isn't this the life though
You know, you have to wait to get your one-on-one attention
But then that makes it so much more worth it. Why did I keep freaking snail blinking? I'm gonna have to change that
Please stop blinking one at a time
I'm gonna have to make this sensitivity
different
any
interest in trying lord of the rings online
I
Like
Shadow and what lord of the rings online? You mean elven scrolls online or is there like a lord of the rings online?
I have no idea about
I'm actually playing final fantasy while watching the stream speaking facts cannot disagree
I work in accounting and I'm the only guy with nine girls and that was a
What ladies man, check you out. You get a nice view all day long
There's a lord of the rings. Maybe I've seen it and I'm just being a dumb dumb
I can't recall it off the toilet in the head
Should I move I feel like I'm like in the way here. Oh, I can't even access the fire. Oh
I can't even access the fire
Dumb dumb. Oh, sorry. I'm already accepted
It's pretty old. Does lord of the rings online still even have server? Yeah, I don't even
I don't even think I've seen any gameplay of it
Unless I have and my brain's just not putting them two together
171 successful cooks to go. Not sure how many include in burning. So probably 10 more trips
Wow
We're at 81,000
XP on cooking we need 20k more wins mercy 20 minutes on mercy. I don't know
If we could stop burning
There's no way you're still head banging over there. Are you not tired of clicking the button?
Finally lord of the ring is microtransaction to heck. Okay, that's probably why I haven't heard about it because everyone just saw how much of a grab it was
I lost my little face. Yeah, maybe I am maybe I'm just head banging
I mean barb village is it? Yeah, I don't I we might maybe do like a watch along of stuff
and
For like the later levels oh 48 man
That's so good. I literally I was aiming for 40 and I'm like so happy with what we've got
Obviously special shout out to the reeflings who are supplying a ridiculous amount of money and fish and everything to me
Because it is insane
And literally the reeflings down here that are just chilling and fishing away there
They're just having a good time leveling up fishing
What are your fishing levels? Hold on. Let me type fishing level check
Fishing level check
I'm still struggling early game fishing and cooking south of lombardy shrimp
It takes forever to net some shrimp and then you burn them to heck
If you guys want to catch up to her, I'll give you what I have left after stream
Out of curiosity, are you avoiding profanity for any reason?
a little bit the ai
Can tell like the ai can read what my voice is so I kind of try and swap out words over time
um because I am quite
Outrageous at certain sections, so I try and tone it down as long as you get like a good 80 to any like mix
Then overall you're fine, which is why I swap out words sometimes
I have enough eggs to be for night night twice unfortunately
Little reeflings cute surprise of the stream
Oh we keep burning them
Ah
Oh lobbies you're not as easy to cook as I I thought my little my caviar
Yes, I maybe need to think of like maybe we watch movies and that whilst we runescape in the background or something
I mean I can do set up watch one movie
And obviously I can't show it back and show the timer so as we jump in at any point
Maybe harry potter. Do you guys like harry potter?
I've watched it through for the first time
A couple years back. I'm not doing the full thing not okay. Maybe not. Sorry. Sorry. Maybe not. Maybe it's the girls movie. Apologies
Is there a see John wick series? We'll watch the John wick series
Movies that would be a good one
Hmm, I think everyone who's ready for runescape and chill honestly John wick runescape and chill
I'll put down the sound of the game like really low and we'll just watch the movie and it's just me going
In the movie and then every time I level up I also go
The first three movies of harry potter is pretty comfortable. Yeah, I guess really dark at the end which I don't
You could do a pool on which movies. Yeah
Uh just because of how long
Like the grains are I would kind of want to do series movies and um
John wick has three installments. I'm pretty sure which is why I quite like that
Hmm
What about shrek? Oh, I don't like the leader shirt. Is it shrek happily ever after?
John wick has four
Have I seen the fourth one? I might know you haven't seen the fourth one. I don't know there's a fourth installment
Huh
I have a silly idea. What's your idea? Hmm. You have me curious speak your truth
Stroney, how do you feel about spider-man movies?
You want to watch the original spider-man's like the toby mcguire?
Spider-man so we can all have a gig a lot of the dancing
Toby mcguire is my spider-man
I remember it like a freaking babbling and watching the movies practically
Yeah, the fourth the final chapter is the fourth. Oh, okay, okay, okay
Stroney, did you know that lord of the rings trilogy lasts less than one of your endurance streams?
I'm saving myself. I'm saving myself for the lord of the rings on christmas day
I am abstaining from such beautiful literature
Uh, such beautiful media that was created for human consumption
Um, so
We're not gonna watch them
for this
The sam remi trilogy. Yeah, spider-man 3
I don't think I saw that one. I didn't see any of the spider-man's that have emma stone in it
But I watched spider-man
We're all three of them. We're in the same movie
And toby was like, yeah, it just comes out of my wrist and the other two were like, huh?
Because I couldn't believe it because I think the new
Oh, I'm really bad with people's names. The new spider-man has to use nanotechnology from iron man to get his gunk out
Um, I don't know what
Garfield
Honestly, any of the spider-man movies views are great. Okay
49. Oh my gosh 49 just popped feels good, man
Tom Holland. Aye, his name's Tom Holland
I sing the praises of the apocrity diaries to anyone who will listen. Is it movie?
I'm not heard of it. If it's a game or a movie
Oh, my tummy's so hungry
But I can't make food. I must grind. I must fish max. We are fish maxing
We hitting 50 before mercy before I think so
We are like blasting through these levels. It's crazy
0.7 of the weight of 99 let's go
Oh, I read apocrity novel
Aren't there like seven Highlander movies?
It's mad max a one-off movie. I think so
That new mad max I think is good
The one that was like witness me and he puts spray can on his teeth
That one's pretty good
Those one-off movies are oh, sorry. I just click I miss click. Oh, sorry. Sorry the grind the grind, please
The lobster maxing. I can't do it if I'm all miss clicking
It was a miss input miss input
Fury road was one
XP waste no, don't bully me over my xp wasting
It says I need 54 cooks and I've got 5th level 50 if I can stop burning them. Maybe two more inventory's of lobbies
Oh, maybe two we can do it into
We're
If only I know how many hours I spent bank standing. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry
I
Think your ping may be blessed
Get that fire on get that fire on get that lobby on the fire
Not the miss input
Blade runner. Oh, that's a good suggestion
I thought about
because of the rile ryan
Gosling ryan gosling
But I don't know why that was so hard to say ryan because of the ryan goslin movies
I thought it would be funny if we did like a six girl watch along of it like all six of us watching it
And then whenever ryan comes on screen all of us can be like, oh, that's literally my refling
That's literally my like fleeting heart. That's literally my snippet. That's literally my pinpal
Oh
I'm on world 380
At barbarian village. Unfortunately. I'm literally about to go off in 13 minutes rip because mercy is coming online
And literally oh my god, that's my refill a bit. Oh my god. My roof was so strong
I'm gonna just be like complimenting you the entire stream
Okay, it says 34 more lobsters. Okay, this time two more inventories. I'll do it because I can't stop burning these lobbies
That goes like literally
I wouldn't mind rewatching the blade runner because I didn't like fully comprehend it
I'm at first
So it'd be nice to like see again kind of mildly knowing what happens
Have you watched seven cycle path?
Movie before no, I haven't I'm not sure what that is that gosling
literally
Can't wait to see us all together again
Can't wait as well. We've got our first group collab and then we've got our one-on-one collabs coming out soon tm
Um, so I'm I'm a see can I please stop burning these lobbies, please?
Um
I think you said a little bit before we're a little bit limited on multiplayer games that we can all play together
So I think I will encourage like some trio collabs or quad man collabs at some point
and
But uh
It'll be fun to see everyone's like dynamically with each other
I hope no one's scared of me
Stranny smells. How dare you
How do your accusations? I smell like burnt lobster
burnt shrimp burnt trout
burnt salmon burnt pike
I smell like burnt everything because I can't stop freaking messing up
I need to kick 13 lobsters in the snatch and I level up
And I burn three in a row. Of course when I say that four in a row
That's more like it
Trying to upset me video game
working
I saw the fish she's handling
I
Looking forward to main crash shenanigans. Yeah, that's in july july shenanigans
I'm not beating the burning
Eating strong. He's burnt food same way up. Oh, no, those are carcinogenic. You're not supposed to eat burnt any kind of food
Wait, why did she smell like fish? We're the ones who question. Oh, we did it. We're 50
We actually did it. No way mercy's up in 10. Oh, no, we got 50. That's insane. Thank you so much. Really crap
Wow
And that was like messing about questing as well and all that
I
Look forward to less burning and maybe so congrats on his food
I hope I'll stop burning. Oh my god. I'm so MLG pro at cooking fish
I'll send the cringe
It says the values 2.3k for that batch of lobsters
I thought lobsters were a money maker
Okay, well, I hope see you play old school again. Yeah, um, we're playing it
We'll play it once next week on week two and then we'll play it twice on week three
Um during the week, but I'll split it up just in case because I know that runescape isn't the most interesting
Not anymore with all the bots
Maybe the bots aren't so bad after all
Controversy you can't say that you can't say that
They wear a really long time ago. I'm wondering if that's one remember like I used to think they're so expensive
Bots keep the lobsters cheap
I'm wondering
like how the economy in runescape would look if
bots
Were like completely forbidden like if they managed to like completely eradicate them
I'm wondering if it would be an uproar because everything would get so expensive
You know
Curious curious
We're learning we're learning
Stony iron man win. Oh good luck with that. Are you joking?
Isn't it's hardcore iron man. You can't use buying iron man is war
You lose everything when you perish
Sorry
I feel like it would probably like
Been working on a mech and ac6 for whatever you get on that
Ultimate iron man no bank hardcore lose stats when that yeah
Are you serious? Do you know how much money I've made today? That's 20 million
No way. I've been given 20 million
Hello
Don't people like spend like actual real world currency to get this kind of going
Gold and coin together is going just like you should know
I'm putting this in the bank. Wait. You said there was a bank up here. Hold on
Hold on. Mommy's going to the bank. She'll be back in a second. There's a bank up here
Is that one of these buildings? That looks like a ruined building
I'm getting scared. I hope I don't get attacked. You have what level are you people identify yourselves?
Okay, no, I must be off of it. Oh, wait. Wait. I see banker booth. We found it
We were finally in edgeville. This is where I was born
Right, let's get this money nice and safe and tidy in here because oh my gosh
Hey leather gloves, can I put that on is that gonna like add to my defense? Oh my gosh leather gloves. That's what I needed
No, I'll check it out. Oh my god. I'm starting
Whoa, that's right. Whoa, they're bend at my arm is that's amazing
We did it we did it
All right, let me come back briefly. No, don't cry. Don't cry. Look over and you're crying. No, don't cry. I'm right here
I'm just stunning on the bank because I'm really scared
I didn't even know there was a freaking thing up there. Well, now I know there's a bank up there
I am expanding my runescape knowledge
Wow, okay. Okay, we're here
I think I might need to
Can I get level 51? Whoa, wait a minute. Can I even cook these?
Can I cook surface?
I can what did they get all burnt out?
It says I have to cook 56 swordfish to already level up again
Wait, it's taking down two. It's just 50. It's literally going down by two 48
47 wait
Is that a chef? It is it's a golden chef hat and a golden apron a reefling literally gave me it
Just I doing something
You should be able to buy enough materials for nine and cooking with five million coins alone
I've got well, I've got 20 we might as well go flinching while we're at it. Will we do crafting?
She's not me becoming a runescape player overnight
Like a runescape skillar, sorry
Oh my goodness that swordfish isn't seen we're at 31. Yeah, it's like recalculating as you guys say
It's trying to do the math, but
That's insane
How much is it on the ground for swordfish it's 4k for that lot
It seems like a shame that I'm kind of wasting that but
Oh
Even more
Goodbye those who have to go
Yes, please don't worry if you have to go now
I'm about to raid in some mercy to give myself a vocal rest before I do ASMR. I believe it's tomorrow
And then it's the sweet stream
Yes, um, so please don't worry if you have to go. Um, I'm literally just cooking away
Um an experience in swordfish xp
I sent for scottish anime women
Thanks for something for me. I sent for replays
Unfathomable progress honestly. Oh, yeah, buy out those stats. Yeah, we don't get it
Rest well rest well
I also shrimp for her. Oh, yeah, you shrimp for me because I'm a I'm a sea fish
I'm a sea animal so you shrimp for me
Oh, we're head banging away
I'll wait the ride I'll ask mercy to put bad jokes written all over your new clothes design
I'm so curious what she comes up with like so so curious
Oh my god, we're 110
kxp for cooking
Oh
That's just some reason
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, and there's more where it came from
Not gonna lie to be part of that army if I played runescape at all
Someone was like, oh, yeah, start up a guild and I'm like, I don't I've never done it. I don't even know how to do it
Well, we'll just play is free free agents if you will we're free agents free reefing
We sent for each other a circling of simps if you will
Shrimping hard
The amount of progress is only possible with an army of shrimp
My little shrimpers
Oh fine. I guess you are my little shrimpers
Don't guild members get exibus. Do they? What for like raise?
Like streams to help I'll go watch mercy and runescape schedule. Yeah
51 on day one 51
That is it insane progress
Insane
Day one level 51 brah
brah
And that's with doing like free quests and stuff together
I'm wondering if we like just
sent it
We're just dead
Wait, you're both doing swordfish as well
You guys said now lobbies isn't enough. We've had enough for lobsters. You're gonna you're gonna sell them on
You sell them back into the the grand exchange economy
We don't need sleep and we have oh, I hope you guys are sleeping well. We got you literally
I hope you guys are sleeping well. I've had a few days without sleeping. I guess brah, I guess dangerous
Hydration
Hmm, it's 1 p.m. Is mercy on
Wait, hold on. I'm gonna need to make sure I'm redirecting
Hold on shiny. Oh, no. No mercy more these future channel. I need the link
Nope, that was her yesterday stream. Don't be silly Billy
Oh, she's not live yet. So it's upcoming. Oh, don't wait 100 foot 20. Oh wait, I'll wait
She's I'll wait until she's live to confirm the redirect
I'll wait until she's live to put the oh, she's literally just went live. No way
That was so that's such good timing. Hold on. Let me let's do what if we just kept cooking
I don't know
My voice is scoffed like it's scoff the unbelief. I can't remember
I
Can't I want to rest for days tomorrow
Is there going to be any scripts? Are you doing freestyle? I might do some scripted stuff
uh, like at the start or like
freezes or certainly paragraphs
um
This woman needs to rest her voice don't encourage her bad habits lmao
Right, let me make sure I'm redirecting into the stream
No, I'm going to make the big boy decision
And rest my voice as much as it pains me
Because I do want to lobster. Sorry. I want a swordfish max
Right, let's do
That okay
Okay, she's still loading so I have stalling time. Okay
She's still loading in the loading screen so I can stall
They'll never know
They'll never know they'll never know we're gonna just one more just one more inventory of fish. Okay. Just one more one more, please
Just one more. Just one more. Okay. I'll be good. I'll be a good girl
Just one more, please
Please I'm on my knees
Just one more inventory though
We'll see how much xp we can get. It'll be beautiful. I mean we'll be so close to 52
Are you gonna do the m&m goodbye? What's the m&m goodbye?
Oh, you're in Scottish M&M again M&M again
I
Starting to nod off to a fish and myself use a few more minutes swordfish max and just one more just one more inventory
Please I'm not addicted. I promise just one more inventory full of fishes
Let's do it. Let's do it
What's the m&m thing? A lot of burnt one. Look. I'm trying my best. Okay. It's hard to cook over the fire
There's so the wind keeps blowing in different directions and people keep moving around the fire
So the air flow isn't really doing it. Don't supply her addiction
Get rest or anyone that beautiful acts in the top form. Yes. I will warn and say that ASMR streams are
a lot shorter
Um, but I'll definitely be looking at marshmallows. I'll definitely be looking at some scripted stuff
And you can always submit what you want to say as well. I think you can do like a chat command thing
Just one more inventory. Please one more inventory. I'm not addicted
Just send me just send me the trade request just one more one more one more come on. Send me the trade request
Come on. Come on. You know, you want it. Please please for me send me the trade request
Come on. You know, you have swordfish one
Come on
Give me the swordfish
I
No, wait, don't buckle. Come on. Give in
It's me. It's you're not enabling me. It's just one more
There's no harm in one more batch of swordfish. Come on
We want that
No way, you're not giving me it
No way, you're not giving me it pick up the salmon
No way. I'm getting picked. I'm picking a freaking salmon
You may have to pull it the hypnotize honestly. I'm not addicted. I promise but let's just grab the salmon
We're like so close to 52. Let's make it 52. All right, and we'll redirect into mersey make it 52
Come on 52
Let's cook
Reeflings are cutting you off. I can't believe I'm having to pick up fish off the floor
Stop giving
Stangered gran bloods go up in
She almost became golem. I was cool and gone. What do you want it?
But I can't do it because my voice was this loud. It's so hard
We're almost at level 52
Oh
I'm still burning salmon
Voice folks must heal
Stop being nice to me. Reeflings
Stop looking out for me. I can't are you done snowballing me? You doodoo head. That's all that you doodoo head
Yo, your ball headed is yo, yo, santa
That's all that
I can go offline whenever I want. Okay
Will you expect brief will you accept briefings instead of fish?
It depends what am I allowed to do with you, huh?
Do you offer me some experience?
Right we're so close to 52 we're so close we're too close
How much exp is a reefing room? It depends that I get your boy cherry or not
I have much exit. Yeah, try cooking one. Oh, they're not dropping any
There's no fish on the floor to cook
I have a pump in the ground who got to pump it up. You got to know there's no fish on the ground
I can't even brand up to 52
If you're close you can start next stream on a good note of leveling up
I'm not addicted reefing. Just give me the sword fish. Look. Come on. Let's go to the bank together
Look, we're going to the bank. I just need one more batch of swordfish
Give me the swordfish
Look, we're literally bank maxing right now
Come to the bank in edgeville. I'll take you to edgeville. Look. Here's the bank. It's so pretty
Just one more batch of swordfish
Let me in
Or lobsters or anything or even south
I I'll do it myself. Where's the banker?
I'll do it myself because because some other reeflings were kind enough to give me all the salmon
I'm taking this salmon. I'm taking it away. Stinky reeflings not giving not feeding my fish addiction
Strani, you have a problem. I don't I don't
I'm it's called fish maxing. You've never heard of it
Oh, I just accidentally opened up a thing. Oh, why did that open up in another browser?
Where the heck is the fish? Have we gone past it? Oh, no, it's here. Sorry
Yeah, we're gonna level up. Oh, hold on. Hold on in boat in boat need in boat
Work. Okay, there we go. We'll be level 52 and then we'll redirect into America
Gonna have to send you up to the 12 step program in a minute
Stinky, how do you I'll have you know I'll be the least once a week
I just show real this morning how I washed away. Oh my good
Strani, you need therapy. Who is that other personality so similar? Go
Those rosy sweet
All I wish to catch a fish
There I did it 52
Yippee, I'll finish my inventory and then I will call it there
You can literally do this any other day. You have to control your screens
Okay, I'm going I'm going I'll go rest. I just need to finish the inventory. Okay
You're lucky. There's no fish down here. I've grabbed something
Put the fire out don't there's a pair of my fire
No, wait, what are you gonna give me more? I don't know. I think I need to go and I want to go
I need a rest of life
Wait, you made me walk all the way to get that salmon when you have freaking in your inventory. Give me it. Give me give me
No way, no way
Okay
As I was saying, I'm not addicted. I just need one more
I had lots of fun too. It was amazing
The story how many hours have you been listening to the song? I don't know. It's good like it's nice. I like it
Mercy's gonna end up reading in the story
Okay, I won't do anymore. We will read into mercy because that's not fair and we can all watch mercy designers
I don't know what she's gonna do guys. Just one more level. I swear
We will play runescape again next week
Um
And then on week three we'll play it during the week to give people a chance to work on weekends
A chance to join in through the day
Sure get a prayer level here or five bones
She's gonna draw you in a swordfish costume at this rate
I haven't played it in a long time, but it's kind of fun doing the quest with everyone
Are they today? Oh, I'm so glad you managed to join in on the quest. We'll definitely do quest next time as well
Um, I don't know what the next quest is that's easy as to do
So Johnny's gonna turn off stream and keep no I want to achieve everything on stream
Literally not even a bit of fish xp, right as you I'm gonna close the game. Okay
As you guys watch me log out, you're really gonna hear it log out, but how do I log out without I mean
I think the game saved that last batch, but I'm logging out
I up type bye bye and chat and then I'll close the game you should the music screen will stop
Bye bye
Okay, hold on I need to go
Okay, let's close right I've logged out so you guys can see it
Hold wait a minute. This is literally a preview to my stream tomorrow
Oh, excuse me
You want to swordfish max with me
You want to cook max with me
You want to plant bank run max with me
There that's your hint. Oh, oopsies I'd put
eyes
That's your hint for the ace more stream tomorrow
Hmm, it's your it's your runescape ad jump here by
But yeah, this is your hint to what's happening at the stream tomorrow. I'm gonna be all up in your face
I'm cooking again. Oh, I'm cooked again. Sorry. I got cooking I got cooking on my mind. I wonder why wonder why
Which is I'll see you guys tomorrow for
Some oh wait, where's the audio?
Oh, no, you can't hear the audio they don't all of this
Oh, you can't hear the audio. Oh, well, um
But yes, I'll see you tomorrow
For some ASMR. This is your hint for what the ASMR is going to look like
I'm going to try and raise my voice as much as I can
I'll see you tomorrow. Love you. Wouldn't I?
Yes
And we're gonna have a good
Enjoying just in time for like please enjoy mercy
As best you can
And I'll see you tomorrow and thank you for everyone who managed to stream stay
We already achieved one of my goals, which was stream stay then
And then I'll have missed you already. I didn't even click golf lane. Yeah, I didn't even click the end broadcast
But I'll see you tomorrow
and
ASMR short stream, but fun
Real fun with what I've got planned
Okay, see you tomorrow. We things
Be there or be square. Hopefully I don't think the ASMR is going to get taken down so saying
Living in the future
Okay, bye. Bye. Thank you for hanging. Bye. I go rest my voice. Okay
Hmm
Very filling